welcome to this new Cyber secur course
for beginers 2023 by simply learn in
this course we will understand what is
cyber security reasons to learn cyber
security cyber security jobs and salary
we will also understand in detail about
ethical hacking while learning basics of
cyber security we will cover what is
firewall what is ransomware what is
malware what is SQL injection what is
fishing and much more stay tuned with
the course if you are looking to learn
in-depth about cryptography K Linux
intrusion detection system or IDs by the
end of this course we will take you
through the most asked interview
questions in cyber security cyber
security is said to be one of the
promising career in the near future and
to open the door to such a successful
career simply learn offers postgraduate
program in cyber security this
comprehensive postgraduate program in
cyber security is T made to equip you
with the essential skills needed to
excel in the rapidly expanding realm of
cyber security with the focus on the
latest industry Trends this program
ensures you to stay ahead of the curve
and become an expert in the dynamic
world of cyber security by the end of
this course you will be skilled with
Advanced hacking Concepts Network packet
analysis ethical hacking ideas firewalls
and honeypots security and risk
management network security and more
find the complete course details from
from the link in the description box so
before we move ahead consider
subscribing to our Channel and hit the
Bell icon to never miss any updates from
Simply learn so without any further
delay over to our tutors did you know
that Facebook removed 2.29 billion
content pieces from their website after
a record number of complaints regarding
hacked accounts even the mighty Facebook
cannot secure its systems 100% such is a
situation when it comes to cyber
security based on recent events and
future predictions cyber crimes will
cost organizations world a whopping
$10.5 trillion coming from just $3.5
trillion in 2050 so you can understand
why it should not come as a surprise
that professionals train in cyber
security are in skyh high demand and
will be for the foreseeable future so
what's better than staying ahead of the
curve and getting traded in cyber
security now there are several reasons
as to why you should learn cyber
security here we have the top 10 reasons
for the same at number 10 the reason we
have is basic requirements there is a
wrong notion that building a career in
cyber security is daunting well it is
not a fancy college degree is not at all
that it takes to become a successful
cyber security professional you can
Venture into the domain of cyber
security with some basic knowledge of it
and with an authorized cyber security
certification the overall eligibility
Criterion for the cyber security domain
is relaxing across the world it
professionals with cyber security
certifications are known to receive
higher salary packages
certifications are always given extra
vitage in the infosec field and it opens
doors to bigger
opportunities these cyber security
certifications can be opted by anyone as
the eligibility for these are very basic
cyber security certifications train
professionals and thus helps in Bridging
the Gap between the supply and demand of
skilled cyber security
professionals so don't take a step back
from learning cyber security thinking it
is a tedious process if you are a
fresher or a professional you can go
ahead with just these basic
requirements before moving on to our
next reason here is a question for you
all how many of you like mathematics
please let us know in the comment
section below I'm sure not everyone
loves mathematics and that is completely
okay when it comes to learning cyber
security and our ninth reason is
mathematics is not a concern for
learning cyber
security many of us find mathematics
challenging some have the aptitude for
dealing with numbers and some don't and
for those who don't they find it
difficult to proceed with a career that
has maths
involved however you can take your
decision without any worries when it
comes to cyber security as the domain of
cyber security does not involve
mathematics so if maths is not your
strong point then choosing to learn
cyber security is a great choice this
can definitely be a relief to many
instead you can get acquainted with
networking
network security control and coding to
build a career in cyber security our
eighth reason is that cyber security is
a profession that helps achieve the
greater good cyber security consists of
a set of measures and approaches that
help companies and individuals data from
being compromised and
stolen cyber Security Professionals have
defended organizations from several
deadly cyber attacks that aimed at
jeopardizing an organization's
confidentiality integrity and
availability
cyber crimes are currently on their rise
with different types of cyber attacks
the threat to organizations and
individuals alike is only growing by the
day government agencies police forces
and cyber crime cells are tackling this
threat however there is more requirement
for skilled cyber security professionals
who can protect data and work for the
greater good therefore if you want to
bring about a positive impact and a
meaningful difference to the society we
live in then learning cyber security is
a great choice our seventh reason is
that you get to travel the world who
doesn't love to travel the globe
learning cyber security is a great
reason especially for those of you who
aspire to travel the world with the lack
of cyber Security Professionals in the
world there are plenty of opportunities
for skilled experts to travel overseas
to Showcase their cyber security skills
which are in high demand The increased
demand for cyber Security Professionals
is not just restricted to one area but
to the entire world there are several
employment opportunities for cyber
Security Professionals across the globe
so learning cyber security can open new
doors for you overseas as well our sixth
reason is very interesting and that is
the fact that you get to work with
secret agencies and high-profile
ones like other
professionals cyber Security
Professionals also have the opportunity
to work with several prestigious
multinational companies and big giants
like Google Dell Accenture and others
however a cyber security professional's
career opportunities can go beyond mnc's
and they might get the opportunity to
work with top government secret agencies
like mosad NSA ni FBI and so on so what
are you waiting for become a cyber
security expert and showcase your skills
to grab the chance to work with these
top agencies our fifth reason is it is
never too late to begin with there are
very few professions that give you the
Liberty to begin late and one such
profession is cyber security it is never
too late to realize that you want to
become a cyber security expert many
people work as cyber Security
Professionals even after the retirement
if they have a good knowledge about
it you could also join cyber security
courses that train you irrespective of
your
age as long as you have good cyber
security skills there is no need to
worry about job security however late it
is our fourth reason is cyber security
is an evergreen industry cyber security
has gradually become an evergreen
industry in the current times with the
onset of the covid-19 pandemic
businesses are moving online and
shifting to cloud storage the demand for
cyber security is at its
peak there is a high demand for cyber
Security Experts who can saveguard
Digital Data hence we can be rest
assured that cyber security is here to
stal and this domain is only going to
grow in the coming
years according to cyber security
Ventures the number of Internet users
will hit a whooping 6 billion by
2022 these numbers speak volumes and
this reveals the growing demand for
cyber Security Professionals across the
globe digitalization is taking place
across several
Industries a cyber security expert finds
opportunities in every field as every
organization wants to be secure on the
digital front so now is the right time
if you are looking to learn and start a
career in cyber security before moving
to our top three reasons to learn cyber
security here's some crucial information
for you
all as you know with relevant
certifications you can grow your cyber
security career and here we are to help
you with that you can check out Simply
learns cyber security export Masters
program to equip you with the necessary
skills to become an expert in this r
rapidly growing
domain training for highly short after
certifications like CompTIA Security
Plus CH cism and cissp is at the
Forefront of this course preparing you
for the industry's best jobs so what are
you waiting for get certified with
simply learn and grow your career in
cyber security
today so our third reason to learn cyber
security is because of the plenty of job
opportunities it offers according to the
us Bureau of Labor Statistics the
employment of information security
analysts is projected to grow 33% from
2020 to 2030 much faster than the
average for all
occupations with the world turning
digital there is a dire need for
companies to hire cyber Security Experts
who can protect and Safeguard sensitive
data as firms work to improve their
cyber security structure they are also
hiring several cyber Security Experts to
design
Implement and maintain the Cyber
Security
Solutions cyber security jobs are not
limited to the it domain many security
positions are found at companies outside
of it including Industries like Media
Sports or Finance to name a few this
emphasizes on the fact that a cyber
security export is exposed to several
job opportunities from different types
of companies across the
globe our second reason for you to learn
cyber security is the good salary
package page it
offers salaries play a crucial part in
any job that you undertake isn't it
every individual likes to get duly
rewarded for their work and cyber
security is one such domain that
provides fat
paychecks cyber Security Experts are the
individuals who have come to the rescue
with the unprecedented rise in cyber
crimes across the world organizations
are willing to pay Skyhigh salaries for
these cyber Security Experts there is a
lack of skilled cyber Security
Professionals and this is another reason
cyber Security Experts are paid
well the salaries of cyber Security
Professionals are still expected to grow
in the coming times owing to the high
demand salaries and cyber security have
a high growth potential and if you are a
skilled cyber security professional you
can always negotiate your
salary finally a top reason to learn
cyber security is that you will have a
job that never gets boring and a domain
that offers unlimited potential for
personal
growth several times individuals find
themselves lost in their career due to
lack of challenges due to their mundane
work and also due to stagnation at work
these reasons play a major role when it
comes to a professional quitting their
job however a job rule in cyber security
tackles these reasons to an extent and
that is why we have this reason at
number one cyber security is a domain
that is constantly evolving and so are
the nature of cyber attacks hackers are
always trying to develop new methods to
get to your data they develop new
exploits regularly and hence as a cyber
security professional you will face
interesting challenges to find Optimal
Solutions for new exploits you will have
new puzzles to solve a cyber security
career is not going to be
stale along with failures you will also
be exposed to new and interesting
discoveries to to keep yourself updated
in this field and to tackle cyber
attacks you should be in a position to
outsmart the hackers being in the field
of cyber security allows you to
constantly upskill and enhance your
knowledge and experience it also ensures
that your Learning Journey will never
stop with the world turning virtual
cyber attacks are constantly flooding
new headlines covid-19 accelerated the
current digital transformation and the
year 2020 witnessed several data
breaches since technology has become
more intertwined with our daily lives it
is no surprise that the need for skilled
cyber Security Professionals is
increasing on that note hey everyone
welcome yet to another exciting video by
simply learn which will take you through
the top cyber security career options
available today but before we begin if
you're new here and haven't subscribed
already make sure to hit the Subscribe
button and that Bell icon for
interesting Tech videos every day there
is a significant lack of skilled cyber
security professionals who can tackle
the cyber C security challenges face
daily hence a career in cyber security
is demanding and equally rewarding
finding the right career path in the
cyber security industry isn't always
easy here we are here to help you with
that there are a few prerequisites for a
career in cyber security the basic one
being a bachelor's degree in a subject
relating to cyber security however if
you don't have a relevant degree you can
always take up relevant cyber security
certifications and Kickstart your cyber
security Journey a few other skills like
networking knowledge of operating
systems and Cloud security are required
to start and grow your cyber security
career you can check out our video on
the top five cyber security skills to no
more cyber security jobs vary from entry
level to Executive management and
everything in between there are several
cyber security pads available today it
is best if you start with entry level
and then move on to the next level with
the help of certifications and relevant
experience here let us have a look at
the top five cyber security job roles
today the first job role is that of a
network engineer Network Engineers
construct and administer a company's
computer networks they are responsible
for installing configuring and
supporting Network equipment they also
configure and maintain firewalls
switches and routers this entry-level
cyber security job can help you start
your journey to become an ethical hacker
the annual average salary of a network
engineer in the us is
$85,900 and in India it is around
510,000
rupees second on our list is information
security analyst as an information
security analyst your primary duty is to
protect sensitive information
information security analysts create and
Implement plans for preventing cyber
attacks they monitor data access and
ensure compliance with policies
depending on the Cyber threat they
decide if it has to be resolved or
escalated further further in the US an
information security analyst earns
$89,100
annually and in India they earn
64275 rupees third on our list is
ethical hacker they're also known as
penetration testers they are Network
Security Consultants who identify and
exploit system vulnerabilities just like
how a hacker would do they probe and
test the network using various
penetration tools and software they also
design new penetration tools and
document the test results in the US a
certified ethical hacker earns around
$93,000 on an annual average basis and
in India they make around 5 lakh rupees
the fourth job role that we are going to
talk about is security architect
security Architects research and plan
the security elements for their
organizations they design robust
security structures that are capable of
preventing malware attacks a security
architect approves the installation of
routers VPN and firewalls their duties
go beyond just architecture building and
including formulating company procedures
guidelines and user guides security
architects in the US make a handsome sum
of
$124,000 a year on an average and in
India they make nearly 21 lakh 80,000
rupees and finally fifth on our list is
Chief Information Security Officer ciso
they are senior level officers in an
organization they Ure the safety of the
information they develop Implement and
maintain information security and risk
management programs they also interact
with stakeholders and regularly brief
them with information security concerns
the average annual salary of a chief
information security officer in the
states is a whopping
$165,000 annually and in India it is 22
lak 22,000 and 845 rupees several
companies are looking for skilled cyber
security profession professionals
Phillips seens Google Microsoft and GE
to name a few with passion the right
amount of experience and relevant
certifications you can grow your cyber
security career you can check out Simply
learn cyber security expert master's
program to equip you with the necessary
skills needed to become an expert in
this rapidly growing domain this course
will help you learn various methods as
to how you can protect your
infrastructure secure your data run risk
analysis achieve compliance and much
more according to cyber crime magazine
by cyber security Ventures globally
there would be nearly 3.5 million
unfilled cyber security jobs by 2021 and
the number of Internet users will hit a
warping 6 billion by
2022 these numbers speak volumes and
this shows the growing demand for cyber
Security Professionals across the globe
now that you know the high demand for
cyber Security Professionals let us help
you start your cyber security career by
bagging the right skill
set many of you out there might be
waiting to become a cyber security
professional but are unsure of how to go
about it and what skills you would need
to get a cyber security job not to worry
we are here to help you with that after
extensive research we have come up with
the top five skills that will help you
get into the field of cyber security
let's have a look at these skills
individually first first we have
networking and system administration the
number one skill you need to have to
enter the field of cyber security is
computer
networking networking is the backbone of
the internet it is imperative that you
have an in-depth understanding of
networking to start a career in cyber
security a network is a group of
interconnected devices and networking is
the art of understanding how data is
sent transmitted and received amongst
these
devices you need to know various routing
protocols the TCP pip and OSI models
govern networking the OSI model is
comparatively newer basically in these
models all the protocols are grouped
into layers and work together to help
you receive data on your device sent
from a server learning networking will
help you understand the technical
aspects of data transmission which will
help you secure your data you can take
up networking certifications like
Security Plus and Cisco CCNA to gain a
strong networking
Foundation another skill that be
beneficial for you is to Master System
Administration if you think about it all
of us are CIS admins at some
level system administration is all about
configuring and maintaining computers
you must be curious to know every aspect
of your computer features and settings
and play around a bit carry out a trial
and error method and give yourself small
tasks like recovering deleted files or
monitoring old viruses on a VM explore
new techniques put them into use and
expand your
knowledge let us now move on to our
second skill knowledge of operating
systems and virtual
machines to become a cyber security
professional you need to have a strong
knowledge of operating environments such
as Windows Linux and Mac OS cyber
Security Professionals largely use Linux
and it comes with several tools to learn
operating systems go ahead and set up
and use Virtual machines that is VMS and
play around with them this will help you
gain hands-on experience as a cyber
security expert you should be
comfortable working on any OS WMS allow
you to train and research in an isolated
environment and help you maximize your
skills the next point to remember is to
know Kali Linux it is the most widely
known Linux distribution for ethical
hacking and penetration
testing it comes with several hundred
tools related to penetration testing
malware analyses security research
computer forensics and so on Kali
contains several projects and and you
can learn a lot another good thing about
Kali is that it is free to use so what
are you waiting for download and start
right away remember that Linux is the
backbone of cyber security and a
commonly asked topic for cyber security
interviews especially for pentesting
roles moving on to our third skill our
third skill is network security control
it is another basic skill that every
cyber security professional should have
network security control refers to the
different measures which are employed to
enhance the security of a network it is
simple you can only Safeguard your
network if you know how it works how
routers firewalls and other devices work
a firewall is a hardware or software
that blocks incoming or outgoing traffic
from the internet to your
computer firewalls are required to
secure a network as a cyber security
expert you must be able to leverage a
firewall to filter and prevent
unauthorized traffic onto to the network
in addition to that as a cyber security
expert you must know about intrusion
detection systems intrusion prevention
systems virtual private networks and
remote
access an intrusion detection system IDs
is designed to detect unauthorized
access to a system it is used together
with a firewall and a router you should
be able to operate the IDS and recognize
any security policy violations and
malicious traffic on the
network as many of you may have used a
VPN is a connection between a VPN server
and a VPN client it is a secure tunnel
across the
internet moving on next up we have an
interesting skill any idea what that is
if yes pause and leave a comment as to
what you think the next skill will be if
getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit skillup by simply learn click
on the link in the description to know
more
and before we jump into this skill if
you find this video interesting make
sure to give it a thumbs up fourth skill
on our list is
coding so you might be wondering if
coding is really required to become a
cyber security professional well it is
true that not all cyber Security
Professionals have or need coding
skills however having zero coding
knowledge May limit your opportunities
in the future knowing a couple of
programming languages will help you
identify the plan behind an attack and
defend against deadly hacking
techniques so as seen on your screens
these are the best programming languages
to learn to make your cyber security
career
worthwhile we have C and C++ the C
programming language is the backbone of
most operating systems C and C++ are
low-level programming languages that you
need to know as a cyber security
professional on the other hand python is
a highlevel programming language that is
becoming popular among cyber Security
Experts today knowing python will give
you an upper hand in your career it will
help you identify and fix
vulnerabilities JavaScript is another
highlevel programming language that adds
interactivity to web pages a good
advantage of knowing JavaScript is that
you can prevent cross-site scripting
attacks from occurring as in these
attacks the attacker implants malicious
code in a web application speaking of
PHP because most of the websites are
created using PHP learning it will help
you defend against Intruders
similarly HTML is another language cyber
Security Professionals should understand
as most websites use it and it is one of
the easiest languages to learn another
programming language that you can use is
goang it is great for cryptography you
can solve various cyber security
problems with it then we have SQL that
is structured query language attackers
use this language to damage the stored
data one such example is the SQL
injection attack hence having a good
understanding of his SQL will be highly
beneficial another Point we'd like to
highlight is to have knowledge of
Assembly Language this will help you
become a cyber security engineer
assembly will help you understand how
malware functions and thereby help you
defend against it in the cyber security
domain you can't just lock into a single
language and hence it is advised that
you're acquainted with a couple of them
you can also do a crash course for these
languages and learn them hence determine
the best programming language for your
cyber security role and and get familiar
with the
basics moving on our fifth skill on the
list is cloud security there is a
growing demand for cyber Security
Professionals with Cloud security skills
in the coming
years companies are on the lookout for
professionals with security skills
applicable to public and hybrid Cloud
platforms such as Amazon web services
and Azure more organizations look to
Cloud infrastructure to store data and
run
applications this includes the
implementation of policies and
technologies that prot protect
cloud-based systems and
devices just like application
development security Cloud security also
involves building secure systems from
the start companies want professionals
who can manage the cloud security tools
to identify and prevent any Cloud
breaches people with experience and
knowledge in managing big platforms such
as Microsoft Azure AWS and the gcp are
in high
demand now that we have seen the top
five cyber security skills let us go
through a set of additional skills that
can help you get into the cyber security
field remember that to become a
successful cyber security expert you
must possess a rich and diverse skill
set so in a list of additional skills
first we have risk
analysis identifying risks even before
their arrival is a great skill cyber
Security Professionals are required to
identify manage and mitigate risks risk
management and mitigation is a skill set
that is going to be highly in demand in
the coming
years next we have information security
companies require skilled professionals
who can protect their electronic data
from unauthorized taxes here in demand
skills are authentication authorization
malware analysis and data
recovery next on our list is security
incident handling and
response as a cyber security expert you
must be prepared to handle any
forthcoming threat of violating an
organization security policy by
following an updated incident response
plan your team can proactively protect
your data and minimize the
damages in security Incident Management
you are required to identify manage
record and analyze security threats in
real time a security incident can be an
active threat or a successful compromise
of data or an attempted intrusion it can
also be incidents like DS attacks
fishing APS ransomware and many more
another important pointer is that as a
security practitioner you must also
manage and analyze the security
information and event management S tools
and
services moving on we have security
audit security auditing is an internal
check that is carried out to find flaws
in the organization's information system
you must be able to conduct a review of
the organization's adherence to
regulatory guidelines security audit and
compliance knowledge are very crucial as
any mystery of Regulatory Compliance
could lead to Hefty penalties soon
organizations will need people who are
more familiar with the various data
privacy regulations if you are good at
paperwork you can capitalize on this
skill companies will need people who can
understand what paperwork to file and
which security protocols to use to
comply with the
regulations finally we have laws and
regulations and often overlooked cyber
security aspect there are several cyber
security laws and regulations and if you
break these laws intentionally or not it
doesn't matter as you will still be
charged these laws Define how you can
use the internet and it also defines how
people people can be protected from
becoming the victims of cyber crimes
knowing these laws and regulations and
following the best practice will make
you ethical at your job and this will in
turn be good for your organization so
those were our list of additional skills
apart from these make sure you stay
updated with new hacks and learn new
tools as cyber security is ever
evolving another important skill apart
from these technical skills is your soft
skills having a set of good soft skills
will help you bag your dream job we have
a video on the top five soft skills that
will help you grow in your career do
watch that and incorporate those skills
as
well when it comes to web app hacking it
generally refers to the exploitation of
applications by HTTP which can be done
by manipulating the applications via its
graphical user interface this is done by
tampering with the uniform resource
identifier also known as a URI or
tampering with the HTTP elements
directly which are not a part of the URI
the hacker can send a link via an email
or a chat and may trick the users of a
web application into executing actions
in case the attack is on an
administrator account the entire web
application can be
compromised anyone who uses a computer
connected to the internet is susceptible
to the threats that computer hackers and
online Predators pose these online vain
typically use fishing scams spam email
or instant messages and bogus websites
to deliver dangerous malware to youran
computer and compromise your computer
security computer hackers can also try
to access your computer and private
information directly if you're not
protected by a firewall they can monitor
your conversations or produce the back
end of your personal website usually
disguised with a bogus identity
Predators can lure you into revealing
sensitive personal and financial
information a web server which can be
referred to as the hardware the computer
or the software which helps to deliver
content that can be accessed through the
internet the primary function of a web
server is to deliver these web pages on
the request to clients using the
hypertex transfer protocol or
HTTP so hackers attack the web server to
steal credential information passwords
and business information by using
different types of attacks like DS
attacks syn flooding ping flood port
scan and social engineering attacks in
the area of web security despite strong
encryption on the browser server Channel
web users still have no Assurance about
what happens at the other
end although wireless networks offer
great flexibility they have their own
security problems a hacker can sniff the
network packets without having to be in
the same building where the network is
located as wireless networks communicate
through radio waves a hacker can easily
sniff the network from a nearby location
most attackers use Network sniffing to
find the SSID and hack a wireless
network an attacker can attack hack a
network from a distance and therefore it
is sometimes difficult to collect
evidence against the main
hacker social engineering is the art of
manipulating users of a Computing system
into revealing confidential information
which can be later used to gain
unauthorized access to a computer system
the term can also include activities
such as exploiting human kindness greed
and curiosity to gain access to
restricted access buildings or getting
the users to installing backdoor
software
knowing the tricks used by hackers to
trick users into releasing vital login
information is fundamental in protecting
computer systems now that we learn about
the different types of tools that can be
used when conducting an ethical hacking
audit let's learn about some potential
benefits of such campaigns and why
organizations prefer to pay for such
audits being able to identify defects
from an attacker's perspective is
game-changing since it displays all the
potential Avenues of a possible hack one
can only prepare for the known
vulnerabilities as a defensive
specialist but proactively trying to
breach a network or device can make
hackers think of techniques that no
defense contractors can account for this
kind of unpredictability goes a long way
in securing a network against malicious
actors another advantage of hiring
ethical hackers is the ability to
preemptively fix possible weak points in
a company's Network infrastructure as
seen on many occasions a real breach
will cause loss of data and irreparable
damage to the foundation of an
organization being able to gauge such
shortcomings before they become public
and can be used exploited is a benefit
most organizations make use
of this is not to imply that such
security audits are only beneficial to
the organization paying for it and
coming across companies that provide
certain Services a reliable thirdparty
security audit goes a long way in
instilling trust and confidence over
their craft if the ethical hackers
cannot find any major vulnerabilities
that can be leveraged by hackers it just
accentuates the technical bence of the
organization and its Engineers thereby
increasing the clientele by a
substantial amount with the next
generation of Internet exchanges focused
on maximum privacy and security a
variety of ways have been enforced to
maintain them as such censorship has
been shifted from the streets to the
digital domain it forces the standard
citizen to derive Al alternative ways to
maintain anonymi major weapon in this
battle for privacy and security is the T
browser an independent browser meant to
browse the internet while relaying
information through the tour Network it
serves as a meaningful alternative to
the standard internet browsing habits to
better understand the purpose of this
browser and suchar we must learn about
the work of the T Network featuring its
own routing protocol the top browser is
an easy way to maintain anonymity while
browsing without emptying one's wallet
let's take a look at the topics to be
covered
today we start at the explanation of
what is the Tor Network and its
significance in the working of the to
browser we take a look at the onion
routing protocol and how it transmits
the data from the client devices to the
T directories in order to circumvent
government
censorship moving on we learn a few
features of the to browser and the
distinct advantages the T Network
provides next we learn the difference
between using a VPN and a t to anonymize
internet usage and finally we have a
live demonstration of the Tor Browser
anonymization features in
action let's move on to learning about
the T
Network T short for the onion router
it's an open-source privacy Network that
permits users to browse the web
anonymously the Tor was initially
developed and solely used by the US Navy
to protect sensitive government
Communications before the network was
made publicly available the digital era
has disrupted the traditional way of
doing things in every sector of the
economy the rapid Rising development and
innovation of digital products has given
way to frequent data breaches and cyber
thefts in response consumers are
increasingly operting for products that
offer data privacy and cyber security T
is one such underground Network that was
implemented for the purpose of
protecting users identities the to
network is one example of the many
emerging technologies that attempt to
fill a data privacy void in a digital
space plagued by cyber security
concerns the to network intercepts the
traffic from your browser and bounces a
user's request of a random number of
other user IP addresses then the data is
passed to the user request Final
Destination these random users are
volunteer devices which are called as
nodes or relays the T Network disguises
your identity by encrypting the traffic
and moving it across different T relays
within the network the Tor Network uses
an onion routing technique for
transmitting data hence the original
name of onion router to operate within
the T Network a user has to install the
T browser any address or information
requested using the browser is
transmitted through the to network it
has its own feature set which we will be
covering over later in this
video as we discussed already the data
passing through the to network must
follow a unique protocol known as The
Onion routing protocol let us learn more
about its unique
characteristics in our normal Network
usage the data is transmitted directly
the sender has data package to transmit
which is done directly over a line of
communication with either a receiving
party or a server of some kind however
since the data can easily be captured
while being transmitted the security of
this exchange is not very reliable
moreover it becomes very easy to trace
the origin of such requests on many
occasions websites with questionable and
controversial content are blocked from
the ISP this is possible since the ISP
is able to detect and spy on user
information passing through the network
apart from isps there is a steady chance
of your private information being
intercepted by hackers unfortunately
easy detection of the source and
contents of a web request make entire
network extremely vulnerable for people
who seek anonymity over the
Internet however in the onion routing
protocol things take a longer route we
have a with the top browser installed on
the client system the network sends the
information to node one's IP address
which encrypts the information and
passes it on to node 2's address which
performs another encryption and passes
it on to node 3 address this is the last
address which is also known as the exit
node this last node decrypts the
encrypted data and finally relays the
request to the Final Destination which
can be another device or a server end
this final address thinks the request
came from the exit node and GRS access
to it the encryption process across
multiple computers repeats itself from
the exit node to the original user the
to network obfuscates user IP addresses
from unwanted surveillance by keeping
the users's request untraceable with
multiple servers touching the data it
makes the tracking very difficult for
both isps and malicious
attackers now that we understand the way
T Works let us learn more about the T
browser the to browser was developed by
a nonprofit organization as a part of
the T project in 2008 and its first
public release was announced the to
browser is a browser Fork from the
popular Firefox that anonymizes your web
traffic using the T network if you're
investigating a competitor researching
an opposing litigant in a legal dispute
or just think it's creepy for your ISP
or the government to know what websites
you visit the to browser might be the
right
solution before the top browser were
developed using that Network to maintain
anonymity was a huge task for everyday
consumers starting from the setup to the
usage the entire process demanded a lot
of knowledge and practice the to browser
managed to make it easy for users to
Traverse the relay servers in tour and
guarantee the privacy of the data
exchange a major feature of the T
browser is the ability to delete all
browser history cookies and tracking
data the moment it is closed every new
launch of the browser opens an empty
slate having a usage habits from being
tracked and singled out a major feature
that is the highlight of the to network
is the availability of onion links only
a small portion of the worldwide web is
available to the general public we have
the Deep Web that contains links that
are not allowed to be indexed by
standard search engines like Google and
Bing the dark web is a further subset of
the Deep Web which contains onion links
to browser gives you access to these
onion websites which are only available
within the T Network onion is a special
use top top level domain which
designates an anonymous onion service
which is also known as a hidden service
similar to The Links of the Deep Web
these onion links provide services like
online shopping cryptocurrency and many
other products not available in the
consumer Internet space often being
considered as a Haven for illegal
activities and sales onion links provide
both information and assets in a private
manner without the risk of spying by
authorities browsing the web over tour
is slower than the clear net du to the
multiple layers of
encryption some web services also block
to users to browser is also illegal in
authoritarian regimes that want to
prevent citizens from Reading publishing
and communicating anonymously
journalists and dissidents around the
world have embraced tore as a
Cornerstone of democracy and researchers
are hard at work at improving TS
anonymity
properties let us take a look at some of
the advantages of using the T browser
over standard web browsers
the highlight of using the to browser is
to maintain anonymity over the Internet
the cause for such requests can differ
from person to person but all of these
concern are answered by the to network
outing the information via multiple
nodes and relay servers make it entirely
difficult for the ISP to keep a track of
usage
data the entire to project is designed
to be completely free and open source
allowing the code for the browser to be
inspected and audited by third party
helps in the early detection of faulty
configurations and critical bugs it is
present for multiple operating system
starting from laptops to mobile
devices a number of websites are blocked
by governments for a variety of reasons
journalists under authoritarian regimes
have difficulty in getting the word out
regarding the situation since the onion
routing protocol transfers data between
multiple servers of random countries the
domains being blocked become available
when used via T usage of these
encryption messaging platforms is easily
enforced using the Tor Browser which
otherwise would have been a difficult
task under oppressive
circumstances many people believe that a
VPN offers the same benefits as the top
browser let's put both of them to the
test and see the differences between
them coming to the first point of
difference to is completely free and
open source all of the code for the
browser and the network can be audited
and has been cleared for security
concerns when it comes to VPN there are
many different brands which have open
source clients but the same cannot be
said for their counterparts some have
partly open source while some have
completely locked up their code so that
they cannot be stolen
further moving on T has multiple relay
points in his data transfer protocol
between the server and the receiver
there are three different IP nodes that
number can increase but it'll always be
more than two once the data is passed
from the cender it goes through all of
the those delay points while in the case
of a VPN the connection is made from the
client device to the VPN server and then
to the requested destination there is no
other IP node that comes into work here
thereby making the connection a one to
one between the client and a
VPN as a next Point since store handles
multiple layers of encryption and the
data passes through multiple systems
along the way the performance is slow
compared to a VPN where the performance
is relatively fast due to the less
number of nodes the data passes through
similarly the multi-layer encryption of
T is consistent if you use T browser
every single request passes through the
same layer of encryption and follows the
same routing protocol in the case of a
VPN different companies offer different
levels of encryption some have multihop
some prefer a single onetoone connection
and these kind of differences make the
choice much more
variable finally the nodes and relays
being used in the Tor Network are
volumer there is no company holding over
them so jurisdiction becomes relatively
straightforward when in the case of vpns
many such vpns are hosted by adware
companies or are being monitored by
Central governments to note the usage
information now that we have a better
understanding of the T browser and its
routing let us take a look at how the T
browser can anonymize and protect our
internet
usage on opening up the T browser for
the first time this is the page that
that you're going to be welcomed with
you have the option of connecting to the
to network before we start our
browsing so let's press
connect and we can see that it is
connected coming to the
anonymization let's check my current
location on Google
Chrome currently is showing as Navi
Mumbai in
Maharashtra if we check the same link on
the tour browser we should get a
different address
now every link that we open in the tour
browser will be little delayed and the
speed will be hampered because of the
multiple layers of encryption like we
discussed now as you can
see it's showing a German IP and the
state of
Bavaria this is how the anonymization
works there is no VPN configured there
is no proxy attached it's straight up
the out of the box settings that come
inbuilt with the Tor Browser similarly
we have an option of cleaning up the
data let's say if you want to refresh
your location and you want to use a
different ID for the next browsing
session if you just restart it once and
we can have to check it
again we should be seeing a different
country this
time as you can see we have Netherlands
right now so this is how you can keep
refreshing your address you can keep
refreshing your host location so that
you cannot be tracked when in browsing
the internet like we discussed we have
some onion links that can only be used
on the tour
Network as you can see these kind of
links do not open in the Google Chrome
browser but once we copy these over to
the T
browser as you can see we have opened
the hidden wiki which is available only
on the tour Network this is kind of an
alternative Wikipedia website where we
can find articles to read and more
information to learn similarly we have
another onion link over
here which is once again available only
for the toall
browser now these kind of delays are
expected but they are a valid compromise
because they maintain the anonymity that
many people desire similarly we have
found a hidden wallet which is a
cryptocurrency wallet which is specific
speically for dark web
members this operates over the T Network
and this is used by mostly journalists
and people who want to anonymize their
internet transactions when it comes to
dealing
money all of the transactions that occur
over the T Network are almost impossible
to track therefore these kind of
cryptocurrency wallets are very big on
the Deep Web this is just one example
while having multiple different wallets
for every single cryptocurrency
available Ware is a malicious software
that is programmed to cause damage to a
computer system Network and Hardware
devices many malicious programs like
prion viruses bombs and Bots which cause
damage to the system are known as
malware most of the malware programs are
designed to steal information from the
targeted user or to steal money from the
Target by stealing sensitive
data let's take a look at the
introduction for two different types of
malware virus and Trojan
firstly let's take a look what exactly
is a virus
program a computer virus is a type of
malicious program that on execution
replicates itself they get attached to
different files and programs which are
termed as host programs by inserting
their code if the attachment succeeds
the targeted program is termed as
infected with a computer virus now let's
take a look at the Trojan Horse Trojan
Horse program is a program that
disguises itself as a legitimate program
but harms a system on installation they
hide within the attachments and emails
then transfer from one system to another
they create back doors into a system to
allow the Cyber criminal to steal our
information let's take a look how they
function after getting installed into
our
system firstly we have virus programs
the computer virus must contain two
parts to infect the system
first is a search routine which locates
new files and data that is to be
infected by the virus program and the
second part is known as the copy routine
which is necessary for the program to
copy itself into the targeted file which
is located by the search routine now
let's take a look at the Trojan Horse
functioning for troan horses entryway
into our system is through emails that
may look legitimate but may have unknown
attachments and when such f are
downloaded into the device the tro
program gets installed and infects the
system they also infect the system on
the execution of infected application or
the executable file and attacks a
system now that we understand what virus
and rions are let's understand different
types of virus and
rions let's take a look at different
types of viruses the first one is known
as the boot sector virus this type of
virus damag dages the booting section of
the system by infecting the masterb
record which is also known as MBR this
damages the boot sector section by
targeting the hard disk of the
system then we have the macro virus mcro
virus is a type of virus that gets
embedded into the document related data
and is executed when the file is open
they also are designed to replicate
themselves and infect the system on a
larger scale and lastly we have have the
direct action
virus this type of virus gets attached
to executable files which on execution
activates the virus program and infects
the system once the infection of the
file is completed they exit the system
which is also the reason it is known as
a non-resident virus let's take a look
at different types of
prions the first type of troan is the
back door troan they are designed to
create a back door in the the system on
execution of an infected program they
provide remote access of a system to the
hacker this way the Cyber criminal can
steal our system data and may use it for
illegal activities next we have cricos
Rion they enter the system by clicking
the random popups which we come across
on the internet they ATT the user to
give their personal details for
different transactions or
schemes which may provide remote access
of of a system to the Cyber
criminal and the last troan type is
Ransom troen this type of troan program
after entering the system blocks the
user from accessing its own system and
also affects the system
functioning the Cyber criminal Demands a
ransom from the targeted user for the
removal of the Trojan program from the
device now that we understand some
details regarding viruses and troan
let's solve a
question the question is Jake was denied
access to his system and he wasn't able
to control the data and information in
his
system now the actual question is what
could be the reason behind this system's
problem option a macro virus option b
Ransom troan option C back door rosion
give your answers in the comment
section now let's understand how to
detect the activity of viruses and troan
in our
system to detect virus Orion activity in
a system we can refer to the following
points for viruses we have slowing down
of the system and frequent application
freeze shows that the infection of the
virus is present in the
system then we have the viruses can also
steal sensitive data including passwords
Account Details which may lead to
unexpected log out from the accounts or
Corruption of the sensitive data and
lastly we have frequent system crashes
due to virus infection which damages the
operating system for Trojan we have
frequent system crashes and system also
faces slow reaction time then we have
there are more random popups from the
system which may indicate troan activity
and lastly we have modification in the
system application and change of the
desktop appearance can be also due to
the infection of a troan
program next let's take a look at a
famous Cyber attack for virus and a
Trojan
hor for virus we have the maom virus
which was identified in the year 2004
which affected over 50 million systems
by creating a network of sending spam
emails which was to gain back door
access into our
systems next for the troan horse we have
the emren program which is a
specifically designed for financial
theft and for stealing Bank related
information next we have few points for
how to prevent virus entry or troan
attack for our
system the most basic way of virus
protection is to using antivirus and do
regular viruses can this will prevent
virus entry in the system and also
having more than one antivirus provides
birge better
protection then avoid visiting
uncertified websites can also prevent
virus entry into our system
then we have using regular driver
updates and system updates to prevent
virus entry for troan we have using
certified softwares from legal sites to
prevent any troan activity in our
system and also avoid clicking random
popups that we often see on the internet
and lastly using antivirus and Fireballs
for protection against Trojan horses is
a good
habit
now that we have reached the end of the
video Let's Take a look what we learned
for the first part we saw the main
objective of the virus is to harm the
data and information in a system whereas
for the troan we have stealing of the
data files and information effect of
viruses is more drastic in comparison to
the Trojan
horses then we have viruses which are
non- remote programs whereas troan
horses are remote accessed and lastly
viruses have the ability to replicate
itself to harm multiple files where as
strojan does not have the replication
ability so let's begin with what is SQL
injection as the name suggest SQL
injection vulnerability allows an
attacker to inject malicious input into
a SQL statement so SQL stands for
structured query language which is a
language used by an application to
interact with the database now normally
this attack is targeted towards a
database to extract uh the data that is
stored within however the vulnerability
does not lie in the database itself the
vulnerability will always lie in the
application it is the developers
prerogative of how to develop the
application how to configure it to
prevent SQL injection queries from
happening a database is created to
answer questions and if a question is
asked it is supposed to answer it
database needs to be configured for some
amount of security but the vulnerability
the flaw here for SQL injection will
always lie in the application itself it
is how the application interacts with
the database that needs to be modified
that needs to be maintained by the
developer rather than just configuring
the database itself so the attacker at
this point in time when they send a
query to the application will form a
malformed query by injecting a
particular command or an operator that
is recognized by the SQL language and if
that operator is passed through the
application to the database then the
database basically gets cracked or does
a data dump because of that unwanted
character coming in so this character
needs to be filtered at the application
Level itself now let's look at a quick
demo so what we have done here is I have
this virtual machine called oasp broken
web applications virtual machine version
1.2 I'm going to power this
on
till this poers on I'm going to show you
where we can download this uh utility
from so you can just look for OAS broken
web application project download you'll
find it on sourceforge.net click on the
link you can download the broken web
application project from here this is a
1.9gb download and you can have a zip
machine directly for VMware or a Oracle
virtual box
now this is an application that has been
developed by oasp which stands for open
web application security project which
is a not for-profit organization and uh
periodically uh releases the most top 10
risks that an application uh will face
for that particular
year so they have given a web
application uh with inbuilt
vulnerabilities for professionals like
us to practice upon to develop our
skills upon because doing this in the
real world is illegal I cannot go onto a
website to demonstrate how a SQL
injection attack Works uh neither should
you try your hands on it till you become
very well rehearsed with it so till to
upgrade your skills to upskill yourself
please download this machine host it in
a VM workstation or Oracle virtual box
and you can uh then try your skills on
it right so just going back to the
browser here if I open up uh a new tab
you'll see that this machine has booted
up and has an IP address called 71. 132
so if I just go on to that IP address
and I type in 192
132 and you'll see the OAS broken web
application project and there are lot of
training applications realistic
intentionally vulnerable applications
old versions of real applications and so
on so forth so there is a lot of
applications inbuilt over here that you
can try your skills upon we are going to
try to use the OAS mutil day over here
uh this gives you the uh OAS top 10
risks for 2010 2013 2017 is the latest
one so far uh but the difference between
2013 and 2017 is that some of these have
changed but not all of them uh the order
has changed a little bit but you can see
that SQL injection is on the top A1
amongst the injection attacks right and
you can see there are multiple types
that have been given here the SQL
injection for extracting data or SQL
injection for bypass authentication or
insert your injection uh uh attacks
blind SQL injection and then there is a
tool called SQL map which is available
freely on your Linux machines Ki Linux
or parot Linux whichever you want to use
uh for your practice targets and so on
so forth so if I just take you here for
bypass
authentication and this is a regular
login page that an application may have
right you look at a username you look at
password you type that in and you log in
so let's say I don't know a password
here I'm just going to type in the
username test password is pssw Rd I try
to log in and it shows me that the
account does not exist so the
authentication mechanism does work I did
try type in a username and password it
wasn't recognized so the account does
not exist now let's try to type in a SQL
query here I'm going to just give it a
single quote which is an operator that
is recognized by the SQL language which
when the database tries to execute uh
will cause the database to uh dump some
data or to bypass authentication in this
case and I'm going to give it a
condition single
quote r 1 equals 1 space hyphen hyphen
space and I'm going to click on login
now right now I'm not logged in at all
and and we tried our username and
password and we weren't able to log in
so now if I log in you will see that it
give me a status update saying the user
has been authenticated and I'm logged in
as admin got root so that is what these
SQL queries can achieve I'm going to log
out right now and uh we're going to look
at the basics of SQL injection so
looking at that small demo looking now
let's look at what types of SQL
injections are available so the first is
inband SQL injection the there are two
subtypes within inband error based
injection attack and a union based
injection attack the second type is
blind SQL injection attack where there's
a Boolean based and a Time based attack
and the third one is outof bound SQL
injection attack now what is inband SQL
injection attack inband is where we
either attempting the error based or the
union based what is error based uh we
send a query to the database we craft a
query to the database and uh it
generates an error M message and it
dumps the error message right in front
of us on the screen that uh makes us
realize that there is a flaw and there
there is some information that is dumped
on the screen which we can then further
utilize to craft our further queries as
we go ahead whereas Union base is the it
is where we combine multiple statements
at the same time so if you look at the
URL earlier in the URL you would see a
large structure in that URL uh we can
try to add more two or more statements
within the URL itself to combine them
and then confuse the database into
executing both the statements together
and giving a data dump at the same time
right so what would a error based uh SQL
injection look like if I go back to the
same database uh which is here right and
if you remember in the username we gave
it a single quote or 1 equals one space
hyphen hyen space we gave it the
condition right so basically what it did
was this a single code is an operator
that goes to the database selects the
default uh table uh in the user tables
in this database column and then
Compares it to the condition that is
given so the condition that we gave was
1 equals 1 which is always true so what
it did was it selected the default uh
user table that was available in the
database and instead of comparing it to
a password it compared it to the
condition so if I give it 1 equals 2
where the condition is false and if I
log in you will see that the account
doesn't exist comes back again because
the condition was false and instead of
comparing the user account to the
password it basically uh compared the
user account to the condition so if I
give it a single quote or 1 equals one
hyphen hyphen space uh and log in you
can see that this is a correct condition
and thus we are able to log in now
before we even go uh to that extent if I
just forget the condition over here and
it just give it a single code the
operator and I send this operator to the
database and I click on login you will
see that it generates an error which is
right on top and it tells us the line
the uh file where the error happened and
you can see it happened in the MySQL
handler. PHP file right and then it give
us the message you have an error in your
SQL syntax check the m manual that
corresponds to your MySQL server version
for the right syntax to use now why
would a hacker want to do this in the
first place because there are different
types of databases so there is a MySQL
Ms SQL or Microsoft SQL Oracle SQL IBM
db2 all of these are variations of the
SQL database uh they use the SQL
language however every database has its
own Command right they they have their
own syntax they have their own uh
specific command commands that are
utilized for the database so in this
scenario the hacker wants to identify
what database is being currently
utilized so they can craft those
particular queries so now with this
injection with just me sending the quote
and the error getting generated I now
come to know that we are using a MySQL
server and the version of that server is
5173 and uh the rest of the information
about uh where the handlers are located
and so on so for for right this gives
the information to the hacker of how
they want to proceed next what kind of
queries they want to create what kind of
syntax they want to utilize so error
based attack is where you generate these
kind of Errors uh and you get this
information the union base is where you
craft your queries within the URL or you
can try to combine multiple statements
within the input fields and try to
generate a response from that then we
come to Boolean based SQL injection uh
sends a SQL query to the database which
forces the application to return a
different result depending on whether
the query returns a true or a false
result so basically if the input is
false the input both the inputs are
false the output would be false uh
there's one input that is false the
other input that is true input B the
output would be true and so on so forth
right so depending on the result from
the inputs the attack will come to know
which input is true with this he can
then access the database of the website
so you're trying to figure out by
sending out multiple inputs uh and then
analyzing the output to see what exactly
uh which command exactly worked what was
the resultant output of that command
thus from this kind of an information
the hacker can infer their next step
forward then you have time based SQL
injections uh now there are times when a
database administrator an application
administrator has done some security
configuration
and does have disabled verbos error
messages now what is a verbos error
message the error message that we saw
right here is a verbos error message
that means that the message gives out
details the message gives out details
about what the database is the version
and whatnot so if they have sanitized
these
errors and you no longer can generate
these errors and thus you cannot figure
out what database is then what do you do
do right for example if I just take you
to Simply
learn
and take you to a URL that is supposedly
not accessible you can see that it gives
a generic error oops like it looks like
you have crash landed on Mars it doesn't
give you a verbos error that we saw here
so this gives us a detail error of what
went wrong where it gives us the
database the version of the database and
uh where the query went wrong and etc
etc etc whereas on this side where
there's some there's a lot of security
that goes in here so you can see that it
doesn't generate a error it just get a
generic page in front of you so in that
case what what does a hacker do so the
hacker then injects a Time
based uh query in the URL which allows
us to verify whether the command is
being executed or not so uh we put in a
time
weit let's say 10 seconds of time weit
so if we the moment we inject the query
if the query times for 10 seconds and
then gets executed that means that the
SQL injection is possible however if we
inject the query and uh it just gets
executed without the delay that means
that the time uh injection attack would
not be uh possible on that particular
site out of bound is not a very common
attack it depends on the features being
enabled on the database management
system that is being used by the web
application so this can be a somewhat of
a misconfiguration error uh by the
database administrator where you have
enabled functions and not sanitized them
so you have not done in access controls
properly you have not given account
control so queries should never be
executed at an administrative level they
should always be uh executed at a user
level with minimum privileges that are
required for that query to be executed
now if you're allowing these kind of
functions to be uh to be enabled at the
dbms and there's an administrative
account that can have access to them at
that point in time an outof bound
injection attack is possible so let's
look at how our website works
right uh how SQL works on a website now
the website is constructed of HTML
hypertext markup language uh which would
include javascripting for functionality
cascading stylesheets for the mapping of
the website right and then reactjs and
whatnot uh for further functionality now
when we send a query to the website it
is normally using the HTTP protocol or
https protocol when the query reaches
the application the application would
then go ahead and generate the SQL query
uh at the client side you'll have uh all
these scripting languages coming in uh
on the front end uh that we can utilize
to craft queries and then send them
across at the server side you'll have uh
databases like Oracle MySQL Ms SQL and
so on so forth that will then execute
those queries right so just to give you
an example if I use a tool called
Postman what we generally do uh when we
craft a query is we send out a uh get
request to the website and then we
receive a response from the site uh with
the HTML code and everything so this is
a tool that is utilized by software
testers to test the responses that
you're going to get from various
websites so on the left hand side you
can see I've uh used it on quite a bit
uh here we have a example for gmail.com
so let's continue with that so this is a
get request being sent to Gmail
the moment I send it it's going to
create an HTTP request and send it
across the response that I get is this
this is the HTML code for
gmail.com right these are the cookies uh
these are the headers uh that include
information so you can see this is a
text HTML character set utilized is
utf8 and the configuration uh that has
been done with the application right so
this is where uh everything comes in
this is the cookie that has been sent
with that particular uh request reest
that I had sent out now if you Analyze
This query right so when we went onto
this application and I typed in that
single quote and we generated this error
right uh you can see that the
application converted this into a SQL
query so the query was select username
from accounts where the username in
quote single quotes and we use the quote
right the single quote right there so uh
that's where we use that operator and
that's where the exception error
occurred so these are the kind of
queries that are structured by the
application and then taken on to the
database for execution when we type in
uh it is a HTTP get request with the
username and password within that query
uh that is sent to the application the
application converts it into a SQL query
sends it to the database and the
database responds with the appropriate
response so how do we prevent SQL
injection in the first place use
prepared statement and parameterized
queries uh these statements make sure
that the parameters passed into seqence
statements are treated in a safe manner
so for example we saw that the single
code was an operator this shouldn't be
allowed to be utilized in the first
place right so here what we are doing
here is a secure way of running a SQL
query in the jdbc using a parameterized
statement Define which user we want to
find so there's a string the email comes
in connection to the database we are
going to figure out how the connection
is going to be passed how it is going to
be created construct the SQL statement
we want to run specifying the parameter
right so we Define how is it going to be
uh created what is going to be created
what can be passed to the database and
what should not be passed to the
database so that is one way of utilizing
prepared statements and parameterized
queries then we have object relational
mapping most development uh teams prefer
to use object object relational mapping
Frameworks to the translation of SQL
results set into code objects more
seamless so this is an example of object
relational mapping uh where we map
certain objects and allow that to be
executed and then escaping inputs it a
simple way to protect against most SQL
injection attacks many languages have
standard functions to achieve this right
so you need to be very careful while
using Escape characters in your code
base when a SQL statement is constructed
not all injection attacks rely on abuse
of quote characters so you need to know
what characters are being utilized uh in
the configuration that you have created
in the structure that you have created
in the code that you have created uh
which characters are being recognized as
operators you need to sanitize those
operators and you need to uh basically
ensure that these operators cannot be
accepted as user input if they are they
Ved out by the application and they
never reach the database other methods
of uh preventing SQL injection are uh
password hashing so that passwords
cannot be bypassed the passwords cannot
be recovered passwords cannot be cracked
uh third party authentication you use o
or some other service for a single sign
on mechanism does uh you rely on a third
party to maintain the security of
authentication and uh what kind of
parameters are passed for example uh
using LinkedIn logins or Facebook logins
right uh for the Layman you normally go
on to Facebook and you allow if you're
using a game right if you start playing
a game you're allowed to log into the
game using your Facebook credentials or
your Google credentials now that is not
just for ease of use but the game user
the developer has Outsource the
authentication mechanisms to third party
such as Facebook or Google because they
understand that that authentication
mechanism is as safe as can be Facebook
and Google are wealthy organizations uh
hire a lot of Security Experts and the
development for their authentication
mechanisms is topnotch small
organization cannot spend that kind of
money on security itself right so you
use a third party authentication
mechanism to ensure that these kind of
attacks may not happen then web
application firewalls uh having a web
application firewall and configuring it
properly uh for SQL injection attacks is
one of the sure short method of uh
mitigating or minimizing the uh threat
in the the first place so at this point
in time you have realized that the
application has some viabilities for SQL
injection and instead of recoding or
restructuring the application uh you
want to take the easier way out or the
cheaper way out so what you do is you uh
you install a web application firewall
and you configure the web application
firewall to identify malicious queries
and stop them uh at the firewall level
itself so they never reach the
application and thus the vulnerabilities
on the application don't get executed
buy better
software and keep on updating the
software so it's not necessary that once
you have a software you install it it's
going to be safe for Life new
vulnerabilities are discovered every day
every hour and it may so happen what is
secured today maybe completely insecure
tomorrow or the day after right so you
need to keep on upgrading the software
if there are no upgrades available and
the VAB still exist you might want to
migrate to a better software and does uh
ensure that you don't get hacked right
always update and use patches
organizations keep on sending out
updates and patches as and when they are
release you need to install them to uh
enhance your security postures and then
continuously monitor SQL statements and
databases use protocol monitors uh use
different softwares use the firewalls to
keep on monitoring what kind of queries
you uh getting and based on those
queries you want to ensure the inputs
and the queries that are creating uh are
not detrimental to the health of the
software that you have simply learn
offers postgraduate program in cyber
security find the complete cause details
from the link in the description box
cross-site scripting from a Layman's
perspective cross-site scripting also
known as xss is a type of code injection
attack that occurs on the client site
the attacker intends to run harmful
scripts in the victim's web browser by
embedding malicious code in a genuine
web page or online application the real
Attack takes place when the victim hits
the malicious code infected web page or
online application the web page or
application serves as a vehicle for the
malicious script to be sent to the
users's browser forums message boards
and online pages that enable comments
are vulnerable vehicles that are
frequently utilized for cross scripting
assaults a web page or web application
is vulnerable to xss if the output it
creates contains unsanitized user input
the victim's browser must then par this
user input in VB script ActiveX Flash
and even CSS cross-side scripting
attacks are conceivable they are
nevertheless most ubiquitous in
JavaScript o to the fact that JavaScript
is most important to most browser
experiences
nowadays the main purpose of this attack
is to steal the other users identity be
it via cookies session tokens and other
information in most of the cases this
attack is being used to steal the other
person's cookies as we know cookies help
us to log in automatically therefore
with the stolen cookies we can log in
with other identities and this is one of
the reasons why this attack is
considered as one of the riskiest
attacks it can be performed with
different client side programming
languages as
well cross-site scripting is often
compared with similar client side
attacks as client side languages are
mostly being used during this however an
xss attack is considered riskier because
of its ability to damage even less
vulnerable
Technologies most often this attack is
performed with JavaScript and HTML
JavaScript is a programming language
that runs on web pages inside your
browser the client side code adds
functionality and interactivity to the
web page and is used extensively on all
major applications and CMS platforms
unlike serers side languages such as PHP
JavaScript code runs inside your browser
and cannot impact the website for other
visitors it is sandboxed to your own
Navigator and can only perform actions
within your own browser window while
JavaScript is client site and does not
run on the server it can be used to
interact with the server by performing
background requests attackers can then
use these background requests to add
unwanted spam content to a web page
without refreshing it they can then
gather analytics about the client's
browser or perform actions
asynchronously
the manner of attack can range in a
variety of ways it can be a single link
which the user must click on to initiate
a JavaScript piece of code it can be
used to show any piece of images that
can be later used as a front end for
malicious code being installed as
malware with the majority of Internet
users unaware of how metadata works or
the ways in which web requests are
called the chances of victims clicking
on a redirecting links is far too high
cross-side scripting can occur on the
malicious script executed at the client
side using a fake page or even a form
that is displayed to the user on
websites with displayed advertisements
malicious emails can also be sent to the
victim these attacks occur when the
malicious user finds the vulnerable
parts of the website and sends it as
appropriate malicious
input now that we understand the basics
of cross-side scripting let us learn
more about how this kind of attack
works in the first place we have the
website or the web browser which is used
to show content to the victim or which
is the user in our case whenever the
user wants to grab some content from the
website the website asks the data from
the server the server provides this
information to the website and the web
browser which ultimately Rees the
victim how the hacker comes into play
here it passes on certain arguments to
the web browser which is can be then
forwarded back to the server or to the
user at hand the entire cross-site
scripting a tag Vector means sending and
injecting malicious code or script this
attack can be performed in different
ways depending on the type of attack the
malicious script may be reflected on the
victim's browser but stored in the
database and executed every time when
the user calls the appropriate function
the main reason for this attack is
inappropriate users input validation
where the malicious input can get into
the output a malicious user can enter a
script which will be injected onto the
website's code then the browser is not
able to know if the executed code is
malicious or not therefore this
malicious script is being executed on
the victim's browser or any faked form
if that is being displayed for the users
there are many ways to trigger an xss
attack for example the execution could
be triggered automatically when the page
loads or when a user hovers over
specific elements of the page like
hyperlinks potential consequences of
cross-site scripting attacks include
capturing keystrokes of a user
redirecting a user to malicious websites
running web browser based exploits
obtaining cookie information of a user
who is logged into a website and many
more in some cases cross-side scripting
attack leads to complete compromise of
the victim's account attackers can trick
users into entering credentials on a
fake form which can then provide all
information to the attacker with the
basic working of a cross-side scripting
attack out of the way let us go over the
different ways hackers can leverage
vulnerable web applications s to gather
information and eventually breach those
systems the prime purpose of Performing
EXs attack is to steal the other
person's identity as mentioned it may be
cookies session tokens
Etc xss may also be used to display
faked Pages or forms for the victim
however this can be performed in several
ways we have a reflected attack this
attack occurs when a malicious script is
not being saved on the web server but is
reflected in the website results
reflected accss code is not being saved
permanently in this case the malicious
code is being reflected in any website
result the attack code can be included
in the faked URL or in the HTTP
parameters it can affect the victim in
different ways by displaying faked
malicious page or by sending a malicious
email in a reflected cross- Sid
scripting example the input of a search
form is reflected on the page to show
what the search key was an attacker May
craft a URL that contains malicious code
and then spread the same URL via email
or social media a user who clicks on
this link opens the valid web
application which then runs the
malicious code in the browser the script
is not stored in the web application and
malicious code is shown only to one user
the user that opens the link executes
the script and the attack is not
necessarily visible on the server side
or to the app owner
itself the next variant is a store C
cross-side scripting attacks this occurs
when a malicious script is being saved
on the web server
permanently this can be considered a
riskier attack since it has leverage for
more damage in this type of attack the
malicious code or script is being saved
on the server for example in the
database of the website it is executed
every time the users call the
appropriate
functionality this way stored xss attack
can affect many users also as the script
is being stored on the web server it
will affect the website for a longer
time in order to perform stored xss
attack the malicious scripts should be
sent through the vulnerable input form
for example can be a comment field or a
review
field this way the appropriate script
will be saved in the database and
evaluated on the page load or
appropriate function
calling in a stored excess example the
script might have been submitted bya an
input field to the web server which did
not perform a efficient validation and
stores the script permanently in the
database the consequence of this might
be that the script is now being
delivered to all users visiting the web
application and for example able to gain
access to the user session
cookies in this attack the script is
permanently St in the web app the users
visiting the app after the information
retrieve the script the malicious code
then exploits the flaws in the web
application and the script and the
attack is visible on the server side or
to the app owner as
well the third variant is Dom based
cross-site scripting attacks this type
of attack occurs when the Dom
environment is being changed but the
client side code does not change when
the Dom environment is being modified in
the victim's browser the client side
code executes differently in order to
get a better understanding of how xss
Dom attack is being performed Let Us
analyze the following example if there
is a website called texting.com
we know default is a parameter therefore
in order to perform accss Dom attack we
should send a script as
parameters a Dom based xss attack may be
successfully executed even when the
server does not embed any malicious code
into the web page by using a flaw in the
JavaScript executed in the browser for
example if the client site JavaScript
modifies the Dom tree of the web page it
can be based on an input field or the
get parameter without validating the
input this allows the malicious code to
be
executed the malicious code the exploits
flaws in the browser on the user site
and the script and the attack is not
necessarily visible on the server side
or to the app
owner by now it is clear that cross-side
scripting attacks are difficult to
detect and even tougher to fight against
there are however plenty of PHS one can
Safeguard against such attacks let's go
through some of these preventive
measures
like mentioned earlier excesss attacks
are sometimes difficult to detect
however this can be changed if you get
some external help a way to prevent
accss attacks is using automated testing
tools like crash test security suit or
actic security
suit still manual testing is highly
timec consuming and costly and therefore
not possible to be done for every
iteration of your web
application consequently your code
should be untested before any release
using automated security you can scan
your web application for cross-side
scripting and other critical
vulnerabilities before every release
this way you can ensure that your web
application live version is still
secured whenever you alter or add a
feature input fields are the most common
point of entry for xss attack script
therefore you should always screen and
validate any information input into data
fields this is particularly important if
the data will be included as HTML output
this can be used to protect against
reflected exsus
attacks validation should occur on both
the client side and server side as an
added precaution this helps validating
the data before it's being sent to the
servers and can also protect against
persistent xss scripts this can be
accomplished using JavaScript xss
attacks only appear if any user input is
being displayed on the web page
therefore try to avoid displaying any un
trusted user input if possible if you
need to display user data restrict the
places where the user input might appear
any input displayed inside a JavaScript
tag or a URL shown on the site is much
more likely to be exploited than the
input that appears inside a division or
a span element inside the HTML body
protecting against accss vulnerabilities
typically requires properly escaping
user provided data that is placed on the
page rather than trying to determine if
the data is user provided and could be
compromised we should always play it
safe and Escape data whether it is user
provided or not unfortunately because
there are many different rules for
escaping you still must choose the
proper type of escaping before settling
on a final
code encoding should be applied directly
before user controllable data is written
to a page because the context you're
writing into determines what kind of
encoding you need to use for example
values inside a JavaScript string
require a different type of escaping to
those in an HTML context sometimes
you'll need to apply multiple layers of
encoding in the correct order for
example to safely embed user input
inside an event handler you need to deal
with both JavaScript context and the
HTML context so you need to First uni
code escape the input and then HTML
encoded content security policy or CSP
is a computer security standard introd
produced to prevent cross-site scripting
clickjacking and other code injection
attacks resulting from the execution of
malicious content in The Trusted web
page context it is a candidate
recommendations of the w3c working group
on web application security it's widely
supported by modern web browsers and
provides a standard method for website
owners to declare approved origins of
content that browser should be allowed
to load on that
website HTTP only is an additional flag
included in a set cookie HTTP response
header using the HTTP only flag when
generating a cookie helps mitigate the
risk of client side script accessing the
protected cookie that is if the browser
supports it if the HTTP only flag is
included in the HTTP response header the
cookie cannot be accessed through a
client side script again this is if the
browser supports the flag as a result
even if a cross-side scripting flaw
exists and a user accidentally accesses
a link that exploits this flop the
browser will not reveal the cookie to a
third
party if a browser does not support HTTP
only and a website attempts to set an
HTTP only cookie the HTTP only flag will
be ignored byow the browser thus
creating a traditional script accessible
cookie as a result the cookie becomes
vulnerable to theft of modification by
any malicious script next on our docket
is a live demonstration where we solve a
set of cross-site scripting problems
starting from the basic level to the
topmost level six we're going to start
at level
one in this web application it
demonstrates the common cause of
crosslite scripting where user input is
directly included in the page without
proper
escaping if you interact with a
vulnerable application window here and
find a way to make it execute JavaScript
of our choosing we can take actions
inside the vulnerable window or directly
edit its URL bar
this task needs only basic knowledge
let's see why the most primitive
injections work here right away let's do
a simple query and inspect the resulting
HTML
page I'm going to use this
phrase with a single quote as a special
character we can now inspect the HTML
page
we can see here in this
line the special character single code
appears in the result over
here the provided query text is placed
directly in a b tag as in a body element
we need to perform a reflected xss into
the web application because they are
nonpersistent xss attacks and the pillot
should be included in the URL to perform
successful exploitation
we can use any payload but we're going
to use the simple one to perform an
alert in this web application it's
simple and can be shown
easily just going to write the script
over
here
and we're going to press
search as you can see we have
successfully launched our first
cross-side scripting attack we can see
an alert box pop up with the necessary
message and a similar process can be
used to steal browser cookies and
passwords allbe it with different
commands now we have the option to move
to level
two in this web application it shows
that how easily accss bugs can be
introduced in complex chat
applications chat app conversations are
stored in a database and retrieved when
a user wants to see the conversation
therefore if a malicious user injects
some JavaScript code all visitors will
be infected this kind of cross-site
scripting attack is more powerful and it
is more riskier than reflected
cross-site scripting attacks and that's
why is known as stored
xss I posted my
query with a special character of a
single quote and this is what I
get whatever I typed in simply appeared
on the page right after I click on share
status let's see the
source you can see here the text I
posted seems directly put inside a block
code tag so even a simple script tag we
used in level one should work here but
it will not let us examine the code to
understand
why we're going to toggle the code over
here and check the index. HTML
file important
part is line
32 the generated HTML fragment which is
the HTML variable in the code is added
to the male HTML using the inner HTML
method so when the browser passing this
HTML fragment it will not execute any
script tag defined within that HTML
fragment HTML parer will not execute a
script tag when it passes htmls via this
method this is why the script tag like
we used in level one is not going to
work here our solution is to use events
events will execute the defined
javascripts we're going to use an image
over
here
and when we press on share
status in the above injection we are
loading an image that doesn't exist
which causes to trigger an on error
event in on error event the it will
execute our alert
method with that we are able to beat
level two and we can now move up to the
next level in our
challenge as you can see clicking on any
tab causes the tab number to be
displayed in the URL
fragment this hints that the value after
the hash #controls the behavior of the
page that is it is an input variable to
confirm let's analyze the
code as you can see in line 43 inside
the event
handling the value provided after the
hash in the
URL is directly passed onto the chew tab
method no input validation is being
performed the value passed to the choose
step method is directly injected into
the IMG tag in line
17 this is an unsafe assignment and it
is the vulnerable part of the code now
all we have to do now is to craft a
payload that would adjust the IMG tag to
execute our JavaScript remember the
script tag from level one would not work
here since the variable HTML is used to
add the Dom dynamically hence the event
friends are ases here once again I will
choose to use the existing IMG tag and
change the source to something that
doesn't exist hence forcing it to fall
into to execute an on error even which I
will pass the
URL
once we visit that URL we can see that
our Java popup has opened up here with
the same message of xss level 3 has been
completed with this we can now move on
to to level four which is going to
present a different kind of
attack in this application there is a
timer on the page that means whatever
numbers we put in the Box a countdown
starts and then when it finishes the
application alerts that the countdown is
finished and we can see the time is a
popup appearing over here and this
resets the timer again now it is obvious
that the value entered in the text box
is is transferred to the server over the
timer parameter in the
URL let us examine the code to see how
the timer parameter is being
handled we're going to visit timer. HTML
over
here and we're going to check over
here in line
21 the start timer method is being
called in the onload event however the
timer parameter is being directly passed
to the start timer method we need to
perform a popup Alert in the web
application which escapes the content of
the function start timer without
breaking the JavaScript
code the parameter value is directly
added to the start timer method without
any filtering what we can try to do here
is to inject an alert function to be
executed inside the on loone event along
with the start timer
method we're going to remove this
argument and put our script over
here
now I may press on create
timer and we have a popup with the xss
level 4
complete we can now move on to level
five in this web application this
application xss is different cuz this
challenge description says cross-site
scripting isn't just about corre
directly escaping
data sometimes attackers can do bad
things even without injecting new
elements into the Dom it's kind of open
redirect cu the attack payload is
executed as a result of modifying the
Dom environment in the victim's browser
this environment is used by the original
client side script so that the client
side code runs in an unexpected manner
the vulnerability can be easily detected
if the next Link in the signup page is
inspected
the href attribute value of next link is
confirm which is exactly the value of
the next URL query
parameter as you can see over here this
means using the next query parameter can
be used to inject a JavaScript code to
the href attribute of the next link the
following is the best way to do it as
soon as the user clicks on the link the
script will be
triggered
going to press anything random and now
that we click next we can see the xss
level 5 that we had provided in the URL
as a parameter to the next
variable since the value of next
provided appears on a popup we can
consider the attack a success and move
on to the final level
six in this sub application it shows
some of the external Javascript is
received if you analyze the the URL you
can see that the script is loaded
already the vulnerability lies within
how the code handles the value after the
hashtag if you check on line 45 the
value right after the hashtag is taken
as the gadget name and then in line
48 the value is directly passed on to
the include Gadget method and the
include Gadget method that we can see
over
here you can see in line
18 a script tag is created and the URL
Gadget name parameter value is directly
used as the source attribute of the
script tag in line
28 this means we can completely control
the source attribute of the script tag
that is being
created that is with this vulnerability
we can inject our own Javascript file
into the code we can inject a URL of our
own hosted JavaScript into the web
application URL after the hashtag and
the URL should not be using https but
anything like that to bypass the regular
expression for security
checking going to remove the pre-stored
URL and we're going to load our own
Javascript
file
finally we have reach the end of our
challenge we completed six different
varieties of cross scripting attacks and
used different solutions for all of the
six questions with work from home being
the norm in today's era people spend
considerable amount of time on the
internet often without specific measures
to ensure a secure session apart from
individuals organizations worldwide that
host data and conduct business over the
internet are always at the risk of a Dos
attack these DS attacks are getting more
extreme with hackers getting easy access
to bot net farms and compromised devices
as can be seen in the graph three of the
six strongest DDOS attacks were launched
in 2021 with the most extreme attack
occurring just last year in 2020 lately
cyber criminals have been actively
seeking out new services and protocols
for amplifying these DS attacks active
involvement with hacked machines and
botet allow further penetration into the
consumer space allowing much more
elaborate attack campaigns apart from
General users multinational corporations
have also had their fair share of
problems GitHub a platform for software
developers was the target of a DS attack
in 2018 widely suspected to be conducted
by Chinese authorities this attack went
on for about 20 minutes after which the
systems were brought into a stable
condition it was the strongest Doos
attack to date at the time and made a
lot of companies reconsider the security
practices to combat such attacks even
after years of experimentation Ros
attacks are still at large and can
affect anyone in the consumer and
corporate space hey everyone this is B
from Simply learn and welcome to this
video on what is a DS attack let's learn
more about what is a DS
attack a distributed denial of service
attack or dos is when an attacker or
attackers attempt to make it impossible
for a service to be delivered this can
be achieved by thating access to
virtually anything servers devices
Services networks applications and even
specific transactions within
applications in a Dos attack it's one
one system that is sending the malicious
data or requests a detos attack comes
from multiple systems generally these
attacks work by Drowning a system with
requests for data this could be sending
a web server so many requests to serve a
page that it crashes under the demand or
it could be a database being hit with a
high volume of queries the result is
available internet bandwidth CPU and RAM
capacity become
overwhelmed the impact could range from
a minor annoyance from disrupted
services to experiencing entire websites
applications or even entire businesses
taking offline more often than not these
attacks are launched using machines in a
botnet a botnet is a network of devices
that can be triggered to send requests
from a remote Source often known as the
command and control
center the bots in the network attack a
particular Target thereby hiding the
original perpetrator of the DS campaign
but how do these devices come under a
botnet and what are the requests being
made to the web servers let's learn more
about these and how DS attack
work a dedos attack is a two-phase
process in the first phase a hacker
creates a botnet of devices simply put a
vast network of computers are hacked via
malware ransomware or just simple social
engineering these devices become a part
of the botn net which can be triggered
anytime to start bombarding a system or
a server on the instruction of the
hacker that created the botn net the
devices in this networks are called Bots
or zombies in the second phase a
particular Target is selected for the
attack when the hacker finds the right
time to attack all the zombies in the
botnet network send these requests the
target thereby taking up all the servers
available bandwidth these can be simple
ping requests or complex attacks like SN
flooding and UDP flooding the aim is to
overwhelm them with more traffic than
the the server or the network can
accommodate the goal is to render the
website or service
inoperable there's a lot of wiggle room
when it comes to the type of DS attacker
hacker can go with depending on the
target's vulnerability we can choose one
of the three broad categories of DS
attacks volume based attacks use massive
amounts of bogus traffic to overwhelm a
resource it can be a website or a server
they include icmp udap and spoofed
packet flood attacks the size of volume
based attack is measured in bits per
second these attacks focus in clogging
all the available bandwidth for the
server thereby cutting the supply short
several requests are sent to the server
all of which warrant a reply thereby not
allowing the target to cater to the
general legitimate
users next we have the protocol level
attacks these attacks are meant to
consume essential resources of the
target server they exhaust the load
balances and Fire walls which are meant
to protect the system against the dors
attacks these protocol attacks include
SN floods and Smurf DDOS among others
and the size is measured in packets per
second for example in an SSL handshake
server replies to the Hello message sent
by the hacker which will be the client
in this case but since the IP is poofed
and leads nowhere the server gets stuck
in an endless loop of sending the
acknowledgement without any end in
sight finally we have the application
Level attacks application lay attacks
are conducted by flooding applications
with maliciously crafted requests the
size of application layer attacks is
measured in request per second these are
relatively sophisticated attacks that
Target the application and operating
system level
vulnerabilities they prevent the
specific applications from delivering
necessary information to users and hog
the network bandid up to the point of a
system crash examples of of such an
attack are HTTP flooding and bgp
hijacking a single device can request
data from a server using HTTP post or
get without any
issues however when the requisite botnet
is instructed to bombard the server with
thousands of requests the database
bandwidth gets jammed and it eventually
becomes unresponsive and
unusable but what about the reasons for
such an attack there are multiple lines
of thought as to why a hacker decides to
launch a Dos attack on unsuspected in
targets let's take a look at a few of
them the first option is to gain a
competitive Advantage many ds attacks
are conducted by hacking communities
against rival groups some organizations
hire such communities to stagger their
Rivals resources at a network level to
gain an advantage in the playing field
since being a victim of a dets attack
indicates a lack of security the
reputation of such a company takes a
significant hit allowing the rivals to
cover up some ground
secondly some hackers launch these DS
attacks to hold multinational
corporations at Ransom the resources are
jammed and the only way to clear the way
is if the target company agrees to pay a
designated amount of money to the
hackers even a few minutes of inactivity
is detrimental to a company's reputation
in the global market and it can cause a
spiral effect both in terms of market
value and product security index most of
the time a compromise is reached and the
resources are freed after a
while Doos attacks have also found use
in the political segment certain
activists tend to use dedos attacks to
voice their opinion spreading the word
online is much faster than any local
Rally or Forum primarily political these
attacks also focus on online communities
ethical dilemas or even protest against
corporations let's take a look at a few
ways that companies and individuals can
protect themselves against dedos attacks
the company can employ load balancers
and firewalls to help protect the data
from such attacks load balancers reroute
the traffic from one server to another
in a DS attack this reduces the single
point of failure and adds resiliency to
the server data a firewall blocks
unwanted traffic into a system and
manages the number of requests made at a
definite rate it checks for multiple
attacks from a single IP and occasional
slowdowns to detect a DS attack in
action
early detection of a dor attack goes a
long way in recovering the data lost in
such an event once you've detected the
attack you will have to find a way to
respond for example you will have to
work on dropping the malicious G dos
traffic before it reaches your server so
that it doesn't throttle and exhaust
your bandwidth here's where you will
filter the traffic so that only
legitimate traffic reaches the server by
intelligent routing you can break the
remaining traffic into manageable chunks
that can be handled by your cluster
resources the most important stage in
DOS mitigation is where you will look
for patterns of Dos attacks and use
those to analyze and strengthen your
mitigation techniques for example
blocking an IP that's repeatedly found
to be offending is a first
step Cloud providers like Amazon web
services and Microsoft Azure who offer
high levels of cyber security including
firewalls and threat monitoring software
can help protect your assets and network
from De OS criminals the cloud also has
greater bandwidth than most private
networks so it is likely to fail if
under the pressure of increased stos
attacks additionally reputable Cloud
providers offer Network redundancy
duplicating copies of your data systems
and equipment so that if your service
becomes corrupted or unavailable due to
a DDS attack you can switch to a secure
access on backed up versions without
missing a beat one can also increase the
amount of bandwidth AA available to a
host server being targeted since GS
attacks fundamentally operate on the
principle of overwhelming systems with
heavy traffic simply provisioning extra
bandwidth to handle unexpected traffic
spikes can provide a measure of
protection this solution can prove
expensive as a lot of that bandwidth is
going to go unused most of the
time a Content delivery Network or a CDN
distributes your content and boost
performance by minimizing the distance
between your resources and end users it
stores the cached version of your
content in multiple locations and this
eventually mitigates dos attacks by
avoiding a single point of failure when
the attacker is trying to focus on a
single Target popular CDN include acomi
CDN Cloud flare AWS cloudfront
Etc let's start with our demo regarding
the effects of DS attacks on a system
for a demo we have a single device that
will attack a Target making it a dos
attack of sorts once a bot net is ready
multiple devices can do the same and
eventually emulate a do DOS attack to do
so we will use the virtualization
software called VMware with an instance
of parro security operating system
running for a Target machine we will be
running another vmw instance of a
standard Linux distribution known as
Linux light in a Target device we can
use wire shark to determine when the
attack begins and see the effects of the
attack OCC
accordingly this is Linux light which is
a target machine and this is parad
security which is used by the hacker
when trying to launch a DS attack this
is just one of the dros that can be
used to launch the attack we must first
find the IP address of our
Target so to find the IP address we open
the
terminal
we use the command if
config and here we can find the IP
address now remember we're launching
this attack in VMware now the both the
instances of parro security and Linux
light are being run on my local network
so the address that you can see here is
192.168
72129 which is a private address this IP
cannot be accessed from outside the
network basically anyone who is not
connected to my Wi-Fi when launching
attacks with public servers or public
addresses it will have a public IP
address that does not belong to the
subnet once we have the IP
address we can use a tool
called hping
3 hping 3 is an open-source packet
generator and analyzer for the TCP IP
protocol to check check what are the
effects of an attack we will be using
wire shark wire shark is a network
traffic analyzer we can see whatever
traffic that is passing through the
Linux light drro is being displayed over
here with the IP address the source IP
and the destination IP as to where the
request is being transferred to once we
have the Dos attack launched you can see
the results coming over here from The
Source IP which will be parot security
Now to launch the HP 3 command we need
to give pseudo access to the console
which is the root
access now we have the root AIS for the
console the hping 3 command will have a
few arguments to go with it which are as
you can see on the
screen minus s and a
flood a hyphen
V hyphen p18 and the IP address of the
target which is 1921 168
72129 in this command we have a few
arguments that such as the minus s which
specifies SN packets like in an SSL
handshake we have the syn request that
the client sends to the server to
initiate a connection The Hyphen flood
aims to ignore the replies that the
server will send back to the client in
response to the SN packets here the
parent security OS is the client and
Linux slide being the
server minus v stands for verbosity as
in where we will see some output when
the requests are being sent the hyphen
p80 stands for Port 80 which we can
replace the port number if we want to
attack a different port and finally we
have the IP address of our Target as of
right now if we check wire shock it is
relatively clear and there is no
indication of a DS attack incoming now
once we launch the attack over
here we can see the requests coming in
from this IP which is 192 168 72.1
128 till now even if the network is
responsive and so is Linux
light the request keep on coming and we
can see the
HTTP flooding has started in flood
mode after a few seconds of this attack
continuing the server will start
shutting down now remember Linux light
is a drro that can focus on and that
serves as a
backend now remember Linux light is a
drro and such Linux DRS are served as
backend to many servers across the world
for example a few seconds have passed
from the attack now the system has
become completely irresponsive this has
happened due to the huge number of
requests that came from par
security you can see whatever I press
nothing is responded even the wi shock
has dropped capturing new request
because the CPU usage right now is
completely 100% and at this point of
time anyone who is trying to request
some information from this Linux drro or
where this Linux drro is being used as a
backend for a server or a database
cannot access anything else the system
has completely stopped responding and
any request any legitimate request from
legitimate users will be
dropped once you stop the attack over
here it takes a bit of time to settle
down now remember it's still out of
control but eventually the traffic dies
down and the system regains its strength
it is relatively easy to gauge right now
the effect of a Dos attack now remember
this Linux light is just a VM instance
actual website servers and web databases
they have much more bandwidth and are
very secure and it is tough to break
into that is why we cannot use a single
machine to break into them that is where
a DS attack comes into play what we did
right now is a Dos attack as in a single
system is being used to penetrate a
Target server using a single request now
when a d attack multiple systems such as
multiple Pirro security instances or
multiple zombies or bots in a botnet
network can attack a Target server to
completely shut down the machine and
drop any legitimate request thereby
rendering the service and the target
completely unusable and
inoperable as a final note we would like
to remind that this is for educational
purposes only and we do not endorse any
attacks on any domains only test this on
servers and networks that you have
permission to test on cyber security has
become one of the most rigid Industries
in the last decade while simultaneously
being the most challenged with every
aspect of corporate culture going online
and embracing cloud computing there is a
plethora of critical data circulating
through the internet all worth billions
of dollars to the right person
increasing benefits require more complex
attacks and one of these attacks is a
Brute Force attack a brute force or
known as Brute Force cracking is the
Cyber attack equivalent of trying every
key on your key ring and eventually
finding the right one bruteforce attacks
are simple and reliable there is no
prior knowledge needed about the victim
to start an attack most of the systems
following prey to Brute Force attacks
are actually well
secured attackers let a computer do the
work that is trying different
combinations of usernames and passwords
until they find a one that works due to
this repeated trial and error format the
strength of password matters a great Dr
although with enough time and resources
brute force will break a system since
they run multiple combinations until
they find the right passcode hey
everyone this is B from Simply learn and
welcome to this video on what is a Brute
Force attack let's begin with learning
about Brute Force attacks in
detail a Brute Force attack also known
as an exhaustive search is a
cryptographic hack that relies on
guessing possible combinations of
targeted password until the current
password is discovered
it can be used to break into online
accounts encrypted documents or even
Network peripheral devices the longer
the password the more combinations that
will need to be tested a Brute Force
attack can be timec consuming and
difficult to perform if methods such as
data officiation are used and at times
downright
impossible however if the password is
weak it could merely take seconds with
hardly any effort dictionary attacks are
an alternative to Brute Force attacks
where the attacker already has a list of
usernames and passwords that need to be
tested against the target it doesn't
need to create any other combinations on
its own dictionary attacks are much more
reliable than brute force in a real
world context but the usefulness depends
entirely on the strength of passwords
being used by the general
population there is a three-step process
when it comes to brute forcing a system
let's learn about each of them in
detail in step one we have to settle on
a tool that we are going to use for
brute forcing there are some popular
names on the market like
hashcat Hydra and John the Ripper while
each of them has its own strength and
weaknesses each of them perform well
with the right configuration all of
these tools come pre-installed with
certain Linux distributions that cater
to penetration testers and cyber
security analysts like K Linux and parot
security after deciding what tool to use
we can start generating combinations of
alpha numeric variables whose only
limitation is the number of characters
for example while using Hydra a single
six-digit password will create 900,000
passwords with only digits involved add
alphabets and symbols to that sample
space and that numbers grows
exponentially the popular tools allow
customizing this process let's say the
hacker is aware of the password being a
specific 8-digit word containing only
letters and symbols this will
substantially increase the chances of
being able to guess the right password
since we remove the time taken to
generate the longer ones we omit the
need for including digits in such
combinations these small tweaks go a
long way in organizing an efficient
Boost Force attack since running all the
combinations with no filters will
dramatically reduce the odds of finding
the right credentials in time in the
final step we run these combinations
against the file or service that is
being broken we can try and break break
into a specific encrypted document a
social media account or even devices at
home that connect to the internet let's
say there is a Wi-Fi router the
generated passwords are then fed into
the connection one after the other it is
a long and uous process but the work is
left to the computer other than someone
manually clicking and checking each of
these
passcodes any password that doesn't
unlock the router is discarded and The
Brute Force tool simply moves on to the
next one this keeps going on until we
find the right combination which unlocks
the
router sometimes reaching the success
stage takes days and weeks which makes
it cumbersome for people with low
computing power at their disposal
however the ability to crack any system
in the world purely due to bad password
habits is very appealing and the general
public tends to stick with simple and
easy to ous
passwords now that we have a fair idea
about how Brute Force Works let's see if
you can answer this question we learned
about how complex passwords are tougher
to crack by Brute Force among the ones
listed on the screens which one do you
believe will take the longest to be
broken when using Brute Force tools
leave your answers in the comment
section and we will get back to you with
the correct option next
week let's move on to the harmful
effects of getting a system compromised
due to Brute Force
attacks a hacked laptop or mobile can
have social media accounts logged in
giving the hackers free access to the
victim's connections it has been
reported on multiple occasions where
compromised Facebook accounts are
sending malicious Lings and attachments
to people on their friends
list one of the significant reasons for
hacking malware infusion is best done
when spread from multiple devices
similar to Distributing spam this
reduces the chance of circling back the
source to a single device which belongs
to the hacker once brute forced A system
can spread malware by via email
attachments sharing links file upload
via FTP
Etc personal information such as credit
card data usage habits private images
and videos are all stored in our systems
be it in plain format or root folders a
compromised laptop means easy access to
these information that can be further
used to impersonate the victim regarding
Bank verification among other
things once a system is hacked it can
also be used as a mail server they
distributees spam across lists of
victims since the hack machines all have
different IP addresses and Mac addresses
it becomes challenging to trace the spam
back to the original hacker with so many
harmful implications arising from a boot
Force attack it's imperative that the
general public must be protected against
such let's learn about some of the ways
we can prevent ourselves from becoming a
victim of Brute Force
attacks using passwords consisting of
alphabets letters and numbers have a
much higher chance of withstanding bu
Force attacks thanks to the sheer number
of combinations they can produce the
longer the password the less likely it
is that a hacker will devote the time
and resources to brute force them having
alpha numeric passwords also allows the
user to keep different passwords for
different websites this is to ensure
that if a single account or password is
compromised due to a breach or a hack
the rest of the accounts are isolated
from the
incident two-factor authentication
involves receiving a one-time password
on a trusted device before a new login
is allowed this OTB can be obtained
either via email SMS or specific 2fa
applications like Ai and agis email and
SMS based otps are considered relatively
less secure nowadays due to the ease
with which SIM cards can be duplicated
and mailboxes can be hacked applications
that are specifically made for 2A course
are much more reliable and secure
captas are used to stop Bots from
running through web pages precisely to
prevent brute forcing through their
website since boot Force tools are
automated forcing the hacker to solve
capture for every iteration of a
password manually is very challenging
the capture system can filter out these
automated Bots that keep refreshing the
page with different credentials thereby
reducing the chances of BR Force
considerably a definite rule that locks
the account being hacked for 30 minutes
after a specific number of attempts is a
good way to prevent Brute Force attempts
many websites lock account for 30
minutes after three failed password
attempts to secure the account against
any such attack on an additional note
some websites also send an email
instructing the user that there have
been three insecure attempts to log into
the
website let's look at a demonstration of
how Brute Force attacks work in a real
world situation the world has gone
Wireless with Wi-Fi taking the re in
every household it's natural that the
security will always be up for debate to
further test the security index and
understand Brute Force attacks you will
attempt to break into the password of a
Wi-Fi router for that to happen you
first need to capture a handshake file
which is a connection file from the
Wi-Fi router to a connecting device like
a mobile or a laptop the operating
system used for this process is parot
security a Linux distribution that is
catered to penetration testers
all the tools being used in this demo
can easily be found pre-installed in
this operating system if getting your
learning started is half the battle what
if you could do that for free visit
scaleup by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know
more to start our demo we're going to
use a tool called airgeddon which is
made to hack into wireless network
specifically at this point it's going to
check for all the necessary scripts that
are installed in the
system to crack into a Wi-Fi and to
capture the handshake file we're going
to need an external network card the
significance of the external network
card is a managed mode and a monitor
mode for now the W lx1 named card is my
external network adapter which I'm going
to select to be able to capture data
over the air we're going to need to put
it in monitor mode as you can see above
it's written it is in managed mode right
now so we're going to select option two
which is to put the interface in monitor
mode and its name is now w0
monitor the monitor mode is necessary to
capture data over the air that is the
necessary reason why we need an external
card since a lot of inbuilt cards that
come with the laptops and the systems
they cannot have a monitor mode
installed once we select the mode we can
go into the fifth which is the handshake
tools
menu in the first step we have to
explore for targets and it is written
that monitor mode is necessary to select
a Target so let's explore for
targets and press
enter we have to let this run for about
60 seconds to get a fair idea about the
networks that are currently working in
this locality for example this ESS ID is
supposed to be the Wi-Fi name that we
see when connecting to a network go24
recover me these are all the names that
we see on our mobile when trying to
search for the Wi-Fi this BSS ID is
supposed to be an identifier somewhat
like a MAC address that identifies this
network from other devices the channels
features on one or two or there are some
many channels that the networks can
focus
on this here is supposed to be a client
that is connected to one such Network
for
example the station that you can see 56
26 this is supposed to be the MAC
address of the device that is connected
to a router this BSS ID is supposed to
be which wi-fi it is connected to for
example 5895 d8 is this one which is the
go24 router so we already know which
router has a device connected to it and
we can use our attack to capture this
handshake now that we it has already run
for 1 minute now that we press contrl
C it will be asked to select a Target
see it has already selected the number
five which is the ge24 router as the one
with clients so it is easy to run an
attack on and it is easy to capture a
handshake
for select Network 5 and we run a
capture
handshake it says we have a valid WPA
WPA2 Network Target selected and that
the script can
continue now to capture the handshake we
have a couple of attacks a do or a do
air replay attack what this attack does
is kick the clients out of the network
in return when they try to reconnect to
the Wi-Fi as they are configured that
way that when a client is disconnected
it tries to reconnect it immediately it
tries to capture a handshake file which
in turn contains the security key which
is necessary to initiate the
handshake for our demo let's go with the
second option that is the do air replay
attack select a timeout value let's say
we give it 60
seconds and we start the
script we can see it capturing data from
the ge24 network and here we go we have
the WPA handshake
file once the handshake file is captured
can actually close this and here we go
congratulations in order to capturing a
handshake it has verified that a pmk ID
from the target network has successfully
been captured this is the file that is
already stored a do cap file for the
path we can let's say we can keep it in
a
desktop okay we give the
path and the Hand Shi file is generated
we can already see a Target over here
same G2 for router with the BSS
ID now if we return to its main
menu we already have the handshake file
captured with us now our job is to Brute
Force into that handshake capture file
the capture file is often encrypted with
the security key of the Wi-Fi network if
we know how to decrypt it we will
automatically get the security key so
let's go to the offline WPA wp2 decrypt
menu since we'll be cracking personal
networks we can go with option
one now to run the Brute Force tool we
have two options either we can go with
the air crack or we can go with the
hashcat let's go with air crack plus
crunch which is a Brute Force attack
against a handshake file we can go with
option
two it can already detect the capture
file that we have generated so we select
yes the BSS ID is is the one which
denotes the go24 router so we're going
to select yes as well the minimum length
of the key for example it has already
checked that the minimum length of a
Wi-Fi security key which is a WPA2 psk
key will always be more than eight
digits and Below 64 digits so we have to
select something in between this range
so if we already know let's say that the
password is at least 10 digits we can go
with the minimum length as 10 and as a
rough guess let's say we put the maximum
length as
20 the character set that we going to
use for checking the password will
affect the time taken to Brute Force for
example if we already know that or we
have seen a user use the password while
connecting to the router as something
that has only numbers and symbols then
we can choose accordingly let's say if
we go with only uppercase characters and
numeric
characters go with option
seven and it's going to start
scripting so how aircrack is working
right here you can see this fast phrase
over here the first five or six digits
are a it starts working its way from the
end from the last character it keeps
drawing every single combination you can
see the last the fourth character from
the right side the D it will eventually
turn to
e because it keeps checking up every
single character from the and this will
keep going on until all the single
characters are tested and every single
combination is tried out since the
handshake file is encrypted using the
security key that is the WPA2 key of the
router whichever pass phrase is able to
decrypt the handshake key completely
will be the key of the Wi-Fi router this
is the way we can Brute Force into Wi-Fi
routers anywhere in the world simple
learn offers postgraduate program in
cyber security when the complete cuse
details from the link in the description
box internet is an endless source of
information and data still in some cases
we come across some occurrences like
cyber attacks hacking force entry which
may affect a Time on the web this is
June she works in a business firm where
she manages the company's data
regularly this is Jacob from the
information Department who is here to
inform her about some of the security
protocols during the briefing she
informed him about some of the problems
a system was facing with which included
slow reaction speed and unusual internet
activity as Jacob heard about the
problems with the system he thinks of
the possibility what could be the reason
behind these problems a system was
facing
with the conclusion that he came across
was the key loging
issue unknown to the problem her system
was facing with she asked him about some
of the details regarding
it
for today's topic we learn what exactly
key loggers are and how they fails to
its origin where they can be used for
malicious acts by the
hacker now that we know what the key
logging program is let's take a look how
they enter into the
system searching for a suitable driver
for a system can often lead to the
installation of the key loging program
into the system if we often visit
suspicious sites and uncertified
software are in installed into our
system then if we use unknown links or
visiting unknown websites which come
through unknown addresses can also be a
reason behind the key logging issue
entering into the system and lastly
there are often cases where different
popups that we often see on social sites
or different media sites can lead to the
installation of key loging program into
our
system now that we know how the problem
gets into the system let's take a look
how to identify whether the system is
infected by the key logging
issue the key logging issue can be
identified if there are often cases when
a keyboard lags behind the system the
data that we enter sometimes is stuck in
between when we type through the
input then there are cases when the
system freeze occurs unknowingly to what
exactly could be the reason behind them
and and also there are delayed reaction
time for different applications that run
on the system and lastly there are
different cases when we often see
suspicious internet activity on the
system that we don't know about this
could lead to the identification of a
problem into the
system now we'll take a look at
different types of key loggers that are
present on the net which can harm our
system
differently the first problem that key
loggers arouse is API based the most
common key logging case which uses API
to keep a log of the type data and share
it to its origin for malicious purposes
each time we press a key the key logger
intercepts the signal and logs it then
we have form grabbing based key loggers
as the name suggest they are a based key
loggers that store the form data that is
if we often use web forms or different
kinds of forms to enter different data
they can be recorded into the system by
the program and send it to its
origin then we have kernel based key
loggers these key loggers are installed
deeply into the operating system where
they can hide from different antivirus
if not checked properly and they record
the data that we type on the keyboard
and send it to its
origin and lastly we have Hardware Key
loggers these key loggers are present
directly into the hardware that is they
are embedded into system where they
record the data that we type on the
keyboard now let's take a look how
hackers differentiate different type of
recorded data and exploit
them when hackers receive information
about the target they might use it to
Blackmail the target which may affect
the personal life of the Target and also
blackmail them for different money
related
issues then in case of company data that
is recorded by the key logging program
can also affect the economic value of
the company in the market which may lead
to the downfall of the
company also in some cases the key
logging program can also log data about
military Secrets which may include
nuclear codes or security protocols
which are necessary to maintain the
security of a
country
now let's take a look whether mobile
devices get infected with the key loging
issue or
not in the case of hand devices
infection of key loggers are low in
comparison to the computer systems as
they use onscreen keyboard or virtual
keyboard but in some cases we often see
different tyes of malicious programs
getting installed into the hand device
if we often visit different uncertified
websites or illegal websites or torrent
sites and also the device that is
infected with the key logging issue or
different kind of malicious program can
often lead to the exploitation of data
that includes photos emails or important
files by the hacker or the Cyber
criminal that install the particular
malicious program into the
system now to prevent our system from
getting infected by the key locking
program let's take a look at different
points the first point includes using of
different antivirus softwares or tools
which can prevent the entering a
malicious program into the
system then keeping system security
protocols regularly updated is also a
good
habit and lastly using virtual keyboard
to input our sensitive data which may
include Bank details login details or
different passwords related to different
websites now that we have some
understanding about the topic of key
loggers let's take a look at the demo to
further increase the knowledge about the
topic for the first step we have to
download some of the important libraries
that are required into the
system which
is this library now we'll run
it the system says the library is
already installed into the system now
let's take a look what exactly modules
are required from the particular
library from this Library we'll
import the keyboard module which will
help us to record the data that we type
on the
keyboard now from the same we'll also
import key
module and The Listener
module
and
also the logging module which will help
us to record the data into a log
file for the next part we'll write a
piece of code that will allow us to save
the data that is recorded by the program
into a text file that will be named as
keor log text file along with the date
and time stamp let's take a
look
now we'll provide it with the file
name that will be given
as key log do txt
file and also so the part where the
format of the data is
recorded put the brackets over here to
contain the file name now we'll write
the format in which the data will be
recorded into the log file which will be
given
as the format would be the message and
the Tim stamp which would be given
as
along with the time
stamp
percentage and ending it with the
bracket now for the next step we'll
design two of the functions that will be
used into the program that will be
termed as while press function and while
release function let's take a
look while press
function would be a function that will
come into play when the keyboard key has
been
pressed
is
and this would go for the format that we
designed in the above
line
and
logging the Pressed
key
info a string file to be
recorded into the lock file file
now now we'll design a function that is
while
release that will come into play
fin the Escape key has been pressed that
is the program will terminate itself and
the program will stop from
running and in the
end we require for the functioning of
the program to Loop these functions that
is while press and while release to
continue its
cycle
that will be going for while
press
and
on release will contain while
release
function
as list
now
and now this part would join the
different threads and store them into
the loog file now that we have completed
the code for the program let's run
it we have to wait for a moment so the
program runs it
now to verify the program let's open
Notepad
and on the notepad we'll
write hello
world which will be the basic whether
the program is working or not let's take
a
look and we'll go for the main page on
Jupiter notebook and refresh the page go
to the
bottom over here we see the key log text
that is the text file that we created
let's open
it and over here we have the data that
is created as we started with Note then
this is the hello world part that we
created just
now we shows that the program we created
is working properly now that we have
reached the end of the module let's take
a look at the summary firstly we learn
what exactly key logos are then we
understood what different modes are
present how the system get infected with
the key logging problem then we learned
how to detect the problem into our
system then we learn what different
types of key loggers are present on the
net we also understood how hackers used
the recorded data from the program and
we also learn whether mobile devices get
infected with the key logging problem or
not and lastly we understood what
different points can be taken to prevent
the entering of the key logging problem
into this system before we learn about
the Pegasus platform let us understand
what spyware is and it's working spyware
is a category of malware that can gather
information regarding a user or a device
straight from the host machine it is
mostly spread by malicious links via
email or chat applications when a link
with the malware is received clicking on
this link will activate the spyware
which allows the hacker to spy on all
our user information with some spyer
systems even clicking on the link isn't
necessary to to trigger the malicious
payload this can ultimately cause
security complications and further loss
of privacy one such SP system that is
making the rounds in the tech industry
today is Pegasus the Pegasus is a
spyware system developed by an Israeli
company known as the NSO group it runs
on mainly mobile devices spanning across
the major operating systems like the
Apple's IOS on iPhone and the standard
Android versions this is not a newly
developed platform since Pegasus has
existed since as early as 2016 a highly
intricate spy program that can track
user location read text messages scan
through mobile files access device
camera and microphone to record voice
and video Pegasus has all the tools
necessary to enforce surveillance for
any client that wishes to buy its
services initially the NSO group had
designed the software to be used against
terrorist factions of the world with
more and more encrypted communication
channels coming to the Forefront Pegasus
was designed to to maintain control over
the data transmission that can be a
threat to National Security
unfortunately the people who bought the
software had complete control over who
how and up to what level they can put
surveillance limits on eventually the
primary clients became Sovereign Nations
spying on Public Information that is
supposed to stay private became really
easy with the service multiple devices
can be affect With the same spyer system
to create a network information this
network keeps feeding data to the host
to understand how a network can be
created let's know how a mobile device
can be affected by Pegasus we all
communicate with friends and family over
instant messaging applications and email
in some instances if you check your
inbox on a regular basis you must have
noticed that we received some spam
emails that the mail providers like
Gmail and Yahoo can just filter into the
spam folder some of these messages
bypass this filter and make their way
into a person's inbox they look like
generic emails which are supposed to be
safe the Pegasus pyware targets such
occurrences by passing malicious
messages and links which install the
necessary Spy software on the user's
mobile device be it Android or an iPhone
this isn't unique to the email ecosystem
since it's equally likely to be targeted
by SMS text WhatsApp Instagram or even
the most secure messaging apps like
signal and threa once the malicious
links are clicked a spyware package is
downloaded and installed on the device
after the Spy is successfully installed
the perpetrator who send the payload to
the victim can monitor everything the
user does Pegasus can collect private
emails passwords images videos and every
other piece of information that passes
to the device Network all this data is
transmitted back to the central server
where the primary spying organization
can monitor the activities at a granular
level this is not even surface level
since complex py software like Pegasus
can access those root files on our
mobiles these root files hold
information that is crucial to the
working of the Android and iOS operating
systems leaking such private information
is a massive blow to the security and
the privacy of an individual the
information that may seem trivial like
the name of your Wi-Fi connection or the
last time you ordered an item from
Amazon are indeed all valuable
information this exploitation is
primarily possible due to the zero day
vulnerabilities known as bugs in the
software development process
the zero de bugs are the ones that have
just been discovered by some independent
security company or a researcher once
they are found reporting these
vulnerabilities to the developer of the
platform which would be either Google
for Android or Apple for iOS is the
right thing to do however many such
critical bugs make their way onto the
dark web where hackers can use them to
create exploits these exploits are then
sent to innocent users with a link or a
message like we had discussed before
Pegasus was able to affect the latest
devices with the all the security
patches installed but some bugs are not
reported to the developers or just
cannot be fixed without breaking some
core functionality these become the
Gateway for spyware to enter into the
system you can never be 100% safe but
you sure can give it all in protecting
yourself the one thing where Pegasus
stands out is a zero click action
feature usually in spam emails the
malicious code is activated when the
user clicks the malware link a user
doesn't need to click the link in the
new version of the Pegasus and a few
other spyware programs once the message
arrives in the inbox of WhatsApp Gmail
or any other chat applications the
spyware gets activated and everything
can be recorded and sent back to the
central server the primary issue with
being affected by spyware as a victim is
detection unlike Crypt Miners and troan
spying Services usually do not demand
many system resources which makes them
tough to detect after they have been
activated
since many devices slow down after a
couple of years any kind of Performance
Set due to such spyware is often
attributed to poor software longetivity
by the users they do not check
meticulously for any other causes that
is causing the Slowdown when left
unchecked these devices can capture
voice and video from the mobile sensors
while keeping the owner in the dark
let's take a moment to check if we are
well aware of the causes of such attacks
how do users fall pre to such spyware
programs a by installing untested
software B by clicking on the third
party links from email and messages C by
not keeping the apps and phones updated
or D all of the above let us know your
answers in the comment section below and
we will rev the correct answer next week
but what about the unaffected devices
the vulnerable ones while we cannot be
certain of our security there are a few
things we can do to boost our device be
it against Pegasus or the next big SP on
the market let's let's say we are safe
now and we have the time to take the
necessary steps to prevent a spyware
attack what are the things we can go for
a primary goal must always be to keep
our apps and the operating system
updated the latest security patches the
vulnerabilities that the explo target
are often discovered by developers from
Google and apple which send the security
patches quickly this can be done for
individual apps as well so keeping them
updated is of utmost importance while
the most secure devices have fallen pre
to Pegasus as well a security patch from
developers may help in minimizing the
damage at a later stage or maybe negate
the entire spyware platform alog
together another big factor is the
spread of malware is the trend of
sideloading Android applications using
do APK files downloading such apps from
a third party website have no security
checks involved and are mostly
responsible for adware and spy invasions
on user devices avoiding the side
loading of apps would be a major step in
protecting
yourself we often receive spam emails or
texts from people we may not know on
social medias they are accompanied with
links that allow malware to creep into
our device we should try to follow the
trusted websites and not click on any
links that redirect us to unknown
domains spyer is a controversial segment
in governance while the ramifications
are pretty extreme in theory it severely
impacts user privacy against
authoritarian regimes sufficient
resources and a contingent plan can
alter the false veale of democracy
altogether even if our daily life is
rather simplistic we must understand
that privacy is not about what we have
to hide instead it portrays the things
we have to protect it stands for
everything we have to share with the
outside world both theorically and
literally hey everyone today we look at
the hack which took the World by storm
and affected multiple governments and
corporations the solar wind attack the
global statistics indicate that upward
of 18,000 customers have been affected
potentially needing billions to recover
the losses incurred before we have a
look at this hack Make sure to subscribe
to our Channel and hit the notification
Bell to never miss an update from Simply
learn the date is December 8th 2020 fire
a global leader in company specializing
in cyber security released a blog post
that caught the attention of the entire
it Community a software known as Orion
which was developed by solar wison
incorporat had become a victim of a
remote access Trojan or a rat
the breach was estimated to be running
since the spring of 2020 and went
virtually unnoticed for months the
reveal sent the developers of the Orion
software into a frenzy as they quickly
released a couple of hot fixes for their
platform in order to mitigate this
threat and prevent further damage but
how did this come into existence we
first need to understand the platform
which was responsible for this preach
solo a software company based in Texas
United States had developed a management
platform known as Orion entering to to
corporations and governments worldwide
Oran was responsible for the monitoring
and management of it Administration this
included managing the client servers
virtualization components and even the
organizations Network infrastructure
that bought the platform solar winds
claims they have more than 300,000
clients including US government agencies
and several Fortune 500 companies this
entire chain can be classified as a
supply chain attack in this variant of
cyber crime the hackers Target
relatively weaker links in and
organization's chain of control and
delivery these are preferbly services
rendered by a third party since there is
no direct jurisdiction over it in this
case the Orion platform was the primary
target the culprit however was software
updates the update server for solarin
Orion had a malicious version attached
with malware or a Trojan to be precise
this was made possible since the code
repository that handled the software
updates was breached once the update
server repository was compromised the
source code of the application became
open to modification and malicious code
found its way onto the software the
remote access troen was attached to a
potential update nicknamed the Sunburst
update this update gave hackers pack
door access to any client that uses the
correct version on its release many
clients believed the update to be
legitimate since it came from the right
source and they had no reason to believe
otherwise American government agencies
were supposedly hit the hardest as the
list of victims included the US
Departments of Homeland Security
Treasury and health several private
companies like Cisco Nvidia and Intel
were compromised according to a list
published by the cyber security firm
trusk most of the companies had issued
quick updates to fix these
vulnerabilities introduced by the
software while the actual perpetrators
have never been found it is believed
that this was an act of crossborder
corporate Espionage conducted by state
sponsored hackers either from Russia or
China before we move forward let's take
a recap of the things we learned
what category of malware was responsible
for the solar wind hack was it one a
virus a remote access Trojan a spyware
or a worm let us know your answers in
the comment section right away and we
will reveal the correct answer in a week
coming to possible reparations the Biden
government has launched a full
investigation on the effects and the
repercussions of this breach there are a
couple of things that we as consumers
must always tend to when working our way
through the worldwide web using a
password manager is highly recommended
which can generate secure alpha numeric
passwords you must also use different
passwords for different accounts thereby
reducing the chances of a single point
of failure should one of those accounts
get breached usage of two-factor
authentication applications is also
encourag since it acts as a safety net
if hackers directly get a hold of our
credentials clicking on unknown links
transmitted via emails is also a strict
no as is installing applications from
unverified sources the solar wind hack
is estimated to cost the parent company
nearly $18 million as reparations making
it one if not the biggest hacks in
cyberspace history as recently as of
July 2021 the hackers accessed some us
attorneys Microsoft 365 email accounts
as part of the attack criminal
organizations like the FBI and CIA are
determined to figure out the culprits
responsible for this debacle however the
intricacy and the full extent of the
breach makes it a way more complicated
job than it looks on paper Dees
algorithm stands for data encryption
standard it is a symmetric key Cipher
that is used to encrypt and recpt
information in a block byblock manner
each block is encrypted individually and
they later chained together to form our
final Cipher text which is then sent to
a receiver DS takes the original
unaltered piece of data called the plain
text in a 64-bit block and it is
converted into an encrypted text that is
called the cipher text it uses 48 bit
Keys during during the encryption
process and follows a specific structure
called the fistal Cipher structure
during the entire process it is a
symmetric key algorithm which means DS
can reuse the keys used in the
encryption format to decrypt the cipher
text back to the original plane text
once the 64-bit blocks are encrypted
they can be combined together before
being
transmitted let's take a look at the
origin and the reason Dees was
founded Dees is based on a fistal block
dier called Lucifer developed in 1971 by
IBM cryptography researcher host fist
Dees uses 16 rounds of this Fel
structure using a different key for each
round it also utilizes a random function
with two inputs and provides a single
output
variable the became the organization's
approved encryption standard in November
1976 and was later reaffirmed as a
standard in 1983 1988 and finally in
1999 but eventually DS was cracked and
it was no longer considered a secure
solution for all official roots of
communication consequently triple Ds was
developed triple Ds is a symmetric key
block Cipher that uses a double Ds
Cipher encrypt with a first key delete
encryption with the second key and
encrypt again with a third key there is
also a variation of the two keys where
the first and second key are duplicate
of each other but triple Ds was
ultimately deemed too slow for the
growing need for fast communication
channels and people eventually fell back
to using DS for encrypting messages in
order to search for a better alternative
a public wide competition was organized
and helped cryptographers develop their
own algorithm as a proposal for the next
global standard this is where the rile
algorithm came into play and was later
credited to be the next Advanced
encryption standard for a long time Dees
was the standard for data encryption for
data security its rule ended in 2002
when finally the advanced encryption
standard replaced Dees as an acceptable
standard following a public competition
for a
place to understand the structure of a
fistal Cipher we can use the following
image as a reference the block being
encrypted is divided into two parts one
of which is being passed onto the
function while the other part is exor
with the function's output the function
also uses the encryption key that
differs for each individual round this
key keeps going on until the last step
until where the right hand side and the
left hand side are being swapped here we
receive our final cyer text for the
decryption process the entire procedure
is reversed starting from the order of
the keys to the block sorting if the
entire process is repeated in a reverse
order we will eventually get back our
plane text and this Simplicity helps the
speed overall This was later detrimental
to the efficiency of the algorithm hence
the security was compromised
Ed a fistal block Cipher is a structure
used to derive many symmetric block
ciphers such as Dees which as we have
discussed in our previous
comment pistal Cipher proposed a
structure that implements substitution
and permutation alternately so that we
can obtain Cipher text from the plain
text and vice versa this helps in
reducing the redundancy of the program
and increases the complexity to combat
Brute Force
attacks the fistal Cipher is actually
based on the sh structure that was
proposed in 1945 the fistel cipher is
the structure suggested by horse feistel
which was considered to be a backbone
while developing many symmetric block
ciphers the Shannon structure highlights
the implementation of alternate
confusion and diffusion and like we
already discussed the fistal Cipher
structure can be completely reversed
depending on the data however we must
consider the fact that to decrypt the
information by reversing the fal
structure we will need the exact
polinomial functions and the key
orders to understand how the blocks are
being calculated we take a plane text
which is of 64bit and that is later
divided into two equal halves of 32 bit
each in this the right half is
immediately transferred to the next
round to become the new Left half of the
second round the right hand is again
passed off to a function which uses an
encryption key that is unique to each
round in the fistal Cipher whatever ever
the function gives off as an output it
is passed on as an XR input with the
left half of the initial plane text the
next output will become the right half
of the second round for the plane text
this entire process constitutes of a
single round in the fal
Cipher taking into account what happens
in the polinomial
function we take one half of the block
and pass it through an expansion box the
work of the expansion box is to increase
the size of the half from 32-bit to
48-bit text this is done to make the
text compatible to a 48 bit Keys we have
generated
beforehand once we pass it through the
EXO function we get a 48-bit text as an
output now remember a half should be of
32-bit so this 48-bit output is then
later passed on to a substitution box
this substitution box reduces its size
from 48 bit to 32bit Output which is
then later exort with the first half of
the plane
text a block Cipher is considered the
safest if the size of the block is large
but large block sizes can also slow down
encryption speed and the decryption spee
generally the size is
64-bit sometimes modern block ciphers
like AES have a 128bit block size as
well the security of the block sver
increases with increasing key size but
larger key sizes may also reduce the
speed reads of the process earlier
64-bit keys were considered sufficient
modern ciphers need to use 128bit Keys
due to the increasing complexity of
today's computational
standards the increasing number of
rounds also increase the security of the
block Cipher similarly they're inversely
proportional to the speed of
encryption a highly complex round
function enhances the security of the
block Cipher Al we must maintain a
balance between the speed and
security the symmetric block Cipher is
implemented in a software application to
achieve better execution speed there is
no use of an algorithm it it cannot be
implemented in a real life framework
that can help organizations to encrypt
or decrypt the data in a timely manner
now that we understand the basics of Fel
ciphers we can take a look at how Dees
manages to run through 16 rounds of the
structure and provide the cipher text at
the end now that we understand
understand the basics of FAL ciphers we
can take a look at how DS manages to run
through 16 rounds of this structure and
provide a cipher text in simple terms DS
takes the 64-bit plain text and converts
it into a 64-bit Cipher text and since
we are talking about asymmetric
algorithms the same key is being used
when it is decrypting the data as
well first take a 64bit ke plane text
and we pass it through an initial
permutation function the ination permit
function has the job of dividing the
block into two different parts so that
we can perform fistal Cy structures on
it there are multiple rounds being
procured in the DS algorithm namely 16
rounds of FAL Cipher structure each of
these rounds will need keys initially we
take a 56-bit cipher key but it is a
single key we pass it onto a round key
generators which generate 16 different
keys for each single round that the
fistal Cipher is being run
these keys are passed on to the rounds
as 48 bits the size of these 48 bit Keys
is the reason we use the substitution
and permutation Bongs in the polinomial
functions of the faal
ciphers when passing through all these
rounds we reach round 16 where the final
key is passed on from the round key
generator and we get a final permutation
in the final permutation the rounds are
swapped and we get our final Cipher text
this is the entire process of Dees with
16 rounds of his cyers encompassed in it
to decrypt a cipher text back to the
Plaine text we just have to reverse the
process we did in the DS algorithm and
reverse the key order along with the
functions this kind of Simplicity is
what gave Dees the bonus when it comes
to speed but eventually it was
detrimental to the overall efficiency of
the program when it comes to security
factors DS have five different modes of
operation to choose from this one of
those is electronic code book each
64-bit block is encrypted and decrypted
independently in the electronic code
book format we also have Cipher block
chaining or the CBC method here each
64-bit block depends on the previous one
and all of them use an initialization
Vector we have a cipher feedback block
mechanism where the preceding Cipher
text becomes the input for the
encryption algorithm it produces a su a
random output which in turn is exor with
the Plaine
text there is an out put feedback method
as well which is the same as Cipher
feedback except that the encryption
algorithm input is the output from the
preceding
Dees a counter method has a different
way of approach where each PL text block
is exord with an encrypted counter the
counter is then incremented for each
subsequent block there are a few other
alternatives to these modes of operation
but the five mentioned above are the
most widely used in the industry and
recommended by crypto photographers
worldwide let's take a look at the
future of
Dees the dominance of Dees ended in 2002
when the advanced encryption standard
replaced the DS encryption algorithm as
the accepted standard it was done
following a public competition to find a
replacement nist officially withdrew the
global acceptance standard in May 2005
although triple Ds has approved for some
sensitive government information through
20130 ND also had to change the DS
algorithm because its key length was too
short given the increased processing
power of the new computers encryption
power is related to the size of the key
and DS found itself a victim of ongoing
technological advances in Computing we
have received a point where 56-bit was
no longer a challenge to the computers
of cracking note that because DS is no
longer the nist federal standard it does
not mean that it is no longer in use
trip DS is still used today and is still
considered a legacy encryption algorithm
to get a better understanding of how
these keys and Cipher text look like we
can use an online tool for our benefit
as we already know to encrypt any kind
of data a key is mandatory this key can
be generated using mathematical
functions or computerized key generation
program such as this website offers it
can be based on any piece of text let's
say the word is simply
[Music]
learn in our
example once the key is settled we
provide the plain text or the clear text
that needs to be encrypted using the
aforementioned key suppose our sentence
for this example is this is my first
message we have satisfied two
prerequisits the message and the key
another variable that goes into play is
the mode of
operation we have already learned about
five different modes of operation while
we can see some other options here as
well let us go with the CBC variant
which basically means the cipher block
chaining method one of cbc's key
characteristics is that it uses a
chaining process it causes the
decryption of a block of Cipher text to
depend all on the preceding Cipher text
blocks as a result the entire validity
of all the blocks is contained in the
previous adjacent blocks as well a
single bit error in a cipher text block
affects the decryption of all the
subsequent blocks rearrangement of the
order of these for example can cause the
decryption process to get
corrupted regarding the manner of
displaying binary information we have
two options here we can either go with
base 64 or the heximal format let's go
with the base 64 right
now as you can see the cipher text is
readily available b64 is a little more
efficient than hex so we will be getting
a smaller Cipher text when it comes to B
64 Al be the size of both the formats
will be the same the hex has a longer
Cipher text since base 64 takes four
characters for every three bytes while
hex will take two characters for each B
hence B 64 turns out to be more
efficient now to decut the cipher text
we go by the same format we choose Bas
64 we copy the cipher text onto a
decryption tool and we have to make sure
that the key we are using is exactly the
same we choose similar mod of
operation and we choose the correct
encoding format as well which is base 64
in this
case as you can see the decryption is
complete and we get a plain text back
even if you keep everything the same but
we just change the encoding format it
will not be able to decrypt
anything unfortunately DS has become
rather easy to crack even without the
help of a key the advanced encryption
standard is still on top when it comes
to metric encryption security and will
likely stay there for a
while eventually with so much computing
power growth the need for a stronger
algorithm was necessary to safeguard a
personal data as solid as Dees was the
computers of today could easily break
the encryption with repeated attempts
thereby rendering the data security
helpless to counter this dilemma a new
standard was introduced which was termed
as the advanced encryption standard or
the AES
algorithm let's look what is Advanced
encryption
standard the AES algorithm also known as
the Ral algorithm is a symmetric block
Cipher with a block size of 128 bits it
is converted into Cipher text using keys
of 128 192 or 256 bits it is implemented
in software and Hardware throughout the
world to encrypt sensitive data the
National Institute of Standards and
Technology also known as n started
development on AES in 1997 when it was
announced the need for an alternative to
the data encryption standard the new
internet needed a replacement for de
because of its small key size with
increasing computing power it was
considered unsafe against entire key
search attacks the triple Ds was
designed to overcome this problem
however it was deemed to be too slow to
be deployed in machines
worldwide strong cases were present by
the Mars rc6 Serpent and the two fish
algorithms but it was the rindal
encryption algorithm also known as AES
which was eventually chosen as the
standard symmetric key encryption
algorithm to be used its section was
formalized with the release of federal
information processing standards
publication 197 in the November of 2001
it was approved by the US Secretary of
Commerce now that we understand the
origin of AES let us have a look at the
features that make AES encryption
algorithm
unique the AES algorithm uses a
substitution permutation or SP Network
it consists of multiple rounds to
produce a cipher text it has a series of
linked operations including replacing
inputs with specific outputs that is
substitutions and others that involve
bit shuffling which is
permutations at the beginning of the
encryption process we only start out
with a single key which can be either a
128bit key a 192bit key or a 256 key
eventually this one key is expanded to
be used in multiple rounds throughout
the encryption and the decryption cycle
interestingly AES performs all its
calculations on bite data instead of bit
data as seen in the case of the DS
algorithm therefore AES treats 128 bits
of a clear text block as 16 bytes the
number of rounds during the encryption
process depends on the key size that is
being used the 128bit key size fixes 10
Rounds the 192bit key size fixes 12
rounds and the 256bit key holds 14
rounds a round key is required for each
of these rounds but since only one key
is input into the algorithm the single
key needs to be expanded to get the key
for each round including the round
zero with so many mathematical
calculations going on in the background
there are bound to be a lot of steps
throughout the procedure let's have a
look at the steps followed in
AES
before we move ahead we need to
understand how data is being stored
during the process of AES
encryption everything in the process is
stored in a 4 into four Matrix
format this Matrix is also known as a
state array and we'll be using these
statea arrays to transmit data from one
step to another and from one round to
the next
round each round takes straight array as
input and gives a straight array as
output to be transferred into the next
round
it is a 16 byte Matrix with each cell
representing one
byte with each four bytes representing a
word so every state array will have a
total of four words representing
it as we previously discussed we take a
single key and expand it to the number
of rounds that we need the key to be
used in let's say the number of rounds
are n then the key has to be expanded to
be used with n +1 rounds because the
first round is the key zero
round let's say n is the number of
rounds the key is expanded to n+ one
rounds it is also a state array having
four words in its vicinity every key is
used for a single round and the first
key is used as a round key before any
round
begins in the very beginning the plane
text is captured and passed through an
exor function with the round key as a
supplement
this key can be considered the first key
from the n+1 expanded set moving on the
state array resulting from the above
step is passed on to a bite substitution
process beyond that there is a provision
to shift rows in the state arrays later
on the state array is mixed with a
constant Matrix to shuffle its column in
the mix column segment after which we
add the round key for that particular
round the last four steps mentioned are
part of every single round that the
encryption algorithm goes through the
state arrays are then passed from one
round to the next as an input in the
last round however we skipped the mix
columns portion with the rest of the
process remaining
unchanged but what are these bite
substitution and row shifting processes
let's find out regarding each step in
more
detail in the first step the plain text
is stored in a state array and is exor
with the k0 which is the first key in
the expanded key set this step is
performed only once on a block while
being repeated at the end of each round
as per iteration
demands the state array is exor with the
key to get a new state array which is
then pass office input to the sub bytes
process in the second stage we have by
substitution we leverage an Xbox called
as a substitution box to randomly switch
data among each element every single
bite is converted into a heximal value
having two parts the first part denotes
the row value and the second part
denotes the column value the entire
State array is passed through the sbox
to create a brand new state array which
is then passed off as an input to the
row shifting process the 16 input bytes
are replaced by looking at a fixed table
given in the design we finally get a
matrix with four rows and four
columns
when it comes to row shifting each bit
in the four rows of the Matrix is
shifted to the left an entry that is a
fall off is reinserted to the right of
the line the change is done as follows
the first line is not moved in any way
the second line is shifted to a single
position to the left the third line is
shifted two positions to the left and
the fourth line is shifted three
positions to the left the result is a
new Matrix that contains the same 16
bytes but has been moved in relation to
each other to boost the complexity of
the
program in mixed columns each column of
four bytes is now replaced using a
special mathematical function the
function takes four bytes of a column as
input and outputs for completely new
bytes we will get a new Matrix with the
same size of 16 bytes and it should be
noted that this phase has not been done
in the last round of the
iteration
when it comes to adding a round key the
16 bytes of the Matrix are treated as
128 bits and the 128 bits of the round
key are exort if it is the last round
the output is the cipher text if we
still have a few rounds remaining the
resulting 128 bits are interpreted as 16
bytes and we start another similar
round let's take an example to
understand how all these processes work
if our plane text is the string
2192 we first convert it into a heximal
format as follows we use an encryption
key which is that's my K Fu and it is
converted into a hexadecimal format as
well as per the guidelines we use a
single key which is then later expanded
into n+ one number of keys in which case
it's supposed to be 11 keys for 10
different
rounds in round zero we add the round
key the plain test is exort with the k0
and we get a state array that is passed
off as an input to the substitution by
its
process when it comes to the
substitution byes process we leverage an
sbox to substitute the elements of each
bite with a completely new bite this way
the state array that we receive is
passed off as an input to the row
shifting process on the next
step when it comes to row shifting each
element is shifted a few places to the
left with the first row being shifted by
zero places second row by one place
third row by two places and the last by
three the state array that we received
from the row shifting is passed off as
an input to mix columns in mix columns
we multiply the straight array with a
constant Matrix after which a receive a
new state are to be passed on onto the
next
step
we add the new state array as an exor
with the round key of the particular
iteration whatever state array we
receive here it becomes an output for
this particular
round now since this is the first round
of the entire encryption process the
state array that we receive is passed
off as an input to the new
Round We repeat this process for 10 more
rounds and we finally receive a cipher
text
once the final State array can be
denoted in the hexadecimal format this
becomes our final Cipher text that we
can use for transferring information
from the sender and
receiver let's take a look at the
applications of AES in this
world AES finds most use in the area of
wireless security in order to establish
a secure mode of authentication between
routers and clients highly secure
mechanisms like WPA and WPA2 psk are
extensively used in securing Wi-Fi
endpoints with the help of Riles
algorithm it also helps in SSL TLS
encryption that is instrumental in
encrypting our internet browser sessions
AES Works in tandem with other
asymmetric encryption algorithms to make
sure the web browser and web server are
properly configured and use encrypted
channels for
communication AES is is also prevalent
in general file encryption of various
formats ranging from critical documents
to the media files having a large key
allows people to encrypt media and
decrypt data with maximum security
possible AES is also used for processor
Security in Hardware Appliances to
prevent machine hijacking among other
things as a direct successor to the dees
algorithm there are some aspects that
AES provides an immediate advantage
let us take a
look when it comes to key length the
biggest flaw in DS algorithm was that
small length was easily vulnerable by
today's standards eses has managed to
NAB up 128 192 and 256bit key lens to
bolster the security further the block
size is also larger in AES owing to more
complexity of the algorithm the number
of rounds in DS is fixed irrespective of
the pl text being used in AES the number
of round depends on the key length that
is being used for the particular
iteration thereby providing more
Randomness and complexity in the
algorithm the dees algorithm is
considered to be simpler than AES even
though AES beats Dees when it comes to
relative speed of encryption and
decryption this makes Advanced
encryption standard much more
streamlined to be deployed in Frameworks
and systems worldwide when it compares
to the data encryption standard hello in
our last video on cryptography we took a
look at symmetry key cryptography we
used a single private key for both the
encryption and decryption of data and it
works very well in theory let's take a
look at a more realistic scenario now
let's meet Joe Joe is a journalist who
needs to communicate with Ryan via
long-distance messaging due to the
critical nature of the information
people are waiting for any message to
leave Joe's house so that they can
intercept it now Joe can easily use
symmetric ke cryptography to send the
encrypted data so that even if someone
intercepts the message they cannot
understand what it says but here's the
tricky part how will Joe send the
required decryption key to Ryan the
sender of the message as well as the
receiver need to have the same
decryption key so that they can exchange
messages otherwise Ryan cannot decrypt
the information even when he receives
the cipher text if someone intercepts
the key while transmitting it there is
no use in employing cryptography since a
third party can now decode all the
information easily key sharing is a risk
that will always exist when symmetri key
cryptography is being used thankfully
asymmetric key encryption has managed to
fix this problem this is B from Simply
learn and welcome to this video on
asymmetry key cryptography let's take a
look at what we are going to learn today
We Begin by explaining what asymmetry
key cryptography is and how it works we
take a look at its application and uses
we understand why it's called public key
cryptography and then learn a little bit
about RS encryption and then we learn
about the advantages of asymmetry key
cryptography over symmetry key
cryptography let's understand what
asymmetry key cryptography
is asymmetric encryption uses a double
layer of protection there are two
different keys at play here a private
key and a public key a public key is
used to encrypt the information pre-
Transit and a private key is used to
decrypt the data post Transit these pair
of keys must belong to the receiver of
the message the public keys can be
shared via messaging blog posts or key
servers and there are no restrictions as
you can see in the image the two keys
are working in the system the sender
first encrypts the message using the
receiver's private key after which we
receive the cipher text the cipher text
is then transmitted to the receiver
without any other key on getting the
cipher text the receiver uses his
private key to decrypt it and get the
plan text back there has been no
requirement of any key exchange
throughout this process therefore
solving the most glaring flaw faced in
symmetry key
cryptography the public key known to
everyone cannot be used to decrypt the
message and the private key which can
decrypt the message need not be shared
with anyone the sender and receiver can
exchange personal data using the same
set of keys as often as
possible to understand this better take
the analogy of your
mailbox anyone who wants to send you a
letter has access to the box and can
easily share information with you in a
way you can say the mailbox is publicly
available to all but only you have
access to the key that can open the
mailbox and read the letters in it this
is how the private key comes to play no
one can intercept the message and read
its contents since it's encrypted once
the receiver gets its contents he can
use his private key to decrypt the
information both the public key and the
private key are generated so there
Interlink and you cannot substitute
other private keys to decrypt the data
in another example if Alice wants to
send a message to Bob let's say tre's
call me today she must use Bob's public
key while encrypting the message upon
receiving the cipher message Bob can
proceed to use his private key in order
to decp the message and hence complete
securi is attained during transmission
without any need for sharing the
key since this type of encryption is
highly secure it has many uses in areas
that require High
confidentiality it is used to manage
digital signatur so there is valid proof
of a document's authenticity with so
many aspects of business transitioning
into the digital sphere critical
documents need to be verified before
being considered authentic and acted
upon thanks to asymmetric cryptography
senders can now sign documents with
their private Keys anyone who needs to
verify the authenticity of such
signatures can use the sender public key
to decrypt the signature since the
public and the private keys are linked
to each other mathematically it's
impossible to repeat this verification
with with duplicate Keys document
encryption has been made very simple by
today's standards but the background
implementation follows the similar
approach in blockchain architecture
asymmetri key cryptography is used to
authorize transactions and maintain the
system thanks to its two key structures
changes are reflected across the
blockchain's peer-to-peer Network only
if it is approved from both ends along
with asymmetric key cryptography stamp
approve architecture its non-
repudiation characteristic also helps in
keeping the network
stable we can also use asymmetry key
cryptography combined with symmetri key
cryptography to monitor SSL or TLS
encrypted browsering sessions to make
sure nobody can steal up personal
information when accessing banking
websites or the internet in general it
plays a significant role in verifying
website server authenticity Exchange the
necessary encryption Keys required and
generating a session using those keys to
ensure maximum security instead of the
rather insecure HTTP website format
security parameters differ on a session
by session basis so the verification
process is consistent and utterly
essential to Modern data
security another great use of the
asymmetric key cryptography structure is
transmitting keys for symmetric key
cryptography with the most significant
difficulty in symmetric encryption being
key exchange is symmetric keys can help
clear the shortcoming the original
message is first encrypted using a
symmetric key the key used for
encrypting the data is then converted
into the cipher text using the
receiver's public key now we have two
Cipher text to transmit to the receiver
on receiving both of them the receiver
uses his private key to decrypt the
Symmetry key he can then use it to
decrypt the original information on
getting the key used to encrypt the data
while this may seem more complicated
than just asymmetric key cryptography
alone
symmetric encryption algorithms are much
more optimized for vast amounts of data
on some occasions encrypting the key
using asymmetric algorithms will
definitely be more memory efficient and
secure you might remember us discussing
why symmetric encryption was called
private key cryptography let us
understand why asymmetric falls under
the public key
cryptography we have two keys at our
disposal the encryption key is available
to everyone the decryption key is is
supposed to be
private unlike symmetric key
cryptography there is no need to share
anything privately to have an encrypted
messaging system to put that into
perspective we share our email address
with anyone looking to communicate with
us it is supposed to be public by Design
so that our email login credentials are
private and they help in preventing any
data mishandling since there is nothing
hidden from the world if they want to
send us any encrypted information this
category is called the public key
cryptography
there are quite a few algorithms being
used today that follow the architecture
of asymmetric cryptography none more
famous than the RSA
encryption RSA encryption is the most
widely used encryption or publicly
encryption standard using asymmetric
approach named after its Founders reest
Shamir and Adelman it uses block ciphers
to obscure the information if you are
unfamiliar with how block ciphers work
there are encryption algorithms that
divide divide the original data into
blocks of equal size the block size
depends on the exact Cipher being used
once they are broken down these blocks
are encrypted individually and later
chained together to form the final
Cipher
text widely considered to be the most
secure form of encryption or bit
relatively slower than symmetric
encryption algorithms it is widely used
in web browsing secure identification
vpns emails and other chat
applications which so many variables in
play that musters follow tees that give
asymmetrically cryptography an edge over
the traditional symmetric encryption
methodologies let's go through some of
them there is no need for any reliable
key sharing channel in asymmetric
encryption it was an added risk in
private key cryptography that has been
completely eliminated in public key
architecture the key which is made
public cannot decrypt any confidential
information and the only key that can
decrypt doesn't need to be sh shared
publicly under any
circumstance we have much more extensive
key lens in RSA encryption and other
asymmetric algorithms like 248 bit key
and 496 bit Keys larger keys are much
harder to break into via brute force and
are much more
secure asymmetry key cryptography can
use as a proof of authenticity since
only the rightful owner of the keys can
generate the messages to be decrypted by
the private key the situation can also
be reversed encryption is done using a
private key and decryption is done by
the public key which would not function
if the correct private key is not used
to generate the message hence proving
the authenticity of the
owner it also has a tamper protection
feature where the message cannot be
intercepted and changed without
invalidating the private key used to
encrypt the data consequently the public
key cannot decrypt the message and it is
easy to realize the information is not
100% legitimate when and where the case
requires now the that we have a proper
revision let's understand what digital
signatures are before moving on to the
algorithm the objective of digital
signatures is to authenticate and verify
documents and data this is necessary to
avoid tampering and digital modification
or forgery of any kind during the
transmission of official
documents they work on the public key
ktog graphy architecture with one
exception typically an asymmetry Key
System encryp using a public key and
decrypts with the private key for
digital signatures however the reverse
is
true the signature is encrypted using a
private key and is decrypted with the
public key because the keys are in
together decoding it with the public key
verifies that the proper private key was
used to sign the document thereby
verifying the signatures Provence let's
go through each step to understand the
procedure
thoroughly in step one we have M which
is the original plain text message and
it is passed onto a hash function
denoted by H hash to create a
digest next it bundles the message
together with a hash digest and encrypts
it using the senders private
key it sends the encrypted bundle to the
receiver who can decrypt it using the
senders public
key once the message is decrypted it is
passed through the same hash function H
hash to generate a similar
digest it compares the newly generated
hash with the bundled hash value
received along with the message if they
match it verifies data
Integrity in many instances they provide
a layer of validation and security to
messages through non-secured Channel
properly implemented a digital signature
gives the receiver reason to believe
that the message was sent by the claimed
sender digital signatures are equivalent
to traditional handwritten signatures in
many respects but properly implemented
digital signatures are more difficult to
forge than the handwritten type digital
signature schemes in the sense used here
are cryptographically based and must be
implemented properly to be effective
they can also provide non-repudiation
meaning that the signer cannot
successfully claim that they did not
sign a message while also claiming their
private key remain secret further some
non-repudiation schemes offer a
timestamp for the digital signature so
that even if the private key is exposed
the signature is
valid to implement the concept of
digital signature in real world we have
two primary algorithms to follow the RSA
algorithm and the DSA algorithm but the
latter is a topic of learning today so
let's go ahead and see what the digital
signature algorithm is supposed to
do digital signature algorithm is a fips
standard which is a federal information
processing standard for digital
signatures it was proposed in 1991 and
globally standardized in 1994 by the
National Institute of Standards and
Technology also known as the nist it
functions on the framework of modular
exponation and discrete logarithmic
problems which are difficult to compute
as a force brute
system unlike DSA most dig types are
generated by signing message digest with
the private key of the originator this
creates a dig thumbprint of the data
since just the message digest is signed
the signature is generally much smaller
compared to the data that was signed as
a result digital signatures impose less
load on processors at the time of
signing execution and they use small
volumes of bandwidth DSA on the other
hand does not encrypt message digest
using private key or decrypt message
digest using public key instead it uses
mathematical functions to create a
digital signature consisting of of two
160 bit numbers which are originated
from the message digests and the private
key DCS make use of the public key for
authenticating the signature but the
authorization process is much more
complicated when compared with RSA DSA
also provides three benefits which is
the message authentication Integrity
verification and non-
repudiation in the image we can see the
entire process of DSF validation a plain
text message is passed onto a hash
function where the digest is generated
which is passed onto a signing function
signing function also has other
parameters like a global variable G of
random variable K and the private key of
the
sender the outputs are then bundled onto
a single pack with the plain text and
send to the receiver the two outputs we
receive from the signing functions are
the two 160 bit numbers denoted by S and
R on the receiver end we pass the PL
text to the same hash function to
regenerate the message digest it is
passed onto verification function which
has other requirements such as the
public key of the sender Global variable
G and SNR received from the
sender the value generated by the
function is then compared to R if they
match then the verification process is
complete and data Integrity is verified
this was an overview of the way the a
algorithm works we already know it
depends on logarithmic functions to
calculate the outputs so let us see how
we can do the same in our next
section we have three phases here the
first of which is key generation to
generate the keys we need some
prerequisites we select a q which
becomes a prime divisor we select a
prime number P such that P minus1 mod Q
equal to 0 we also select a random
integer G which must satisfy the two
formulas being mentioned on the screen
right now once these values are selected
we can go ahead with generating the keys
the private key can be denoted by X and
it is any random integer that falls
between the bracket of zero and the
value of Q the public key can be
calculated as y = to G ^ x mod P where y
stands for the public key the private
key can then be packaged as a bundle
which comprises of values of p q G and X
similarly the public key can also be
packaged as a bundle having the values
of p q G and Y once we're done with key
generation we can start verifying the
signature and this
generation repeat once the keys are
generated we can start generating the
signature the message is passed through
a hash function to generate the digest
Edge first we can choose any any random
integer K which falls under the bracket
of 0 and Q to calculate the first 160
bit number of ass signing function of r
we use the formula g the^ k mod P into
mod Q similarly to calculate the value
of the second output that is s we use
the following formula that is shown on
the
screen the signature can then be
packaged as a bundle having R and
S this bundle along with a PL in text
message is then passed on to the
receiver now with the third phase we
have to verify the signature we first
calculate the message digest received in
the bundle by passing it to the same
hash function we calculate the value of
w U1 and U2 using the formulas shown on
the screen we have to calculate a
verification component which is then to
be compared with the value of R being
sent by the sender this verification
component can can be calculated using
the following formula once calculated
this can be compared with the value of R
if the values match then the signature
verification is successful and the
entire process is complete starting from
Key generation to the signature
Generation all the way up to the
verification of the
signature with so many steps to follow
we are bound to have a few advantages to
boot this and we would be right to think
so DSA is highly robust in the security
and stability aspect when compared to
Alternative signature verification
algorithms we have a few other ciphers
that aim to achieve the Simplicity and
the flexibility of DSA but it has been a
tough ask for all the other
suits the key generation is much faster
when compared to the RSA algorithm and
such while the actual encryption and
decryption process May falter a little
in comparison a quicker start in the
beginning is well known to optimize a
lot of
Frameworks DSA requires Less storage
space to work its entire cycle in
contrast its direct correspondent that
is RSA algorithm needs a certain amount
of computational and storage space to
function efficiently this is not the
case with DSA which has been optimized
to work with weaker hardware and lesser
resources the DSA is patented but nist
has made this patent available worldwide
royalty-free a CFT version of the
speculation fips 1865 indicates that DSA
will no longer be approved for digital
signature generation but it may be used
to verify signatures generated prior to
the implementation date of that
standard the RSA algorithm is a public
key signature algorithm developed by Ron
reest ADI Shamir and Leonard Edelman the
paper was first published in 1977 and
the algorithm uses logarithmic functions
to keep the working complex enough to
withstand brute force and streamlined
enough to be fast post deployment RSA
can also encrypt and decrypt general
information to securely exchange data
along with handling digital signature
verification let us understand how it
achieve this we take our Plaine text
message M we pass it through a hash
function to generate the digest H which
is then encrypted using the sender's
private key this is appended to the
original plane text message and sent
over to the
receiver once the receiver receives the
bundle we can pass the plane text
message with the same hash function to
generate a digest and the cipher text
can be decrypted using the public key of
the sender the remaining hashes are
compared if the values match then the
data Integrity is verified and the
sender is authenticated apart from
digital signatures the main case of RSA
is encryption and decryption of private
information before being transmitted
across communication challenge this is
where the data encryption comes into
play when using RSA for encryption and
decryption of General data it reverses
the key set usage unlike signature
verification it receives the receiver's
public key to encrypt the data and uses
the receiver's private key in decrypting
the data thus there is no need to
exchange any keys in this scenario there
are two broad components when it comes
to RSA cryptography one of them is key
generation key generation employs a step
of generating the private and the public
keys that are going to be used for
encrypting and decrypting the data the
second part is the encryption and
decryption functions these are the
ciphers and steps that need to be run
when scrambling the data or recovering
the data from the cipher text you will
Now understand each of these steps in
our next
subtopic keeping the previous two
concepts in mind let us go ahead and see
how the entire process works starting
from creating the keeper to encrypting
and decrypting the
information you need to generate the
public and private Keys before running
the functions to generate Cipher text
and plain text they use certain
variables and parameters all of which
are explained we first use two large
prime numbers which can be denoted by P
and Q we can compute the value of n as n
= p into q and compute the value of Zed
as P -1 into Q
-1 a number e is chosen at random
satisfying the following conditions and
a number D is also selected at random
following the formula Ed mod Z equal to
1 and it can be calculated with the
formula given
below the public key is then packaged as
a bundle with n and E and the private
key is packaged as a bundle using n and
D this sums of the key generation
process for the encryption and
decryption function we use the formula C
and M the cipher Tex can be calculated
as C = to m ^ e mod n and the plain text
can be calculated from the cipher text
as C power D mod n when it comes to a
data encryption example let's take p and
Q as 7 and 13 the value of n can be
calculated as
91 if we select the value of e to be
five it satisfy all the criteria that we
need it to the value of D can be
calculated using the following function
which gives it as 29 the public key can
then be packaged as 91a 5 and the
private key can then be packaged as 91a
29 the plain text if it is 10 which is
denoted by m Cypher text can be
calculated the formula c = m^ e mod n
which gives us 82 if somebody receives
this Cipher text they can calculate the
plane text using the formula C to the^ D
mod n which gives us the value of 10 as
selected as our PL
text we can now look at the factors that
make the RSA algorithm Stand Out versus
its competitors in the advantageous
topics of this
lesson RSA encryption depends on using
the receivers public key so that you
don't have to share any secret key to
receive the messages from others this
was the most glaring flaw faced by
symmetric algorithms which were
eventually fixed by asymmetric
cryptography
structure since the key pairs are
related to each other a receiver cannot
intercept the message since they didn't
have the correct private keys to decrypt
the information if a public key can decp
the information the sender cannot refuse
signing it with his private key without
admitting the private key is not in fact
private
anymore the encryption process is faster
than that of the DSA algorithm even if
the key generation is slower in RSA many
systems across the world tend to reuse
the same keys so that they can spend
less time in key generation and more
time on actual Cipher text
management data will be tamper proof in
transit since since meddling with the
data will alter the usage of the keys
the private key won't be able to decp
the information hence alerting the
receiver of any kind of manipulation in
between the receiver must be aware of
any third party who possesses the
private key since they can alter the
data mid Transit the cases of which are
rather low imagine creating an account
on a new website you provide your email
address and set a password that you are
confident and you would not forget what
about the website owner how securely are
they going to store your
password for website administrators they
have three Alternatives they can either
store the passwords in a plain text
format they can encrypt the passwords
using an encryption and decryption key
or they can store the passwords in a
hash value let's have a look at each of
these when a password is stored in clean
text format it is considered to be the
most unsafe option since anyone in the
company can read your passwords a single
hack and a data server breach will
expose all the accounts credentials
without needing any extra
effort to counter this owners can
encrypt the passwords and keep them in
the servers as a second alternative but
that would mean they also have to store
the decryption key somewhere on their
servers in the event of a data breach or
the server hack both the decryption key
and encrypted passwords will be leaked
thus making it a single point of
failure what if there was an option to
store the passwords after scrambling
them completely
but with no way to decrypt them this is
where hashing comes to play since only
the hashed values are stored in the
server no encryption is needed with no
plain text passwords to protect your
credentials are safe from the website
administrators considering all the pros
hashed passwords are the industry
standard when it comes to storing
credentials
nowadays before getting too deep into
the topic let's get a brief overview of
how hashing
works
hashing is the process of scrambling a
piece of information or data beyond
recognition we can achieve this by using
hash functions which are essentially
algorithms that perform mathematical
operations on the main plain text the
value generated after passing the plain
text information through the hash
function is called the hash value digest
or in general just the hash of the
original data while this may sound
similar to encryption the major
difference is hashes are meant to be IR
reversible no decryption key can convert
a digest back to its original value
however a few hashing algorithms have
been broken due to the increase in
computational complexity of today's new
generation computers and processors
there are new algorithms that stand the
test of time and are still in use among
multiple areas for password storage
identity verification
Etc like we discussed earlier websites
use hashing to store the users passwords
so how do they make make use of these
hash
passwords when a user signs up to create
a new account the password is then run
through the hash function and the
resulting hash value is stored on the
servers so the next time a user comes to
log to the account the password he
enters is passed to the same hash
function and compared to the hash stored
on the main server if the newly
calculated hash is the same as the one
stored on the website server the
password must have been correct because
according to Hash functions terminology
same inputs will always provide the same
outputs if the hashes do not match then
the password entered during login is not
the same as the password entered during
the signup hence the login will be
denied this way no plain text passwords
get stored preventing both the owner
from snooping on user data and
protecting users's privacy in the
unfortunate event of a data breach or a
hack apart from password storage hashing
can also be used to perform Integrity
checks when a file is uploaded on the
internet the file's hash value is
generated and it is uploaded along with
the original information when a new user
downloads the file he can calculate the
digest of the downloaded file using the
same hash function when the hash values
are compared if they match then file
Integrity has been maintained and there
has been no data
corruption since so much important
information is being passed on the hash
function we need to understand and how
they
work a hash function is a set of
mathematical calculations operated on
two blocks of data the main input is
broken down into two blocks of similar
size the block size is dependent on the
algorithm that is being
used hash functions are designed to be
one way they shouldn't be reversible at
least by Design some algorithms like the
previously mention md5 have been
compromised but more secure algorithms
are being used today like the sh f
algorithms the digest size is also
dependent on the respective algorithm
being used md5 has a digest of 128 bits
while sh 256 has a digest of 256 bits
this digest must always be the same for
the same input irrespective of how many
times the calculations are carried out
this is a very crucial feature since
comparing the hash value is the only way
to check if the data is untouched as the
functions are not
reversible
there are certain requirements of a hash
function that need to be met before they
are accepted while some of them are easy
to guess others are placed in order to
preserve Security in the long
run the hash function must be quick
enough to encrypt large amounts of data
at a relatively Fast Pace but it also
shouldn't be very fast running the
algorithm on all cylinders makes the
functions easy to boot force and a
security liability there must be a
balance to allow the hash function to
handle large large amounts of data and
not make it ridiculously easy to Brute
Force by running through all the
possible
combinations the hash function must be
dependent on each bit of the input the
input can be text audio video or any
other file extension if a single
character is being changed it doesn't
matter how small that character may be
the entire digest must have a distinctly
different hash value this is essential
to create unique digests for every
password that is being stored but what
if two different users are using the
same password since the hash function is
the same for all users both the digest
will be the same this is called a hash
Collision you may think this must be a
rare occasion where two users have
exactly the same password but that is
not the case we have techniques like
salting that can be used to reduce these
hash collisions as we will discuss later
in this
video you would be shocked to see the
most used part passwords of 2020 all of
these passwords are laughably insecure
and since many people use the same
passwords repeatedly on different
websites hash collisions risk are more
common than one you would
expect let's say the hash functions find
two users having the same password how
can they store both the hashers without
messing up the original data this is
where salting and peppering come to
play salting is the process of adding a
random keyword to the end of the input
before it is passed on to the hash
function this random keyword is unique
for each user on the system and it is
called the salt value or just the salt
so even if two passwords are exactly the
same the solt value will differ and so
will the digest there is a small problem
with this process though since the salt
is unique for each user they need to be
stored in the database along with the
passwords and sometimes even in plain
text to speed up the process of
continuous verification if the server is
hacked then the hack ashes will need to
be brute forced which takes a lot of
time but if they receive the salts as
well the entire process becomes very
fast this is something that peppering
aims to
solve peppering is the process of adding
a random string of data to the input
before passing them to the hash function
but this time the random string is not
unique for each user it is supposed to
be common for all users in the database
and the extra bit added is called the
pepper in this case the pepper is in
stor on the servers it is mostly
hardcoded onto the website source code
since it's going to be the same for all
credentials this way even if the servers
get hacked they will not have the right
pepper needed to crack into all the
passwords many websites use a
combination of salting and peppering to
solve the problem of hash collision and
bolster security since BR Force takes
such a long time many hackers avoid
taking the effort the returns are mostly
not worth it and the possible
combinations of of using both salting
and peppering is
humongous with the consensus aiming
towards an educated public on digital
privacy it's no surprise to see an
increasing interest in encryption
algorithms we have already covered the
major names like the dees and the AES
algorithm md5 algorithm was one of the
first hashing algorithms to take the
global stage as a successor to the md4
despite the security vulnerabilities
encountered in in the future md5 Still
Remains a crucial part of data
infrastructure in a multitude of
environments the md5 hashing algorithm
is a one-way cryptographic functions
that accepts a message of any length as
input and it returns as output a fixed
length digest value to be used for
authenticating the original messages the
digest size is always 128 bits
irrespective of the input the md5 hash
function was originally designed for use
as a secure cryptographic hash algorithm
to authenticate digital signatures md5
has also been depreciated for users
other than as a non- cryptographic check
sum to verify data integrity and detect
unintentional data
corruption Ronald dest founder of RSA
data security and Institute professor at
MIT designed md5 as an improvement to a
prior message digest algorithm which was
the
md4 as already iterated before the
process is straightforward we pass up PL
text message to the md5 hash functions
which in turn perform certain
mathematical operations on the clear
text to scramble the data the 128bit
digest received from this is going to be
radically different from the plane text
the goal of any message digest function
is to produce digest that appear to be
random to be considered
cryptographically secure the hash
functions should meet two requirements
first that it is impossible for an
attack to generate a message that
matches a specific hash value and second
that it is impossible for an attacker to
create two messages that produce the
same hash value even a slight change in
the plane text should trigger a drastic
difference in the two digest this goes a
long way in preventing hash collisions
which take place when two different
plane Texs have the same
digest to achieve this level of
intricacy there are a number of steps to
be followed before we receive the diges
let us take a look at the detailed
procedure as to how the md5 hash
algorithm
works the first step is to make the
Plaine text compatible with the hash
function to do this we need to pad the
bits in the message when we receive the
input string we have to make sure the
size is 64 bits short of a multiple of
512 when it comes to padding the bits we
must add one first followed by zeros to
round out the extra characters this
prepares a string to have a length of
just 64 bits less than any multiple of
512 here and out we can proceed On To
The Next Step where we have to Pat the
length bits initially in the first step
we appended the message in such a way
that the total length of the bits in the
message was 64 bits short of any
multiple of 512 now we add the length
bits in such a way that the total number
of bits in the message is perfectly a
multiple of
512 that means 64 bit lens to be precise
are added to the message our final
string to be hashed is now a definite
multiple of
512 The Next Step would be to initialize
the message digest buffer the entire
hashing plane text is now broken down
into 512-bit
blocks there are four buffers or
registers that are of 32 bits each named
a b c and d
these are the four words that are going
to store the values of each of these
subblocks the first iteration to follow
these registers will have fixed
hexadecimal values as shown on the
screen
below once these values are
initial of these 512 blocks we can
divide each of them into 16 further
subblocks of 32 bits each for each of
these subblocks we run four rounds of
operations having the four buff for
variables a b c and d these rounds
require the other constant variables as
well which defer with each round of
operation the constant values are stored
in a random array of 64 elements since
each 32-bit subblock is run four times
16 such subblocks equal 64 constant
values needed for a single block
iteration the subblocks can be denoted
by the alphabet M and the constant
values are denoted by the alphabet
T
coming to the actual round of operation
we see our four buffers which already
have pre-initialized values for the
first iteration at the very beginning
the values of buffers b c and d are
passed on to a nonlinear logarithmic
function the formula behind this
function changes by the particular round
being worked on as we shall see later in
this video Once the output is calculated
it is added to the raw value stored in
buffer a the output of this addition is
added to the particular 32-bit sub block
using which we are running the four
operations the output of this requisite
function then needs to be added to a
constant value derived from the constant
array K since we have four different
elements in the array repeat since we
have 64 different elements in the array
we can use a distinct element for each
iteration of a particular block The Next
Step involves a circular shift that
increases the complexity of the hash
algorithm and is necessary to create a
unique digest for each individual input
the output generated is later added to
the value stored in the buffer B the
final output is now stored in the second
buffer of B of the output register
individual values of c d and a are
derived from the preceding element
before the iteration started meaning the
value of b gets stored in C value of C
get stored in D and the value of D in a
now that we have a full register ready
for this subblock the values of ab CD
are moved on as input to the next
subblock Once all 16 subblocks are
completed the final register value is
saved and the next 512 bit block begins
at the end of all these blocks we get a
final digest of the md5
algorithm regarding the nonlinear
process mentioned in the first step the
formula changes for each round it's
being run on this is done to maintain
the computational complexity of the
algorithm and to increase randomness of
the procedure the formula for each of
the four rounds uses the same parameters
that is b c and d to generate a single
output the formulas being used are shown
on the screen right
now algorithm unlike the latest hash
algorithm families a 32-bit digest is
relatively easier to compare when
verifying the digest they don't consume
a noticeable amount of disc storage and
are comparatively easier to remember and
reiterate passwords need not be stored
in plain text format making them
accessible for hackers and malicious
actors when using digest the database
security also gets a boost since the
size of all the hash values will be the
same in the event of a hack or a breach
the malicious actor will only receive
the hashed values so there is no way to
regenerate the plane text which would be
the user passwords in this case since
the functions are irreversible by Design
hashing has become a compulsion when
storing user credentials on the server
nowadays a relatively low memory
footprint is necessary when it comes to
integrating multiple Services into the
same framework without a CPU overhead
the digest size is the same and the same
steps are run to get the hash value
irrespective of the size of the input
string this helps in creating a low
requirement for computational power and
is much easier to run on older Hardware
which is pretty common in server farms
around the
world we can monitor file corruption by
comparing hash values before and after
Transit once the hash is matched file
Integrity checks are valid and we can
avoid data
corruption hash functions will always
give the same output for the similar
input irrespective of the iteration
parameters it also helps in ensuring
that the data hasn't been tampered with
on route to the the receiver of the
message we use our Wi-Fi everyday for
work and we use the internet for
entertainment and communication the
dependency on technology is at an
all-time high thanks to the radical
developments and innovation in these
last two decades a big portion of this
belongs to ensuring secure channels of
communication and data
transmission the secure hash algorithm
are a family of a cryptographic hash
functions that are published by the
National Institute of Standards and
Technology along with the NSA it was
passed as a federal information
processing standard also known as FPS it
has four different families of hash
functions ssj 0 is a 160 bit hash
function published in 1993 and it was
closed down later after an undisclosed
significant flaw sha1 is also a 160 bit
hash function which resembles the
earlier md5 algorithm this was designed
by the NSA to be a part of the digital
signature
algorithm S2 is a family of two similar
hash functions with different block
sizes known as the Sha 256 and the Sha
512 the differ in the word size sh 256
uses 32 bit words where sh 512 uses
64bit words sha3 is a hash function
properly known as kak it was chosen in
2012 after a public competition among
non NSA designers it supports the same
hash lens as H2 and its internal
structure differ significantly from the
rest of the Sha family as we have
already iterated the process is
straightforward we pass a plain text
message to the sh hash function which in
turn performs certain mathematical
operations on the clear text to scramble
the data the 160 bit digest received
from this is going to be radically
different from the plain text the goal
of any hash function is to produce
digests that appear to be random to be
considered cryptographically secure the
hash function should meet two
requirements first that it is impossible
for an attacker to generate a message
that matches a specific hash value and
second it should be impossible for an
attacker to create two messages
producing the exactly same hash value
even a slight change in the plane text
should trigger a drastic difference in
the two digest this goes a long way in
preventing hash collisions which takes
place when two different plane text have
the same
digest the Sha family functions have
some characteristics that they need to
follow while generating the digest let's
go through a few of
them the length of the clear text should
be less than 2 the^ 64 bits in the case
of sh 1 and sh2 56 this is essential to
keep the Plaine text compatible with the
hash function and the size needs needs
to be in comparison area to keep the
digest as random as
possible the length of the hash digest
should be 256 bits in the Sha 256
algorithm 512 bits in the Sha 512
algorithm and so on bigger digest
usually suggests significantly more
calculations at the cost of speed and
space we typically go for the longest
diges to bolster security but there must
be a definite balance between the speed
and security of a hash
function by Design all hash function of
the sh 512 sh 256 are
irreversible you should neither get a
plain text when you have the digest
beforehand nor should the digest provide
the original value when you pass it
through the same hash function again
another case of protection is that when
the hash digest is passed into the Sha
function for a second time we should get
a completely different digest from the
first instance this is done to reduce
the chance of Brute Force
attacks to achieve this level of
intricacy there are a number of steps to
be followed before we receive the digest
let us take a look at the detailed
procedure as to how the Sha algorithm
works the first step is to make the
plain text compatible with the hash
function to do this we need to pad the
bits in the message when you receive the
input string you have to make sure the
size is 64 bit short of a multiple of
512 when it comes to padding the mids
you must add one first followed by the
remaining zeros to round out the extra
characters this prepares our string to
have a length just 64 bits less than any
multiple of
512 here on out we can proceed to The
Next Step where we have to Pat the
length bits initially in the first step
we appended the message in such a way
that the total number of bits in the
message was 64 bit short from becoming a
multiple of
512 now we add the length of bits in
such a way that the total number of bits
in the message is a perfect multiple of
512 that means 64 bits plus the length
of the original message becomes a
multiple of 512 this becomes a final
string that needs to be
hashed in the next step we have to
initialize this chaining
variables the entire plane text message
can now be broken down into blocks of
512 bits each unlike other hash
algorithms like md5 which use four
registers or buffers sha family use five
buffers of 32 bits each they are named a
b c d and e these registers go through
multiple rounds of operation where the
first iteration has fixed hmal values as
can be seen in the
screen moving on we have to process each
of the 512-bit blocks by breaking each
of them into 16 subblocks of 32 bits
each each of them goes through four
rounds of operation that use the entire
register and have the 512-bit block
along with the constant array out of
those four rounds each round has 20
iterations so in general we have 80
rounds sum
total the constant value of K is an
array of 80
elements of those 80 16 elements are
being used each round so that comes out
to 80 rounds for each of those
elements the value of T differs by the
number of rounds as can be seen in the
table
below a single formula is necessary to
calculate the output of each round and
iteration the formula can be AB CDE
register is equal to e plus a nonlinear
process P along with a circular shift of
a plus WT plus KT in this formula ABCD
is the register value of the chaining
variables as we discussed before p is a
logical process which has a different
formula for each round S5 is a circular
shift by five bits and WT is a 32bit
string derived from the existing
subblock this can be calculated
depending on the iteration at
hand KT signifies a single element of
the 80 character element array which
changes depending on the particular
round at hand for the values of WT the
first 16 values are the same as that of
the subblocks so there is no extra
calculation needed for the next 64
elements the value of WT can be
calculated as shown in the formula here
to better understand this let's take a
look at how each of this goes in a
sequential process we have our initial
register using the five words of 32 bits
each in the first step we put the values
of a b c and d to the subsequent
register as the output next next we use
a nonlinear process P that changes
depending on the round and uses the
values of b c and d as
input whatever output is generated from
the nonlinear process it is added with
the value of the E
registor next the value of a is circular
shifted by five bits and is added with
the output generated in the previous
step the next step is adding the value
of WT and the constant element of KT the
current output is then stored in the
register a similarly this iteration is
repeated every round and for each
subblock in the process once all the
registers are complete and all the
subblocks are joined together to form
the single Cipher text message we will
have our hash output regarding the
nonlinear process P that uses the values
of b c and d as input the formula
changes every round to maintain a
complexity of the program that can
withstand Brute Force attacks the
depending on the round the values are
passed through a logical operation which
is then added with the values of WT KT
and so on now that we understand how to
get our hash digest from the plain text
let us learn about the advantages we
obtain when using the Sha hash algorithm
instead of relying on data in a plain
text
format digital signatures follow
asymmetric encryption methodology to
verify the authenticity of a document or
a file hash algorithms like a s 256 and
the industry standard sh 512 go a long
way in ensuring the verification of
signatures passwords need not be stored
in a plain text format which makes them
accessible to hackers and other
malicious actors when using digest the
database security also gets a boost
since the size of all hash values will
be the same in the event of a hack or a
breach the malicious actor will only
receive the hash values with no way to
regenerate generate the plane text in
this case the plane text would be user
credentials since the hash functions are
irreversible by design it has become a
compulsion when storing passwords on the
servers the SSL handshake is a crucial
segment of the web browsing sessions and
it's done using sha functions it
consists of your web browsers and the
web servers agreeing on encryption keys
and hashing authentication to prepare a
secure connection it relies on a
combination of symmet and asymmetric
algorithms which ensure the
confidentiality of the data transmitted
between a web server and a web client
like the
browsers you can monitor file corruption
by comparing hash values before and
after Transit once the hashes match file
Integrity checks are valid and data
corruption is avoided hash functions
will always give the same output for the
same input irrespective of the iteration
parameters it also helps in ensuring
that the dat data hasn't been tampered
with on route to the receiver of the
message passwords are by far the most
common type of user authentication they
are popular because their Theory makes
perfect sense to individuals and is
reasonably simple to implement for
developers on the other hand poly
constructed passwords can pose security
flaws a well-designed password-based
authentication process does not save the
user's actual password this would make
it far too simple for a hacker or a
malevolent Insider to access all of the
systems user account
in this video you will learn how to
crack passwords and simultaneously try
to make your passwords as Brute Force
resistant as possible let's take a look
at the topics to be covered
today we start by learning about what is
password cracking in
general next we take a look at the
different techniques of password
cracking that hackers use in order to
generate user credentials for
hacking moving on we take a look at the
multiple tools that hackers can use to
generate these hashes and the
passwords finally we take a look at the
steps and the guidelines that users can
follow to prevent their passwords from
being
cracked let's start by giving a basic
idea about password
cracking password cracking is the
process of identifying an unknown
password to a computer or a network
resource using a program code it can
also assist a threat actor in gaining
illegal access to resources malicious
actors can engage in various criminal
activities with the information obtained
through password tracking the procedure
might entail comparing a set of words to
guest credentials or using an algorithm
to guess the password repeatedly
password cracking can be done for
several reasons but the most malicious
reason is in order to gain unauthorized
access to a computer without the owner's
awareness this results in cyber crime
such as stealing passwords for the
purpose of accessing banking information
other non-malicious reasons for password
cracking occur when someone has
misplaced or forgotten a password
password another example of nonm
malicious password cracking may take
place if a system administrator is
conducting test on password strength as
a form of security test this enables so
that the hacker cannot easily access
protected systems the best way that
users can protect their passwords from
cracking is to ensure that they choose
strong
passwords typically passwords must
contain a combination of mixed case
random letters digits and
symbols strong password should never be
actual words in addition
strong passwords are at least 8
characters long in many password
protected applications users are
notified of the strength of the password
theyve chosen upon entering it the user
can then modify it and strengthen the
password based on the indications of its
strength now that we understand the
basics of password cracking let's go to
the basic techniques hackers use to
retrieve passwords from General
victims asking the customer for the
password is simple approach to hacking a
fishing email directs the unwar reader
to a counterfeit login page linked with
whatever service the hacker wants to
access generally by demanding the user
fix some critical security flaw or Aid
in a database reset that page then
captures their password which the hacker
can subsequently exploit for their own
purpose social engineering influences
the victim to get personal information
such as bank account numbers or
passwords the strategy is popular among
hackers because they realize that humans
are the gateway to vitally credentials
and
information through social engineering
the employe tried and through tactics to
exploit and influence age-old human
Tendencies rather than devising novel
means to breach secure and Advanced
Technologies it has been demonstrated
that many firms either lack adequate
security or are overly friendly and
trustworthy when they should not be they
allow granting access to critical
facilities based on a uniform or a so
story a hacker searches a password
dictionary for the the correct password
in the case of a dictionary attack
password dictionaries cover many themes
and of mixture of topics such as
politics movies and music groups users
failure to create a strong password is
why this approach efficiently cracks
passwords till today simply said this
assault employs the same terms that many
individuals use as passwords a hacker
can compare the password hash obtained
to hashes of the password dictionaries
to find the correct plain text
password now that the passwords have
been hashed the hackers attempt to
achieve authentication by breaking the
password hash they accomplish this by
employing a rainbow table which is a set
of pre-computed hashes of portable
password
combinations hackers can use the rainbow
table to crack the hash resulting and
guessing your password as a result it
retrieves the password hash from the
system and eliminates any need to break
it furthermore it does not necessitate
the discovery of the password itself the
breach is accomplished if the hash
matches
in a brood Force assault the attacker
attempts multiple password combinations
until the correct one is identified the
attacker uses software to automate this
process and run exhaustive password
combination in a substantially shorter
length of time with the growth of
hardware and technology in recent years
such programs have been invigorated it
won't be quick if your password is more
than a few characters lengthy but it
will eventually reveal your password
boot Force assaults can be sped up by
throwing more processing resources at
them
with so many different techniques coming
together to correct passwords none of
them are useful without the right tools
there are a prora of scripts and
Snippets of code that can retrieve
passwords from either encrypted storage
or from the hash digest let's go through
some of these
tools cane and able is a password
recovery tool for Microsoft operating
systems it allows easy recovery of
various kinds of passwords by sniffing
the network cracking encrypted passwords
using dictionary Brute Force and crypt
analysis attacks recording Vibe
conversations recording scrambled
passwords recovering wireless network
Keys Etc are some of the other features
of K enable the latest version is faster
and contains a lot of new features like
ARP poison routing which enables
sniffing on Switched lens and man in the
middle attacks the sniffer in this
version can also analyze encrypted
protocols such as ssh1 and https while
containing filters to capture
credentials from a wide range of
authentic ation
mechanisms it also ships routing
protocol authentication monitors and
Route
extractors dictionary and boot Force
crackers are also present along with
common hashing algorithms and several
specific authentications password hash
calculators and other
features John the Ripper is a password
cracking application that was first
released in 1996 for Unix based
computers it was created to evaluate
password strength brot Force encrypted
hash passwords and break passwords using
dictionary attacks it can use dictionary
attacks rainbow tables and other attacks
depending on the target
type Rainbow Crack is a password
tracking application that uses time
memory trade-off algorithm to crack
password hashes with rainbow tables
rainbow tables make password cracking
more easier and faster than traditional
Brute Force attacks it is like a
dictionary containing nearly every
possible password and the pre-calculated
hashes creating this kind of dictionary
takes much more time than cracking a
single hash but after that you can use
the same dictionary over and over again
this procedure might take a long time
however once the table is ready it can
break passwords far quicker than Brute
Force
methods with so many tools ready to enab
our passwords there are certain set of
rules users can follow to protect their
credentials from being compromised let's
cover some of these
guidelines longer passwords are required
ired making the Brute Force mechanism
tougher to implement longer passwords
and passphrases have been demonstrated
to boost security significantly however
it is still critical to avoid lenier
passwords that have previously been
hacked or that feature often in cracking
dictionaries this password policy
encourages users to establish passwords
that do not contain personal information
as previously said most users create
passwords utilizing personal information
such as Hobbies nicknames pet or family
member names Etc if a hacker has access
to personal information about a specific
user for example via social media they
will test password combinations based on
that
knowledge password regulations should
compel users to distinguish between
security and convenience users should be
prohibited from using the same password
for all services password sharing
between users including those who work
in the same department or use the same
equipment should be avoided
a single breached password doesn't
affect your other accounts with this
policy some password regulations
necessitate the creation of a pass
phrase rather than a pass word while
pass phrases serve the same objective
the length make them more difficult to
break in addition to letters a good pass
should include numbers and symbols
passwords may be easier for users to
remember than pass phrases however the
latter is much more breach
resistant two- Factor Authentication or
TFA can help secure an online account or
even a smartphone TFA does this by
asking the user to provide two forms of
information a password or a personal
identification PIN and a code texted to
the user's smartphone or a fingerprint
before accessing whatever is secured
this helps discourage unauthorized
entries to an account without the
original owner's permission at this
point you may wonder why you need a
strong password in the first place even
if most websites are safe there is still
a danger that someone will try to access
or exploit your information a strong
password is among the most effective
ways to protect your accounts and
personal information from hackers you
should follow certain rules and
guidelines while creating a strong
password password managers are also
recommended to help remember the created
passwords for convenience of
usage with that being said let's take a
look at the topics we are covering
today we start by learning about the
state of password cracking in today's
world and why create strong passwords is
an absolute must for every account next
we will look at some guidelines and
rules that help strengthen passwords and
make password cracking a daunting task
for hackers moving on we understand why
past faes have grown in popularity and
are being recommended for credential
protection over traditional passwords
and finally we take a look at how
password managers help alleviate the
problem of creating and remembering
complex passwords along with other
critical personal
information let's start by learning
about why strong passwords have become
an absolute
necessity one of the most common ways
that hackers break into computers is by
guessing passwords simple and commonly
used passwords enable Intruders to
easily gain access and control a
Computing device conversely a password
that is difficult to guess makes it
prohibitively difficult for common
hackers to break into a machine and will
force them to look for another Target
the more difficult the password the
lower the likelihood that once computer
will fall victim to an unwanted
intrusion many individuals opt to tie
their websites to something they can
readily recall to generally easy
memorable combos however this does not
make the password unique in fact it's
the reverse passwords are handled by 53%
of individuals using their Recollections
and memory with modern computational
standards simple passwords take seconds
and a couple of minutes at worst to be
completely brute forced according to
Global surveys more than 60% of people
use the same passwords for their
personal and job applications while this
may allow the user never to forget the
password it makes a single point of
failure the only pin to drop if one of
the accounts gets breached all
subsequent accounts are as good as
hacked to further elaborate on how you
can create strong passwords let's go
through some of the
guidelines let's go through some dos and
Dons to understand how to create new
passwords for accounts it is recommended
to keep the password length at least 12
characters to ensure brute forcing to be
difficult a combination of upper and
lowercase alphabets is an absolute
necessity when creating strong
passwords it is also recommended to use
numerics along with those alphabets to
create a complicated
password finally special characters help
in making a password much more Brute
Force resistant than any number of
alphabets or or letters can make moving
over to the Don
section it's absolutely not recommended
to keep Simple dictionary terms such as
computer or even the word password as
your credential because those are very
easy to be brute forced and are usually
present in majority of the dictionary
attack word list similarly changing a
single alphabet or a single character in
a dictionary word does not make it Brute
Force instant considering there are
already algorithms present that can
counter this
tactic using the same character multiple
times in a password also reduces the
strength and makes it easier to crack
for
hackers apart from using single
characters multiple times following
patterns that are present on the
traditional English keyboard such as e w
t y or the line below the main alphabet
such as the ZX cvbnm Etc make it easier
to guess since these are once again
common combinations that are present in
word list
already finally the most important part
being not using personal information
such as birthdays addresses and other
important information in the passwords
more often than not if a hacker is
trying to break into your account there
has been some amount of research done be
it via social media or any other medium
if they have already this information
present with them breaking into your
account becomes all the more
easier
now that you understand how to create
strong password look at how pass phases
have become prevalent as a replacement
for plain text
passwords a past phrase is a sentence--
like string of words used for
authentication that is longer than a
traditional password easy to remember
and difficult to crack typical passwords
range on an average from 8 to 16
characters while passphrases can reach
up to 100 characters or more using a
long passphrase instead of a short
password to create a digital signature
is one of the many ways that users can
strengthen the security of their data
devices and accounts the longer a p
phrase is the more likely a user is to
incorporate bits of entropy of factors
that make it less predictable to
potential attackers as more websites
applications and services increase the
user security requirements a p phas is a
fast and easy way to meet these
criterias let's take a look at some of
the advantages that past faes have over
common
passwords pass phrases are simpler to
remember than just a random assortment
of symbols and characters it's easier to
comprehend a line from your favorite
song or a quotation than a short but
difficult password passwords are
reasonably easy for humans and robots to
guess or crack online thieves have also
Advanced and created Cutting Edge
hacking tools to crack even the most
complex
passwords passphrases are nearly hard to
crack since most efficient password
cracking programs fail at approximately
10 characters as a result even the most
sophisticated cracking tool will be
unable to guess brute force or
pre-compute these passwords complies
with password setting rules with EAS
passphrases the usage of punctuation and
upper and lowercase password satisfy the
password complexity criteria most
operating systems and apps support past
phrases phrases of up to 127 characters
are permitted on all major operating
systems including Windows Linux and Mac
as a result for optimal protection you
can use lengthier pass
phrases but when creating a strong
password the major problem people come
across is remembering these passwords or
the pass phrases this is where you can
find a use for a password
manager when you establish accounts or
change passwords password managers
generate new strong passwords and they
keep all of them in one place protected
by a single single strong master
password if you maintain your master
password the manager will retain
everything else including your username
and pass phrases and fill them in for
you whenever you sign on to a website or
app on your computer or phone there is
no good memory needed for this this
implies that everyone may use the most
recent suggestions for strong passwords
such as extended phrases symbols grammar
and
capitalization password managers enable
consumers to write a single master
password and automatically F each
website with their own unique set of
credentials and not just passwords
credit card information may be stored
securely with several password managers
some others make multiactor
authentication or use a second test such
as answering a question once the correct
password is input which is a simple and
effective solution to verify legitimate
login
inputs among the global players in
password managers services like biten
keas and have been running for years now
and are very worthy recommendations if
you want to get started with password
management now that we understand what
is hacking let's take a look at some
points to know whether our system is
already hacked or
not the first point regarding how to
check whether a system is hacked or not
can be cases where the system security
is Switched Off by unknown means and it
is not visible to user this is one of
the most primary checkpoint to know if
our system is hacked or
not next point to check whether a system
is hacked or not would be frequent
antivirus software failures which are
due to the interference from hacking
attempts performed by a professional
hacker or a cyber
criminal then we also face problems
regarding systems reaction speed which
is affected due to the the execution of
unknown applications in the background
of the
system which also affects the hardware
resources in the
device next we also face problems
regarding passwords which are no longer
working or are changed without a user's
Intervention which might indicate that
there was some unknown hacking activity
that took place in our
account
let's take a look at some more points
regarding the
topic there are often cases when the
system's cursor move on its own and
perform tasks indicating that the system
is being used by someone else using an
illegal hacking method there are also
cases when we often see files and
folders being created in the storage dis
on the system which is unknown to us to
better understand the points regarding
how to identify whether our system is
hacked or not let's take a look then
let's start with the first
point if we want to check whether our
system is haed or not the first point
would be to choose the settings
option and using privacy and security
and moving on to the window security
this option that is available on our
system allows us to see various
protection applications that are
available on the
system if we see any problem regarding
any one of them for example apps and
browser control in my system it says
there's a problem with it which might be
due to hacking attempts that was done on
my
system now let's take a look at the
other option how we can check whether
our system is hacked or not that would
be checking the antivirus software that
is installed in our
system if you face problems regarding
that this might be the
issue according to my antivirus software
it says my computer is at risk this
might be due to the interference from
cyber criminal or a hacker while using
different illegal softwares during its
hacking
attempt then there are also
cases where we see there are unknown
programs being executed in the
background of our system which we can
take a look using the task manager
software using the task manager we can
take a look at each and every
application that is being executed in
the system and see the
origin if we find any unknown program or
application we can assume that it might
be due to a hacking
attempt moving on if we want to check
further whether our system is hacked or
not
we can check for files or folders that
are being created unknown to us for
example this unknown
folder which contains some security
details that are unknown to
me this might be also due to a hacking
attempt by a hacker or a cyber
criminal then there are also cases when
the systems cursor move on its own and
perform tasks that are not initiated by
us and performs copying of different
folders or data from one file to other
this is due to a hacking attempt that
was done on a system and the hacker has
taken control of a
system then there are also cases
regarding login issues or password
problem for
example if I want to access into my
account and there's a problem with the
password it might be due
to the attempt of hacking into my
account by a professional
hacker seems like there's a problem with
the username which means there was a
hacking attempt by a professional
hacker we can further check hacking
attempts by accessing a web browser and
checking whether there's some extra
add-ons or Unown add-ons that wasn't
installed by us this might also indicate
a hacking attempt on the system now that
we are clear about how to check whether
a system is hacked or not let's take a
look at some of the counter measure
against hacking let's
begin the first point regarding how to
avoid hacking is do regular manual
Security checks and keep the system
security updated using certified
antivirus softwares is a basic counter
measure against hiking
attempts and if possible visit only
secure websites for surfing on the
Internet or use VPN or other Internet
Security applications to mask your
systems Network to avoid any hacking
attempts for the
device then we have avoid clicking on
random web popups and ads to avoid
Hackers from getting into a system and
accessing a device
data and lastly use strong passwords or
complex passwords for your login
details applying these counter measures
we can avoid hacking to a certain extent
the concept of instant messaging crossed
into the mainstream in the 1990s
allowing friends acquaintances
colleagues and like-minded thinkers from
all over the world to connect in real
time since then instant messaging has
revolutionized how we communicate and
today over a billion people are signed
up for at least one messaging app the
present instant messaging experience is
seamless and it intuitively integrates
features like video photos voice
e-commerce and gaming with plain or
messaging among these apps WhatsApp has
comfortably found its place among the
most popular messaging platforms like
everyone associated with the internet a
matter of security is never far away
considering the huge user base of this
messaging app hackers are always on the
lookout for compromised accounts to grab
today we are going to cover some of the
ways we can protect our WhatsApp account
from falling into malicious
hands we start by learning about the
importance of security when it comes to
WhatsApp and instant messaging apps in
general next we cover some of the most
important steps that should be followed
in order to protect our WhatsApp
accounts from
hackers finally we learn what we should
do when a WhatsApp account gets
compromised let's start by learning why
we need to focus on the safety of
WhatsApp
in the year of 2020 the big news was
about Amazon CEO Jeff Bezos and his
phone being haed by Saudi Arabia a
report coming from the guardian
suggested that bezos's phone was hacked
via a video file sent on WhatsApp the
report said that bezos's mobile phone
was hacked by Saudi Arabian prince in
the year 2018 and gigabytes worth of
data was stolen from the device while
there are some issues being raised about
the report which states with the medium
to high confidence that Jeff piz's phone
was hacked it does raise a security fear
for regular users after all if the phone
of one of the world's most powerful men
can be hacked the same can happen to any
one of us as
well when it comes to regular users we
exchange messages with our loved ones
regarding a paradigm of topics the
information which may seem trivial
initially can later function as
ammunition for a campaign regarding
identity theft basic information like
preferred Banks occasional dining places
can go a long way in Social Engineering
attacks further increasing the need for
secure messaging
habits WhatsApp uses endtoend encryption
to protect all communication on its
platform these encryption keys not only
make it impossible to decrypt messages
but they also prevent third parties and
even WhatsApp from accessing messages or
calls but not entirely although end to
encryption makes WhatsApp more secure
than other communication apps no app is
100% safe to use like any application or
digital device WhatsApp is often
targeted by Bad actors
it also has access to your contacts and
tracks where and how long you use it
putting your privacy and personal
information at
risk we all have access to our cell
phones so it's no surprise that sms2
factor authentication is one of the most
widespread types of MFA available you
don't need any apps or digital keys and
it's not tip to a specific ecosystem
unfortunately it's also not a secure
multiactor authentication method the
nature of SMS itself opens up your or
organization to a host of risk hackers
may have many ways to leverage SMS to
find a way into your accounts and
network be it via spoofed SIM cards or
message hijacking WhatsApp toofa using
SMS isn't a foolproof
solution now that we understand the
variety of reasons why WhatsApp needs
extra security let's go through some of
the ways we can achieve
this it is more than probable that one
fine day you might receive a WhatsApp
message or even an SMS that reads that
your order is delayed please check its
data here or your account is locked and
please unlock it here or even some
tempting messages like win free 3G and
movie tickets here some of them may
sound intimidating and some of them may
be lucrative but they all have one
purpose to trick you into clicking that
link and once you do that it's already
over it will install malware on your
phone and you won't have a clue about it
only when you start noticing that your
phone bills are abnormally high or your
bank account has been used without your
permission the realization will Dawn
upon you that something is wrong with
your phone but by then it may be too
late WhatsApp in itself provides various
privacy options to users the messaging
platform provides users with option to
choose who they want to share their
profile photo status and other details
with it's a good idea to change the
settings to contacts only this means
only phone numbers that are saved on
your smartphone will be able to see your
profile photo status phone number and
autod delete status as
well make sure you enable the option to
lck the screen every time WhatsApp is
closed this will ensure no one else but
you can open your WhatsApp account just
head to the settings menu privacy and
select the screen lock option you will
then need to register your fingerprint
after the process is completed you will
have to scan your fingerprint every time
you open the WhatsApp app this adds an
extra layer of security
the two-step verification works as an
extra layer of security and helps
WhatsApp users to protect their otps and
documents shared through WhatsApp it's
very easy to set up a PIN to activate a
two-step verification users have to
enter it periodically once it is
activated WhatsApp will sometimes keep
asking users to enter this six-digit
passcode users cannot disable this
without disabling the two-step
verification feature alog together in
case users do not provide WhatsApp with
an email ID and want to disable twostep
verification then the number will be
permitted to
reverifying messages upon reverifying
we often have the tendency to log to
Whatsapp web at the office and then
leave the account open on the desktop
The Habit can actually create problems
for you someone else sitting on the same
PC can access all your chats without you
even realizing it it's a good practice
to log out from WhatsApp before leaving
the office it just takes a few seconds
to log in again by just scanning the
code and you're
done all WhatsApp users should ensure
that the chats are end to end encrypted
to verify that a chat is end to- endend
encrypted open the chat tap on the name
of the contact to open the contact info
screen and then tap encryption to view
the QR code and a 60 digigit number
WhatsApp n2n encryption ensures that
only you and your contact can read the
messages that are being exchanged and
nobody in between not even
WhatsApp with the necessary guidelines
out of the way let us go to the
recommended course of action should our
WhatsApp accounts be
compromised the first and most important
thing that you need to do is report the
issue to the WhatsApp support team for
assistance make sure that you reach out
to the support team through its help
desk and Report the hacking attempt
WhatsApp help center will take the
shortest time to resolve the issue via
email or within the app itself this will
help you to take prompt legal action
against the hackers if you can't access
your email call the support team in some
cases the support will deactivate your
WhatsApp account and request you to
reactivate within 30 days if you don't
want it to be deleted
completely when someone compromises your
WhatsApp account they can now send
messages to your contact stating that
the company sent your verification code
and gain access to the account that's
why one of the first things you'll want
to do is send a message to your friends
and family letting the know that you've
lost access to your account this action
prevents further exploitation of your
account and others another reason you
want to let your contacts know you have
no access to your WhatsApp account is
that they may fish for personal
information from your banking number to
your email address hackers will cleverly
attempt to gain as much access to your
personal information as
possible WhatsApp web is an extension of
WhatsApp messenger over the web that
facilitates easy synchronization of our
smartphone and personal computer
computer this is the biggest security
threat that hackers can easily exploit
to get into your personal data over
WhatsApp therefore it is highly
recommended that you use this WhatsApp
feature carefully once you notice that
your what messenger has been hacked go
to your WhatsApp web and tap or click on
the log out from all computers option
this will deactivate all the web
extensions of your
account another the unfortunate
circumstances where the account recovery
doesn't seem likely you can always ask
WhatsApp support to delete your account
permanently while far from the ideal
solution it can act as a failsafe option
if you want to protect your personal
data at any cost possible you can always
open a new account later with the
security issues mitigated it's no secret
that the majority of our internet usage
set the risk of being hacked be it via
unsafe messaging applications or
misconfigured operating systems to
counteract this void of digital security
penetration testing has become the norm
when it comes to vulnerability
assessment K Linux is an operating
system that has become a well-known
weapon in this fight against hackers a
Linux distribution that is made
specifically for penetration testers K
Linux has layers of features that we
will be covering in today's lesson let's
take a look at the topics to be covered
in this
video we start by learning about K Linux
and a basic explanation of its purpose
we take a look at the history of K Linux
from the story of its origin to its
current day exploits
next we learn a few distinct features of
Kali that make it an attractive choice
for penetration testers
worldwide finally we take a look at the
multiple ways we can install K Linux to
start our journey in the world of
penetration testing let's start by
learning about K Linux in
general Ki Linux which is formerly known
as backtrack Linux is an open- Source
Linux distribution aimed at Advanced
penetration testing and security
auditing
it contains several hundred tools that
are targeted towards various information
security tasks such as penetration
testing security research computer
forensics and reverse engineering color
Linux is a multiple platform solution
accessible and freely available to
Information Security Professionals and
hobbyists among all the Linux
distributions K Linux takes its roots
from the Debian operating system Debian
has been a highly dependable and stable
distri distribution for many years
providing a similarly strong Foundation
to the Kali
desktop while the operating system is
capable of practically modifying every
single part of our installation the
networking components of Kali become
disabled by default this is done to
prevent any external factors from
affecting the installation procedure
which may pose a risk in critical
environments apart from boosting
security it allows a deeper element of
control to the most enthusiastic of
users
we did not get K Linux since the first
day how did it come into existence let's
take a look at some of its
history K Linux is based on years of
knowledge and experience in building
penetration testing and operating
systems during all these project
lifelines there have been only a few
different developers as the team has
always been small the first project was
called Vex which stands for white hat
nopex as can be inferred from the name
it was based on the noix operating
system as its underlying OS opix had
releases ranging from version 2.0 to
2.7 this made way for the next project
which was known as wax or the long hand
being white hat slacks the name Chang
was because the base OS was changed from
noix to slacks wax started at version 3
as a nod it carrying on from WPIX there
was a similar OS being produced at the
same time auditor security collection
often being shorted to just auditor
which was once again using
KNIX its efforts were combined with wax
to produce backtrack backtrack was based
on slackware from version 1 to version 3
but switched to Ubuntu later on with
version 4 to version 5 using the
experience gained from all of this Ki
Linux came after backtrack in 2013 Ki
started off using Debian stable as the
engine under the hood before moving to
Debian testing when Kali Linux became a
rolling operating
system now that we understand the
history and the purpose of K Linux let
us learn a little more about its
distinct
features the latest version of Khali
comes with more than 600 penetration
tools
pre-installed after reviewing every tool
that was included in backtrack
developers have eliminated a great
number of tools that either simply did
not work or which duplicated other tools
that provided the same or similar
functionality the Kali Linux team team
is made up of a small group of
individuals who are the only ones
trusted to commit packages and interact
with the depositories all of which is
done using multiple secure protocols
restricting access of critical code
bases to external asset greatly reduces
the risk of source contamination which
can cause K Linux users worldwide a
great deal of damage as a direct victim
of cyber
crime although penetration tools tend to
be written in English the developers
have ensured that Khali includes true
multilingual support allowing more users
to operate in the native language and
locate the tools they need for the job
the more comfortable a user feels with
the intricacies of the operating system
the easier it is to maintain a
stronghold over the configuration and
the device in
general since Arm based single board
systems like the Raspberry Pi are
becoming more and more prevalent and
inexpensive the development team knew
that Khali's armm support would need to
be as robust as as they could manage
with fully working
installations K Linux is available on a
wide range of armm devices and has armm
repositories integrated with the
mainline distributions so the tools for
armm are updated in conjunction with the
rest of the
distribution all this information is
necessary for users to determine if K
Linux is the correct choice for them if
it is what are the ways that they can go
forward with this installation and start
the penetration testing
Journey the first way to use scal is by
launching the distribution in the live
USB mode this can be achieved by
downloading the installer image file or
the ISO file from the Kali Linux website
and flashing it to a USB drive with a
capacity of at least 8 GB some people
don't need to save their data
permanently and a live USB is the
perfect solution for such cases after
the iso image is flashed the thumb drive
can be used to boot a fully working
installation of the operating system
with the cavar that any changes made to
the OS in this mode are not written
permanently some cases allow persistent
usage in live USBS but those require
further configuration than normal
situations but what if the user wants to
store data permanently in the installed
OS the best and the most reliable way to
ensure this is the full-fledged hard
disk installation this will ensure the
complete usage of the system's Hardware
capabilities and will take into account
the updates and the configurations being
made to the OS this method is supposed
to override any pre-existing operating
system installed on the computer be it
windows or any other variant of
Linux the next alternative route for
installing K Linux would be to use
virtualization software such as VMware
or virtual box the software will be
installed as a separate application on
an already existing OS and K Linux can
be run as an operating system in the
same computer as a window the hardware
requirements will be completely
customizable starting with the allotted
Ram to the vir virtual hard disk
capacity the usage of both a host and
guest operating system like K Linux
allows users a safe environment to learn
while not putting the systems at risk if
you want to learn more about how one can
go forward with this method we have a
dedicated video where K Linux is being
installed on VMware while running on a
Windows 10 operating system you can find
the link in the description box to get
started with your very own virtual
machine the final way to install Kali
Linux is by using a dual boot system to
put it in simple words the K Linux OS
will not be overriding any pre-installed
operating system on a machine but will
be installed alongside it when a
computer boots up the user will get a
choice to boot into either of these
operating systems many people prefer to
keep both the windows and Kali Linux
installed so the distribution of work
and recreational activities is also
allotted effectively it gives users a
safety valve should their custom Linux
installation run into any bugs that
cannot be fixed from within the
operating system now for the convenience
of explanation we're going to install K
Linux today on a virtual machine
software known as VMware VMware is able
to run multiple operating systems on a
single host machine which in our case is
a Windows 10
system to get started with K Linux
installation we have to go to the
website to download an image
file we go to get Kali and as you can
see there are multiple platforms on
which this operating system can be
inverted as per our requirement we're
going to go with the virtual machine
section as you can see it is already
recommended by the
developers this is the download button
which will download a 64bit ISO file we
can download 32-bit but that is more
necessary for hard metal machines or if
you're going to use it for older devices
which do not support 64-bit operating
systems yet after clicking on on the
download button we can see we have a wi
archive which will have the ISO
files for now we have downloaded the ISO
file and it is already present with me
so we can start working on the VMS side
of things once the ISO file is
downloaded we open up VMware
Workstation go to file and we create a
new virtual
machine in these two options it is
highly recommended to go with the
typical setup rather than the custom one
the custom is much more advanced and
requires much more information from the
user which is beneficial for developers
and people who are well versed with
virtualization software but for 90% of
the cases typical setup will be
enough here we can select the third
option which will be I will install the
operating system later in some operating
systems we can use the ISO file here
directly and VMR will install it for us
but right now in the case of K Linux the
third option is always the
safest K Linux is a Linux distribution
so we can select Linux over here and the
version as you can see here it have
multiple versions such as the multiple
Kels every distribution has a a parent
distribution for example K Linux has
Debian and there are other distributions
which are based or forked from some
parent distribution kinus is based of
Debian so we can go with the highest
version of Debian which is the Debian
10. X
64bit go on next we can write any such
name we can write K Linux so that it'll
be easier to recognize the virtual
machine among this list of virtual
machine instances the location can be
any location you decide to put by
default this should be the documents
folder but anywhere you put it will hold
up all the information of the operating
system all the files you download all
the configurations you store everything
will be stored in this particular
location that you
provide when we go next we are asked
about the dis capacity this disc
capacity will be all the storage that
will be provided to your virtual machine
of K Linux think of your Windows device
if you have a 1 TB of hard drive you
have the entirety of the hard disk to
store data on how much data you give
here you can only store up to that
amount of data not to mention some
amount of capacity will be taken up by
the operating system itself to store its
programs and applications for now we can
give around let's say 15 GB of
information or if a recommended size for
Dean is 20 you can just go ahead at 20
it depends all on the user case if
you're going to use it extensively you
can even go as high as 50 or 60 GB if
you have plans to download many more
applications and perform multiple
different tests another option we get
over here is storing virtual dis as a
single file or storing them into
multiple
files as we already know this virtual
machine run entirely on
VMware sometimes when transferring these
virtual machine instances let's say from
a personal computer to a work computer
we're going to need to copy up the
entire folder that we had mentioned
before over
here instead all virtual machines have a
portability feature now this portability
feature is possible for all scenarios
except it is much easier if the split
the virtual dis into multiple files now
even if this makes porting virtual
machines easier from either system to
system or software to software let's say
if you want to switch from VMware to
Virtual box or vice versa the
performance takes a small hit it's not
huge but it's recommended to go with
storing the virtual L as a single file
if you have no purposes of ever moving
the virtual machine machine even if you
do it's not a complete stop that it
cannot be ported it's just easier when
using multiple files but in order to get
the best performance out of the virtual
machine we can store it as a single file
over
here this is a summary of all the
changes that we made and all the
configurations that have been settled
until now now at this point of time we
have not provided the do ISO file yet
which is the installation file for the K
Linux that we downloaded from this
website
as of right now we have only configured
the settings of the virtual machine so
we can press on
finish and we have K Linux in the list
now to make the changes further we press
on edit virtual machine
settings the memory is supposed to give
the ram of the virtual machine so
devices with ram of 8 GB or below that
giving high amount of ram will cause
performance is issues and the host
system if the memory has some amount of
free storage left let's say on idle
storage my Windows machine takes about 2
GB so I have 6 GB of memory to provide
although if you provide all of the 6 GB
it'll be much more difficult for the
host system to run everything properly
so for this instance we can keep it as
2GB of memory for the virtual machine
instance similarly we can use the number
of processors and we can customize it
according to our liking let's say if we
want to use One processor but we want to
use two different cores we can select
them as
well hard disk is preset up as the SCSI
hard disk and it does not need to be
changed for the installation of this
operating system at
all CD ID DVD this is where the
installation file comes you can think of
the ISO file that we downloaded as a pen
drive or a USB thumb drive which is
necessary to install an operating system
to provide this we going to select use
ISO IM image file you're going to click
on
browse going to go to downloads and
select the Im so file over
here select
open and we can see it is already loaded
up next in the network adapter it is
recommended to use natat this helps the
virtual machine to draw the internet
from the host machine settings if your
host machine is connected to the
internet then the virtual machine is
connected as well there are some other
options such as host only or custom
segments or land segments but those are
not necessary for
installation rest of them are pretty
standard which do not need any extra
configuration and can be left as it
is press okay and now we can power on
this virtual
machine in this screen we can choose how
we want to proceed with the
installation we have a start installer
option over here so we're going to press
enter on
that we going to wait for the things to
load from the ISO
file um the first step in the
installation is choosing the language of
the operating system for this we can go
with English as
standard this is a location this will be
used for setting up the time and some of
the internal settings which depend
entirely on the location of the user so
for this we're going to go with
India configuring the keyboard it's
always recommended to go with the
American English first many people make
a mistake of going with the Indian
keyboard if it is possible and it
provides a lot of issues later on so
it's always preferred to go with the
American English and if later we see
some necessity of another keyboard
dialect that is NE required we we can
install it later but for now we should
always stick with American English as a
basic at this point it's going to load
the installation components from the ISO
file it is a big file of 3.6 GB so it
has a lot of components that need to be
put into the virtual machine which can
also be used to detect
Hardware
once the hardware and the network
configuration is done by the ISO file we
want to write a host name for the system
this host name can be anything which is
used to recognize this device on a local
network or a land cable let's say if we
use the name
Kali domain name you we can skip it for
now it's not necessary as such for the
installation this is the full name for
the
user let's say we can provide the name
as simply learn as a full
name next we're going to set up a
username this username is going to be
necessary to identify the user from its
root accounts and the subsequent bow
accounts for now we can give it as
something as simply one to
three now we have to choose a password
for the user now remember since this is
the first user that is being added onto
this newly inst install operating system
it needs to be a password for the
administrator we can use whichever
password we like over
here and use the same password below and
press on
continue at this point it's going to
detect on the components on which the
operating system can be
installed like here there are multiple
options like the use entire disk use
entire dis and set up lvm use entire dis
and set up encrypted lvm for newcomers
it is recommended to just use the first
one since lvm encryption is something
that you can learn afterwards when
you're much more hands on with the Linux
operating system for now we're going to
use the use entire dis guided
installation and press on
continue when we set up the virtual
machine on VMware we had set up a dis
capacity that we gave a prose 20gb that
is the hard disk which is being
discovered here even though it is a
virtual dis on VMR it acts as a normal
hard disk on which an operating system
can be installed so we select this one
and press on
continue here there is a multiple
partition system all the operating
systems that are installed have
different components one is used for the
a keeping of the applications one for
the files other for the RAM management
and other things for newcomers it is
always recommended to keep it in one
partition and we're going to select that
and press on continue
this is just an overview of the
partition it's going to make as you can
see it has a primary partition of 20.4
GB and a logical partition of 1 GB used
for swap memory now these kind of naming
can be confusing for people who are not
well versed with Linux operating systems
or in general virtualization but for now
you can go ahead and press on continue
as this will be fine we can press on
finish partitioning and write changes to
disk and continue
it's just a confirmation page as you can
see it's WR that scsi3 is our virtual
hard disk of 20gp disc
capacity we write the changes to the
disk we press yes and click on
continue at this point the installation
has started now this installation will
take a while depending on the amount of
ram provided the processor provided and
how quickly the performance of the
system is being hampered by the host
machine on quicker systems this will be
rather quick while on the smaller ones
this will take a
while since this is going to take some
time to install as it is being run on a
virtual machine with only 2GB of RAM
we're going to speed up this part of the
video so we don't have to waste any more
time just watching the progress
bar
now that our core installation is
completed it's asking us to configure a
package manager the work of a package
manager on Linux operating system is
similar to the Google Play Store on
Android mobile devices and on the app
store for the Apple
devices it's an interface to install
external applications which are not
installed by default let's say for
Google Chrome or any other browser which
can be used to browse the internet
at this point of time it's ask us to
select a network mirror we're going to
select as yes and move forward with this
next it's going to ask us for an HTTP
proxy which we can leave it as blank and
press it as continue
forward at this point of time it's
looking for updates to the K Linux
installation this will fetch the new
builds from the Kali server so the
installation is always updated to the
latest
version
now that the package manager is
configured we have the grub bootloader
the grub is used for selecting the
operating system while booting up its
core functionality is to allow the
operating system to be loaded correctly
without any faults so at this point of
time if it ask install the grab boot
loader to your primary dive we can
select this as yes and press
continue remember the installation was
conducted on dev
SDA so we're going to select
installation of the gr loader on the
same hard disk that we have
configured we press this one and press
continue so now the grub bootloader is
being installed the grub is highly
essential because it it shows the
motherboard where to start the operating
system from even if the operating system
is installed correctly and all the files
are in correct order the absence of a
boot loader will not be able to launch
the OS
properly
as you can see the installation is
finally complete so now we can press on
continue and it's going to finalize the
changes now you can see K Linux being
booted up straight away it doesn't check
for the ISO file anymore since the
operating system is now installed onto
the virtual hard disk storage that we
had configured
before
here we're going to enter our username
and password that we had set up
before and we have the color system
booted
up and this is your homepage we can see
the installed applications over here
which are being used for penetration
testing by multiple security analyst
worldwide all of these come
pre-installed with K Linux and others
can be installed using the AP package
manager that we had
configured we can see a full name over
here and with this our installation of
the K Linux is complete hey everyone
it's no secret that the majority of our
internet usage is at the risk of getting
hacked be it via unsafe messaging
applications or misconfigured operating
systems to counteract this void of
digital security penetration testing has
become the norm when it comes to
vulnerability assessment par security OS
is an operating system that has become a
well-known weapon in this fight against
hackers a Linux distribution more cater
towards penetration testers specifically
parent security has layers of features
that we will be covering in today's
lesson
let's take a look at the topics for this
video we start by learning about what
par security is and why it should be
considered as a viable alternative next
to K Linux or penetration
testers next we take a look at the
minimum system requirements necessary to
obtain Optimum performance from an
installation of par security moving on
we learn about some unique features that
make parot Stand Out Among the multiple
ethical hacking operating systems
available on the market
and finally we look at the multiple ways
that par security OS can be installed be
it on a single system or for portable
media so let's start out by learning
what parot security
is paratos is a Debian based Linux
distribution with an emphasis on
security privacy and development it is
built on debian's testing branch and
uses a custom Harden Linux kernel while
being founded in
parro security contains several hundred
tools targeted towards various
information security tasks such as
penetration testing security research
computer for insex and reverse
engineering it has become a
multi-platform solution accessible and
freely available to Information Security
Professionals and
hobbies it features a distinct forensic
mode that does not Mount any of the
system hard diss or partitions and has
no influence on the host system making
it more stealy than regular mode this
mode is used on the host system when
there is a need for executing forensic
procedures in software development a
rolling release is a paradigm in which
software upgrades are rolled out
constantly rather than in batches of
versions this ensures that the software
is constantly up to date rolling release
distribution such as parro security OS
follows the same concept providing the
most recent Linux kernel and software
versions as they become available on the
market
with the basic introduction to the
operating system out of the way let us
have a look at the bare minimum system
requirements necessary to be able to run
this operating
system first up we got a CPU requirement
which states that a 1 GHz dual Coe CPU
is the absolute minimum in order to use
parat OS while multiple core systems
will provide more Optimum performance a
small beginner has been
included a very distinct thing to be
noted is that the operating system can
be installed on all variants of chipsets
be 32-bit 64-bit and the newly popular
armm portfolio of
devices unlike K Linux which requires
some amount of graphical acceleration
needed to display the operating system
correctly paratos has no such
requirements and can be used with the
leanest of
machines taking into account the ram
issue a minimum of 256 MB to 512 MB free
Ram provides the optimum usage
scenarios even when the OS is installed
on a hard drive storage media it should
theoretically occupy around 8 GB of
information which may extend up to 16 GB
depending on the tools being installed
out of the box when it comes to booting
options we have the option of going with
the Legacy BIOS settings or with the
more modern ufi settings these are just
some of the requirements for the
installation of parro security OS to
understand this process more vividly and
to learn how visualization can help
install an OS in our existing computer
please follow the link to a par security
installation video linked right
above let's understand what some of the
things that make parot security unique
among all the other penetration testing
operating
systems along with all the giant catalog
of scripts par security has its own
custom hardened Linux kernel which has
been modified explicitly to provide as
much security and resistance to hackers
as possible as a first line of defense
the configurations in the operating
system act as a second Gateway taking
care of militia's requests and dropping
them off this is particularly beneficial
since should there be a scenario where
the latest Linux kernel is causing some
particular issue the parat development
team will most likely IR in it out first
before passing it on as an
update if the custom hardened kernel
wasn't reasoning enough parent security
developers manage to install more
hacking tools and scripts to ensure a
smooth transition for the gal Linux
users
all the tools you found in Kali are
present in parto and then a few extra
ones for good measure this has been
achieved while keeping roughly the same
size of the installation file between
both operating
systems however it's not all
productivity points for parro OS they
provide a choice between two different
desktop environments the made desktop
which comes pre-installed by default and
KDE for those unfamiliar with Linux
terminology you can think of desktop
environments as the main UI for a Linux
system being highly modular in nature
one can use K Linux or paratos while
adding another DT of environment which
they find appealing while Kali has only
a single option paratto has managed to
provide two optimized Wills with M
desktop and KD desktop ready made on the
website one of the primary advantages of
paratos over Kali is that it's
relatively light weight this implies
that it takes frequently less dis space
and computing power to function properly
with as little as 320 MB of ram required
in reality parat OS is also designed to
operate successfully off a USB stick but
K liux does not work well from a USB
stick and is generally installed in a
virtual machine parat can be seen as
more of a niche distribution if you're
searching for something lighter than K
Linux there are multiple ways to go
about with this
installation many people prefer to
install it directly onto a hard disk
where the parad security OS will
override whichever data the hard already
has now this is beneficial if you want
to preserve your data for the long term
but this might pose some trouble to
people who do not have a spare hard disk
or do not want to lose their current
installation of Windows operating system
another way to use par security is by
using the live boot but whatever changes
we make to the live boot operating
system those changes are removed the
moment we restart or shut down the
system a very good Common Ground between
both these installations is
virtualization using virtu virualization
software like VMware or virtual box we
can install parad security on our
systems while simultaneously saving our
data and having the convenience of a
host machine such as a Windows operating
system in case things go
wrong to start the installation we first
need to get a ISO file for the par
security operating system this can be
found on the current
website parat sec.org
once we enter the website move into the
the download
section and select the get security
Edition over
here par security OS has multiple
desktop environments to you to choose
from these desktop environments serves
as a different user interface for the
user for example right now we have the M
desktop and the KDE desktop as you can
see from the screenshots both of these
look quite different while having a
similar look and feel to them for our
example let's go with a M desktop we
have two options either we can go with
the direct download or we can get the
torrent file for this example if you
press on the download
button and our download will start I
have already downloaded this file but
the ISO file provided over here will
serve as an installation it will have
around 4 and 1/2 GB of space it will be
used to install this operating system in
VMware once the file is downloaded we
can close the
and open VMware Workstation VMware can
also be used as a player version or the
Workstation version if you have much
more familiarity with using virtual box
of virtualization application we can use
that as
well once the VMware is open we click on
file and select a new virtual
machine for the first time installation
we're going to go with the typical and
recommended installation procedure
instead of an advanced one if you have
already installed multiple virtual
machine os's going with the advanced
option will give you much more control
over the hardware customization but for
now we're going to stick with the
typical
option moving on it'll ask us for a
source to where to install the operating
system from since we're going to use a
live ISO first we're going to select the
third option which will be I will
install the operating system later and
press
next as we already know parent security
is a derivative so When selecting the
guest operating system type we're going
to go with Linux and the selection we're
going to choose whichever the highest
version of Debian is along with a 64bit
OS we're going to click on next we're
going to name our virtual machine let's
say parent security
OS we're going to select the location
where we want to save the virtual
machine this will have all the hard disk
of the operating system
installation we're going to click on
next for the disk size we're going to
specify how much of the current memory
are we going to allocate this is the
hard disk memory of the operating system
installation whatever changes you make
in the operating system whatever
applications we install on the virtual
instance will all be stored in this
amount of memory while it is recommended
to go with at least 15 GB of storage we
can go as high as possible and we're
going to select the recommended 20 GB
app has
written when given the choice of storing
the virtual dis as a single or multiple
files many people want to keep their
virtual instance in a way so that it
helps them stay portable people change
systems and sometimes they want to swap
their instances between the work and
their personal computer if there is no
portability in mind storing the virtual
dis as a single file gives the best
performance and should be the
recommended goto when installing for the
first time we click on next here and and
it's going to give us a summary of the
settings we have already settled till
now we're going to press on
finish and there we go we have our
installation First Step
completed here on out we're going to
click on edit virtual machine
settings here we're going to have a look
at some of the requirements that the
parent security OS will need it is known
to be a memory lightweight operating
system but just to have the most Optimum
performance we're going to provide
around 2 GB of RAM from our host system
which is a Windows 10
machine when it comes to the processors
I'm going to increase it to two and the
number of CES to two as well so giving
out a total four processor CES to the
operating system now this depends on
what are your computer rig and how much
resources you can justify so these need
to be customized according to the system
at
hand hard size has already been set at
20gb and the rest of them are pretty
standard and we can go go on one thing
that we need to make sure is selecting
the CD DVD IDE here we have to use a ISO
image file over here previously it
should be used physical drive and at
Auto detect we're going to use a use ISO
image file over here we're going to
click on
browse we're going to go to where we
have downloaded the ISO file which is
over here and select
it press okay
here and and we can now power on this
virtual
machine at this point of time there are
two options we can go with the try
install option using the graphical user
interface or we can go using the
terminal mode to get a better user
experience we're going to go with the
try install mode specifically press
enter and it's going to start the live
boot ISO mean meanwhile VMware has an
prompt over here where it will try to
install some VMware tools on it while
this is not mandatory it is much more
recommended to install these tools so
that you can get some additional
features like drag and drop with the
host system and many more things for now
we're going to close this
prompt
as you can see this is the live boot ISO
of the parrett security operating
system currently it's running the M
desktop as we have downloaded in the
website the live boot ISO is necessary
to get a good feel of the operating
system there are many good Linux dros
that have this live boot option so that
you can give a try of of the operating
system before installing
permanently once you into the live board
we can start up with the installation
using the shortcut as you can see
install
parot going to double click
it and this is a calaris installer
choose your language as American
English and press
next you can select your time zone
according to your location
and we can go
next at this point of time you have to
choose the correct keyboard now what
many people go get confused is choosing
their own language keyboard what people
must keep in mind is what keyboard the
laptop
provides most of the systems that come
pre-build provide the English US
keyboard so whatever keyboard you choose
make make sure to type here and test
that all the buttons including the
superscript and the subscript buttons
are working correctly before moving
forward with this
step once you have settled on the
keyboard that you need to install you
can go
ahead here it will ask you to select
storage device and the only option
you're are going to get is the amount of
hard disk storage you have given in the
virtual machine settings we have already
provided 20gb of storage we're going to
choose that and we're going to erase
this
dis manual partitioning can be useful
when you're going to install parot
security on an operating system or on a
hard disk where it is already including
a Windows OS for now we're going to
select erase disk and press next we're
going to give our full name Let It Be
simply
learn you can give the name of the
computer and this is the username which
we will use to log
in this is your root password that we
going to give over here the root
password of this Cali Linux will act as
the administrative access and it will be
necessary for making changes to the
system or installing an updating
software enter the password and repeat
it over
here you have the option to log in
automatically without asking for the
password but for security purposes it is
recommended to keep this
disabled click on next this is another
summary of the installation that we
going to move forward with have a look
that whatever changes we have made is
according to your requirements and once
everything is checked we can press on
install click on install
now and we're going to let it complete
the
work as you can see the installation of
parro security is now now completed
we're going to make sure that we have
the restart Now button over here
disabled and I'm going to click on
done we're going to shut down this live
boot
ISO going to click on
menu turn off the
device and shut
down
we're not restarting straight away
because if you remember correctly in the
virtual machine instance settings we had
given it an ISO
file please remove the live medium and
press enter to continue we can just
press enter to
continue and it's going to shut down now
to move on we're going to click on edit
virtual machine
settings going to CD DVD and we're going
to use physical drive now we're going to
remove it from the iso image file
because the installation has already
been completed and we don't want to use
the same ISO file again and again by
using physical drive over here it's
going to detect the 20gb hard disk that
we have already provided and
installation is done on it going to
press
okay and we're going to power on this
virtual machine for
testing make sure this you clicky s over
here
this is the grub menu at this we G
different choices for example which
NVIDIA drivers off or with some other
Advanced options more often than not
we're going to choose the first option
and press
enter if you remember clearly we did not
get the option of try install or a
terminal run just like we did in the
live boot ISO since this is running
straight from the 20gb hard drive
storage it's going to start the OS
directly now with the login screen you
can see a username over here as we
provided in the
installation we're going to enter our
root
password and press
enter and this is a currently working
desktop of the par security operating
system we can open the terminal over
here
and we're going to try a root password
and
installation to install any software
we're going to use the keyword sud sudo
AP install and Neo
fetch we're going to use the root
password that we used to log
in going to press y for
yes this is just an additional step that
we doing to check that the installation
is done correctly with the correct
amount of Hardware requirements that we
had
provided now that we have installed
neofetch we can write the command
neofetch and this is going to give us
some information about our
installation you can see the OS name as
par OS 4.11 is running on a VMware host
the kernel versions and some of the
other information like the number of
packages installed the current shell
version resolution of the VMware
instance that we are running the desktop
environment which is made as we had
downloaded once and some other things
you can see the memory is supposed to be
1951 mbes which is supposed to equal
around 2 GB of RAM usage that we had
provided Kali Linux and parrot or are
two popular penetration testing
distributions while these operating
systems each have unique offerings the
overall Choice can differ between
Personnel thanks to the various tools
and Hardware specifications today we
will look at both these distributions
and settle on the perfect choice for
each type of user let's go through the
agenda for this
video we will learn about K Linux and
pirot security Os from scratch while
understanding their primary selling
points as a Linux distribution catered
towards penetration testers next we know
about some features of these operating
systems that stand out of their
package finally we directly compare K
Linux and parro security OS thereby
making a clear-cut conclusion on which
OS is perfect on a per requirement
basis so let's start by learning about K
Linux from a ground
level K Linux which is formerly known as
backtrack Linux is an open- Source Linux
distribution aimed at Advanced
penetration testing and security
auditing it contains several 100 tools
targeted towards various information
security tasks such as penetration
testing security research computer
forensics and reverse
engineering K Linux is a multiplatform
solution accessible and freely available
to Information Security Professionals
and
hobbyists among all the Linux
distributions k takes its roots from the
Debian operating system Debian has been
a highly dependable and a stable
distribution for many years providing a
similarly strong Foundation to the K
Linux
desktop while the operating system can
practically modify every single part of
our installation the networking
components of K Linux come disabled by
default this is done to prevent any
external factors from affecting the
installation procedure which may pose a
risk in critical environments apart from
boosting security it allows a more
profound element of security control to
the most enthusiastic of
users now let's take a look at parad
security operating
system parent security OS is a Debian
based Linux distribution with an
emphasis on security privacy and
development it is built on the Debian
testing branch and uses a custom Harden
Linux
kernel par security contains several
hundred tools targeted towards tasks
such as penetration testing computer
forensics reverse engineering and
security research it is seen as a
generally lightweight distribution that
can work under rigorous hardware and
software
specifications it features a distinct
forensics mode that does not Mount any
of the systems hard diss or partitions
and has no influence on the host system
making it much more stealy than its
regular occurrence this mode is used on
the host system to ex execute forensic
procedures a rolling release is a
paradigm in which software upgrades are
rolled out constantly rather than in
batches of versions and software
development this ensures that the
software is constantly up to date
rolling release distribution such as
parot security OS follows the same
concept it provides the most recent
Linux kernel and software versions as
soon as they become
available with a basic introduction to
the operating systems out of the way
let us take a look at the unique
features of both K Linux and parro
security
OS the latest version of Ki Linux comes
with more than 600 penetration tools
pre-installed after reviewing every tool
included in backtrack developers have
eliminated a significant number of tools
that either simply did not work or
duplicated other tools that provided the
same and similar functionality the K
Linux team comprises a small group of
individuals who are the only ones
trusted to commit packages and interact
with the repositories all of which is
done using multiple secure
protocols restricting access of critical
code bases to external assets
dramatically reduces the risk of source
contamination which can cause SC Linux
users worldwide a great deal of damage
as a direct victim of cyber
crime although penetration tools tend to
be written in English
the developers have ensured that Kali
includes proper multilingual support
allowing more users to operate in the
native language and locate the tools
they need for their job the more
comfortable a user feels with the
intricacies of the operating system the
easier it is to maintain a stronghold
over the configuration and the device in
general since arm-based single board
systems like the Raspberry Pi are
becoming more prevalent and inexpensive
the development team knew that ki's arf
support would need to be as robust as
they could manage with fully working
installations Kali Linux is available on
a wide range of armm devices and has
armm repositories integrated with the
mainline distribution so the tools for
armm are updated in conjunction with the
rest of the
distribution let's take a look at some
of the features of parat security
operating system
now along with the giant catalog of
scripts par security OS has its own
hardened Linux kernel modified
explicitly to provide as much security
and resistance to hackers as possible in
the first line of
defense the configurations in the
operating system Act is the second gate
view taking care of malicious requests
and dropping them off this is
particularly beneficial since should
there be a scenario where the latex
Linux kernel is causing some particular
issue the parat O development team will
most likely iron it out first before
passing it on as an
update if the custom hardal kernel
wasn't reason enough parent security
developers managed to install more
hacking tools and scripts to ensure a
smooth transition for the Kali Linux
users all the tools you find in Kali are
present in parent to us and a few extra
ones for good measure and this has been
achieved while keeping roughly the same
operating system size between both of
them however it's not all productivity
points for pirate OS they provide a
choice between two different desktop
environments mate which comes
pre-installed by default and KDE for
those unfamiliar with Linux terminology
you can think of desktop environments as
the main UI for a distribution being
highly modular in nature one can use
parad security OS while adding another
desktop environment that they find
appealing while K Linux has only a
single option par security has provided
two optimized builds with M desktop and
KD
desktop one of the primary advantages of
parro os over Kali Linux is that it's
relatively lightweight this implies that
it takes significantly less dis space
and computing power to function
correctly with as little as 320 MB of
ram required in reality paratos is
designed to operate successfully off a
USB stick but K Linux does not work well
from a USB Thrive and is generally
installed in a vir ual machine paratos
is more of a niche distribution if
you're searching for something lighter
than K
Linux features are great but what about
Performance Real World metrics let us
compare both these operating systems
directly with respect to their Hardware
specifications and usability in the end
we can decide on what distribution is
fit for each type of
user
for our first point of comparison let's
take a look at the ram required for
Optimum performance of the operating
system which is highly essential when
trying to crack hashes or something of
similar nature rme usage is a very
important facet while khux demands at
least 1 GB of RAM par security can
operate optimally with a minimum of 320
MB of
RAM for correct displaying graphical
elements K Linux requires GPU based
acceleration while this is not the case
with parad security OS which doesn't
require any graphical acceleration
needed from the user
side once these operating systems are
installed on VMware using the live boot
isos they take up a minimum amount of
hard disk storage both of these
operating systems have a recommended dis
storage of minimum of 20 GB in Kali
Linux and a minimum of 15 GB in in parot
security so they can install all the
tools necessary in the ISO
file when it comes to the category and
the selection of tools K Linux has
always been the first in securing every
single tool available for hackers in the
penetration testing industry par
Security on the other hand has managed
to take it up a
notch while specializing in Wireless
pent testing par security makes it a
point that all the tools that K Linux
provides has been included in the iso
while simultaneously adding some extra
tools that many users will have to
install from third party sources in K
Linux being a decade old penetration
testing distribution K Linux has formed
up a very big Community with strong
support signature par Security on the
other hand is still growing and it is
garnering much more interest among
veteran penetration testers and ethical
hackers
a primary drawback of K Linux is the
extensive Hardware requirement to
perform optimally it requires higher
memory than parro security it also needs
graphical acceleration while demanding
more virtual hard disk Storage parro
security on the other hand was initially
designed to run off a USB drive directly
thereby requiring very minimal
requirements from a hardware perspective
like just 320 MB of RAM and no graphical
acceleration needed this means parro
security is much more feasible for
people who are not able to devote
massive resources to either their
virtual machine or on their laptop hard
disk
directly with the comparison done
between both of these operating systems
let's take a look at the type of users
both of these are catered
to one can go with K Linux if they want
the extensive Community Support offered
by its users if they want to go with a
trusted development team that have been
working on this distribution since many
years if they have a powerful system
which can run K Linux optimally without
having to bottleneck performance and if
they are comfortable with a
semi-professional environment which may
or may not be very useful for new
beginners one can decide to go with par
security if they want to go with a very
lightweight and lean distribution that
can run pretty much on all
systems it also has a lot of tools
pre-installed and some of them are not
even present on G Linux
it is much more suitable for
underpowered Drs where users do not have
a lot of Hardware resources to provide
to the operating system and thereby it
is much more feasible for people with
underpowered laptops or no graphical
acceleration compared to K Linux par
secuity desktop environment is also
relatively easier to use for new
beginners for people who are just
getting into ethical hacking par
security does a relatively better job of
introducing them to the operating system
and to the various toools without having
to dump them into the entire intricacies
simply learn offers postgraduate program
in cyber security find the complete
course details from the link in the
description box with the world moving
towards the next generation of computer
hardware the software side of things
still has a lot left to be discovered
with the majority of laptops coming with
Windows pre-installed many users are
devoid of the Linux operating system EXP
experience which is more resource
friendly than the mainstream operating
systems it can be attributed to the
difficulty people used to face when
installing a new operating system like
Linux in the old days however a lot of
these issues are fixed nowadays thanks
to the big names like Debian and ubu who
have been instrumental in making Linux
based operating systems as user friendly
as possible but which one of them is
better for you let's take a look at the
topics to be covered today as we answer
this question for
you
we start by learning about the operating
systems from a Layman's perspective and
uncovering the basic offerings of both
entities next we cover the unique
features of both Ubuntu and Debian and
how they stack up against each other and
other industry
counterparts moving on we take a look at
some pointers before installing each of
these operating systems and the
respective download
links finally We compare the contrasting
features of both Ubuntu and Debian and
infer the kind of users each OS Gaters
to so let's start by learning about
Ubuntu and Debian in
general ubu is an open- Source free
Linux distribution it is an operating
system for cloud computing in accordance
with support with open stack Ubunto is
developed by the canonical community and
it is freely available also kolinka
limited is responsible for the funding
of Ubuntu basically ubu is released
every 6 months free support is available
for 9 months after every release and
long-term support which are the LTS is
released every 2 years the first release
of ubu was in October
2004 you must have heard about uban 2 no
matter what it is the most popular Linux
distribution overall not just limited to
servers but also the most popular choice
for Linux desktops it's easy to use
offers a good experience and comes
pre-installed with essential tools to
get a head start
of course Ubuntu managed to simplify the
Linux experience years back and that is
the reason why it is still so popular
even with several impressive Linux
distributions available right now every
new release is more polished and comes
loaded with new features and
improvements thanks to its huge user
base a number of software vendors have
made the applications compatible with
one2 while the catalog may not be as
extensive as Windows the options are
still well curated more importantly the
the advantage of Linux based operating
systems is the ability to use free and
open- Source alternatives to Major
proprietary software while lacking some
Polish and overall feature set most
alternatives are enough to get the job
done for majority of the users the
never-ending Community Support also
helps in troubleshooting should things
go wrong at any point in
time the default desktop environment in
ubu is gnome or a Unity the unity is a
modern desktop environment with a
powerful Search tool for finding all
your applications and documents with its
base setup as no it integrates well with
common applications such as audio
players video players and social media
there are a few other desktop
environments for open to as well with
unity as its Flagship
environment Debian on the other hand is
a free operating system for your
computer which started in 1996 and is
maintained by global
contributors if the operating system are
set of basic programs and utilities that
make your computer run its core is the
kernel the kernel is the most
fundamental program on the computer
Debian uses the Linux kernel a
completely free piece of software which
is started by Linus trowal and supported
by thousands of programmers worldwide a
large part of the basic tools that fill
out the operating system come from the
gnu project and those tools are free as
well Debian is the mother of reux
distributions beginners always wonder
why this not so good looking drro is so
popular inside the Linux developers
Community especially when there are a
lot of modern distributions that are
easy to use and have beautiful UI later
on they found out the power of Debian
after using a bunch of distributions
from other developers you'll be
surprised to know that almost all other
popular consumer level disos are based
on Debian even ubu it is so stable and
feature Rich that the developers find it
easy to build their Dr based on Debian
rather than building it from
scratch Debian is run and maintained on
its GitHub repository thanks to
contributions from developers worldwide
the major decisions are taken up on the
repository issues tab leading to
CommunityWide feedback and a holistic
approach to open source development of
the Debian operating system thanks to
this variety of personnel the source
code of Debian comprises around 70
different programming and scripting
languages Debian supports all kinds of
graphical environments ranging from full
feature desktop environments to lighter
alternate
and imem minimalist window
managers you want to ships with unity
desktop by default where the package
manager can install the Nome environment
if needed while also including cinnamon
lxd xfc KDE and mate on the other hand
Dean gives you the choice of choosing
which desktop environment you want from
the Geto by providing ISO files for each
desktop environment
individually now that we understand
where both these operating systems stand
let us take a look at some of the best
features offered by each of these
distributions ubu is the closest thing
to a household name among desktop Linux
distributions it is a great distribution
to start with and it's even a great
distribution to keep using after you're
more experienced if you're happy with it
it is user friendly in a lot of ways it
provides a simple desktop has an easy
installer and provides a checkbox during
the installation process that will
automatically install Flash plugins and
various codex that you will need for
multimedia support there's an additional
drivers tool that will detect closed
Source or proprietary drivers that might
be necessary to get all your Hardware
working and easily install them for
you ubu is produced by canonical and
their friends it is run as an open
project to enable others with diverse
ideas to benefit from all the work the
developers do to deliver the world's
best open platform still canonical is
responsible for delivering six monthly
Milestone releases and regular LTS
releases from Enterprise production use
Enterprises can count on canonical to
support secure and manage Ubunto
infrastructure and devices with more
than 500 employees in over 39 countries
the company underpins the critical
infrastructure for thousands of
businesses and millions of Ubuntu users
around the
world Unity desktop was originally
developed by canonical and introduced
earlier for Netbook computer with uban 2
10.10 then it went on to be the default
desktop environment for uban 2
eventually it has been dropped by
canonical and replaced by gome however
it has made a comeback after uban to
18.04 while being completely stable the
HUD and Global menu hold up just fine
with major applications such as libary
office Thunderbird and other web
browsers that means that the unity
desktop works as it is supposed to while
making you more productive with some
desktop environment ments have a steep
learning curve Unity is very intuitive
for new users in spite of deviating from
the traditional start menu format that
the windows users are generally
accustomed
to the calamaras installer is a
framework by design it is very
customizable in order to satisfy a wide
variety of needs and use cases calamaras
aims to be easy usable beautiful
pragmatic and more importantly
distribution agnostic calamaras includes
an ad adved partitioning feature as well
which supports for both manual and
automated partitioning operations it is
the first installer with an automated
replace partition option which makes it
easy to reuse a partition over and over
for distribution
testing coming to Debian it is a
community distribution through and
through it's governed by a board of
elected developers it has its own
internal structure and laws and just
about everyone working on it is a
volunteer making it completely Community
Driven it is maintained and developed by
programmers and developers all around
the world this form of development
ensures continuity if one of the
developers decides to stop working on
the project another developer might come
in and take place and keep the project
going on it is completely free of
centralized control and this is also one
of the reasons for an undecided stable
release cycle Debian Sid is the
permanently unstable development version
of Debian it is where the latest
versions of programs are being
considered for inclusion in the deban
release cycle are uploaded and tested
because it has no official install media
and the few net boot images that are
built often don't work even people who
are willing to risk using a development
version may have trouble installing it
however it Still Remains the best place
to test new features that have not yet
made their way onto the stable
Branch Debian has only free and open-
Source software in its repositories this
is mostly ample for our users except for
users who use Hardware that only has
proprietary drivers these repositories
work well in most cases it is possible
to add other repos as well that have
propriety software if that is the
requirement Debian Standard Version is
very stable as software and libraries in
it go through rigorous testing the
stability makes Debian a perfect server
OS and it's also the same reason why
average user shy away from using Debian
as their primary OS on
desktop this is also one of the reasons
why many Developers was used Dean as a
base for the derivative one of which is
also
Ubuntu now that we are aware of each
distributions unique features let's take
a look at how we can go ahead and
install these operating systems and
where we can get their downloadable
images when it comes to Ubuntu Ubuntu
has dropped the support for 32bit
systems currently it supports only 64bit
devices and armm devices in installation
is easy with the calaris framework
coming into ISO pred default and the
latest ISO can be downloaded from the
link being shown on the screen right now
in the case of dbn the support for
multiple range of devices is still
present that can also include 32bit
systems and other smaller devices which
are not
modern even though it does not use the
calaris installer even downloading the
ISO file can be a bit hectic for new
users considering this is a distribution
aimed developers and intermediate users
finding the right link can be difficult
because of which we have mentioned the
link on the screen below where you can
get the latest ISO depending on which
desktop environment you choose to go
with with the installation out of the
way let's take a direct comparison of
the features between both ubu and
Debian Debian is a community-driven open
source Linux distribution and is
primarily aimed to be robust capable and
most importantly free on the other hand
Ubunto is also and free in open source
like Debian but it's backed up and
developed by a canonical which is a
corporate
company Debian and Ubuntu are both
fundamentally fast regarding performance
as Dean comes bare minimum and is not
bundled or prepacked with additional
software and features it makes it super
fast and lightweight at least when
compared with uban 2
directly both uban 2 and Debian use the
same AP softw Ware packaging management
system but provide a different software
repository Debian is more like promoting
freedom of choosing free software thus
it does not include any proprietary
software by default you can always
install the paid versions but you have
to enable it manually ubun to focuses on
usability including all the software
including free paid open source closed
Source Etc ubun to also introduced a
universal package management system
called Snap it will be used across dros
and thus prevent more drro based
software
fragmentations as the dean drro does not
contain any proprietary blobs there
might be some problems with drivers and
firmware that means Debian lacks some of
the essential proprietary firmware by
default but the users can enable the
repository and install it manually like
other paid software on the other hand
ubu does not care how much whether it's
paid free open source or clone source so
it includes as many drivers and firmware
as possible we want to also to install
and configure the necessary drivers and
firmware automatically during
installation or
afterward if you are a gamer then you
will probably be concerned with the
latest software drivers and Hardware
support while Debian can potentially
provide that it is likely that you might
end up breaking your installation as
mentioned before uban to supports
certain proprietary packages as well
which often consist of graphic drivers
which are essential to gaming Debian
focuses on the open source aspect of the
software
hence it can be a well-known fact that
with Gamers Ubuntu and some other
distributions like popos have been
working much better regarding both
software and Hardware
support regarding the audience they
cater to both entu and Dean have their
pros and cons Ubuntu is a very good
distribution for amateur users with
little to know experience and if they
want to have the latest versions of
packages and applications at all times
on their
systems it is also for users who do not
want a lot of customizability in spite
of unity being very customized desktop
environment it is also perfect for users
with newer Hardware since it comes
updated with all the latest graphical
devices and their respective
drivers Debian on the other hand is
Catered towards a little bit of
experienced users who can fix some minor
bugs on their own or with minimal
Community Support it also is for users
who want to support an open source
approach rather than an operating system
which is devoid of of any contribution
from other end and is primarily backed
by a corporation it also doesn't favor
gaming since it does not guarantee
compatibility with all the newest
graphic cards or even Wi-Fi cards in
some
cases however due to the low memory
overhead Dean is very useful for people
who are looking to run home servers or
even corporate environments where
running servers on Debian will provide
much more use data protection is of
Paramount importance in today's world
the vast amount of data flow between
corporations and consumer needs to be
secured considering that they entrusted
with a lot of belief a company can spend
millions of dollars on the most secure
servers but it takes a single hacker to
ruin all the Goodwill between the
organizations to prevent these malicious
attacks many automated security systems
have been developed but none of them
have been as used as IDs platforms which
are also known as intrusion detection
systems welcome to this introductory
lesson on intrusion detection systems so
let's go through the topics that we are
going to to cover today we start with a
basic definition of ideas from a
Layman's perspective then moving on we
cover the multiple types of intruders
that seek to access confidential
information without any
authorization next we cover the basic
ways to detect intrusion signatures from
the perspective of a network
administrator we then take a look at the
different types of ideas systems that
can be used in corporate environments
today a small explanation of the two
types of protection is Then followed by
an introduction to some of the most most
well-known IDs tools on the market so
let's get started with what is an
IDs an intrusion detection system is an
app or device that monitors inbound and
outward Network traffic continuously
analyzing for activity changes in
patterns and alerts an administrator
when it detects unusual behavior at
administrator then reviews alarms and
take action to remove the threat for
example an IDs might might inspect the
data carried by Network traffic to see
if it contains node malware or other
malicious content if it detects this
type of threat it sends an alert to your
security team so they can investigate
and remediate it once your team receives
the alert they must act quickly to
prevent an attack from taking over the
system to ensure that the IDS doesn't
slow down Network performance the
solutions often use the switched Port
analyzer or a text access port to
analyze a copy of the inline data
traffic so that the do not meddle with
the actual
traffic however they do not block threat
once they enter the network as intrusion
prevention systems do regardless of
whether you set up a physical device or
an IDs program the system can recognize
attack patterns with network packets
monitor user Behavior identify abnormal
network activity or ensure user and
system activity do not go against
security
policies the main goal of an ideas is to
detect the anomalies before the hackers
complete the objective once the system
detects a threat the IT team is informed
and the information is passed on given
the requirement for understanding
context an Enterprise has to be ready to
make any IDs fit its own unique needs
expert advised what this means is that
an IDs cannot be a one size fits all
configuration to operate accurately and
effectively and this requires a Savvy
ideas analyst to tailor the ideas for
the interest and needs of a given site
and knowledgeable train system analyst
are SC the trick with ideas is that you
have to know what the attack is to be
able to identify it the ideas has always
had the patient zero problem you have to
have found someone who got sick and died
before you can identify it it can
usually go for two types of protection
active protection and passive in a
passive system the idas detects a
potential security breach logs the
information and signals and alert in a
reactive system or an active system the
ideas responds to the suspicious
activity by logging off a user or by
reprogramming the firewall to block
Network traffic from the suspected
malicious
source so now that we understand what an
IDs is let us go through the different
types of intruders IDs platforms must be
aware of to understand the type of
intruders let us go through a scenario
we have the servers which are protected
by the ideas Platforms in place so let's
say a hacker tries to breach the system
from outside the organization this can
be done using multiple attacks like DS
attacks injection attacks Etc the
category of individuals that are not
authorized to use the system but still
exploit users privacy and confidential
information using different techniques
are known as
masqueraders a masquerader is an
intruder that is an outsider who does
not have direct access to the system and
aims to attack unethically by stealing
data or
information however there is another
Intruder who is theoretically harder to
detect and approve than a masquerader
these are the people people within the
organization who want to weaken the
security defenses be it for corporate
Espionage or to Aid other
masqueraders the category of individuals
that are authorized to use a system but
misuse the granted access and privilege
these are individuals that take undue
advantage of the permissions and give
access to them and this category of
intruders are known as Misa misers are
people that are insiders and have direct
access to the system which they aim to
attack unethically by stealing data or
information let us now go through some
of the ways the idas platforms can
detect intrusion before it is too late
intrusion detection systems primarily
use two key methods one is signature
based intrusion and the anomaly based
intrusion signature based intrusion
detection is designed to detect possible
threats by comparing the given Network
traffic and log data to existing attack
patterns these patterns are called
sequences and could include bite
sequence which is also known as
malicious instruction sequences
signature based detection enables you to
accurately detect and identify possible
loan attacks anomally based intrusion
detection is the opposite it's designed
to pinpoint unknown attacks such as new
malware and adapt to them on the Fly
using machine learning machine learning
techniques enable an intrusion detection
system to create baselines of
trustworthy activity which is known as a
trust model then compare new behaviors
to verify trust models false alarms can
occur when using an anomaly based idas
since previously unknown yet legitimate
Network traffic could be falsely
identified as malicious activity now if
you combine both of those you have the
hybrid intrusion detection they use
signature based and anomaly based
intrusion detection to increase the
scope of your ideas this enables you to
identify as many threats as possible a
comprehensive intrusion detection system
can understand the evasion technique
cyber criminals used to trick and ideas
to thinking there isn't an attack taking
place these techniques could include
fragmentation low bandwidth attack
patent change evasion and many
more we can now take a look at the type
of protection offered by IDs
platforms there are a couple of phase
that can be set up so let's go through
each
method the first is a network based
ideas the sensors are deployed at
strategic points within the network such
as within the DMZ or at the Network's
perameter the sensor can monitor
individual packets of inbound and
outbound traffic to and from all devices
on the network it analyzes them for
malicious activity and depending on the
network architecture and amount of
traffic involved multiple instances of
network based idas may be necessary the
second category is host based intrusion
detection systems or
HIDs an agent runs on all servers
endpoints and devices in the network
that have access to both the internet
and the internal Network intrusions
identified by analyzing operating
specific activities like the
modification of the file system registry
or Access Control lists and the
monitoring system application logs as
well they augment network based idea
systems by detecting animalist traffic
which originate within the organization
or from the host that is being monitored
for example a host infected with malware
that is attempting to spread it to other
internal host is an issue that a network
based ideas could potentially fail to
detect the third variant is a
cloud-based intrusion detection
system because of the internet facing
nature of the cloud on premises ID
Solutions are not necessarily optimized
for
monitoring for example network based
sensors need to be deployed within the
cloud at an environments Network
perimeter and yet a cloud service
provider may or may not have a way to
facilitate this cloud-based servers use
purpose-built cloud sensors that use
cloud service provider application
programming interface or cloud service
provider apis to get as much visibility
as possible into your Cloud environment
now that we understand the different
types of ideas deployment tactics let us
go through some tools that excel in this
field offering topof thee line
implementations in a corporate and
consumer
environment the first tool being covered
is the solar wind security event
manager the solarin security event
manager is designed to integrate
real-time log data from across your
infrastructure enabling it to act both
as a network based idea system and a
host based idea system the solution can
let you cover all kinds of malicious
attacks and help you protect your
network from harmm it is also designed
to enact both signature based and anamal
based intrusion detection by comparing
sequences of network traffic against a
set of customizable
rules next we have the McAfee life Safe
macafee Life safe is an intrusion
detection system designed to bring a
real-time threat awareness to your
physical and virtual networks it uses
signature based intrusion prevention and
anomaly based intrusion detection along
along with emultion techniques to spot
and identify malicious activity maafe is
also built to correlate threat activity
with application usage which can further
prevent network issues stemming from
cyber
attacks next we have bluma bluma is a
security information and event
management platform built to enact
thread detection and responses across
your cloud and on premises environments
it is designed to continuously monitor
your it infrastructure for suspicious
activity and misconfigurations both of
which could result in data Leakes and
compliance breaches it enables you to
respond to an attack in progress and
stop malicious actors in their tracks
monitoring usage of corporate data and
access to privilege information had been
a daunting task before the Advent of IM
am encompassing numerous apis single
sign on Frameworks and data handling
policies IM has established itself as a
key component of every it department but
how does it enforce these rules and who
are the key benefactors of these
policies what about the advantages of
these Frameworks and the workflow of
these systems we are here today to
answer these questions let's take a look
at some of the topics to be covered
today we start by learning about IM am
that is identity and access management
from a surface level so as to put a
clear idea of what it is next we cover
the general workflow and process of how
IM am Works moving on we cover some of
the tools that find their place in an IM
am framework and are crucial
components finally we go through some of
the advantages of the I am learning what
makes them a lucrative deal for
organizations so let's get started by
learning about I am from a surface level
perspective identity and access
management or IM am is a set of
processes policies and tools for
defining and managing the roles and
access privileges of individual Network
entities to a variety of cloud and on
premise applications the users can
include customers Partners employees
devices like computers smartphones
routers Etc the core objective of IM IM
systems is one digital identity per
individual or item once the digital
identity has been established it must be
maintained modified and monitored
throughout each users or devices access
life cycle access and user are two vital
IM IM Concepts access refers to the
actions permitted to be done by a user
like view create or change a file users
could be employees Partners suppliers
contractors or even customers
furthermore employees can be further
segmented based on their roles IM
systems are designed to perform three
key tasks identify authenticate and
authorize meaning that only the right
person should have access to computers
Hardware software apps any it resources
etc for the entry of new us users or the
changing of the roles of existing users
the list of access privileges must be up
to date all the time IM am functions
usually fall under it departments or
section that handle cyber security and
data
management now that we understand the
importance of I am in today's cyber
security sphere let us understand the
process of this framework we have
multiple components that Aid this
process let's start by going through
each of them
individually principle is an entity that
can perform actions on an awsc Source or
any Cloud management system a user a
role or an application can be a
principal it's always the principal who
raises a concern to access or modify
data on servers serving as the first
point of contact in the IM
workflow authentication is the process
of confirming the identity of the
principal trying to access the product
the principal must provide its
credentials or required keys for
authentication this step can be further
enhanced by multiple authentication fact
factors and Googs among other things
once the identity is confirmed the
principal has the ability to view the
data behind the wall of security take
the necessary
steps when it comes to requests a
principal then sends a request to the
cloud management system specifying the
action and which resource should perform
it in this step the user can ask to
modify delete edit or affect other users
in this particular buket of organization
by changing the data or the information
when it comes to authorization it
carries out the rest of an organization
identity and access management processes
once the user has been authenticated
users are granted authorizations
according to the role at an organization
the practice is referred to as role
based access control or
rbac authorizations determine a roles
resources and level of access in the
network these items may include systems
applications file shares printers and
more for example an accounting
department employee who regularly works
with payroll software must be authorized
to do such if authentication resembles a
passport these are the things your
digital identity can access with it well
authentication is fully straightforward
authorizations and their management are
far more challenging authorizations
consist of complex set of rules and
policies and groups which are permitted
explicitly configured per user
account with the working of IM
Frameworks out of the way let's cover
some of the tools that these systems
work
on SSO is an IM tool that enables a user
to log into one and organization's
properties and automatically be logged
into a design set of other
properties for example when you log into
Google you're automatically logged into
your Gmail and your YouTube accounts
similarly for users single sign on
reduces fiction since they don't have to
keep track of different credentials for
every application for organizations SS
Al helps in collecting valuable insights
about user behavior and preferences
since it tacks them as they move from
one application to another connected by
one single
login next is multiactor authentication
or
MFA implementing multiactor
authentication is crucial to protect the
organization's data from malicious
intrusions and virtually every IM
platform offers some form of
MFA however it's equally crucial to
customize MFA with the appropriate level
of security
for example in business to Consumer
scenarios you need to consider ux and
try not to create unnecessary friction
for users who don't want to be subjected
to heighten scrutiny every time they log
in for Workforce you may want a more
stringent MFA since the consequences of
an unauthorized party gaining access to
your private Network can be so
devastating a modern IM solution will
allow you to implement MFA only when
it's needed this can be accomplished
through setup authentication or adaptive
authentication in which users only only
trigger MFA if they're trying to access
sensitive data or their behavior is
flagged as
risky in the past few years identity has
become the preferred Gateway for hackers
to break into systems Brute Force
attacks credential stuffing attacks and
even highly targeted fishing campaigns
are all attempts by hackers to break in
through a company's front door which is
the login box there multiple ways IM
systems can help detect and mitigate
these malicious attacks IM Solutions
detect attacks by monitoring signals
such as the velocity of traffic
detection of login patterns that differ
from a user's routine use of a breached
password use of devices and IP addresses
with a poor reputation among other
things these are some of the most widely
used tools when it comes to IM
Frameworks but why do we go through
setting up so many tools and
firewalls let's go through some of the
advantages of using IM systems in both
corporate and consumer
environments IM solution helps identify
and mitigate security risks you you can
use IM to identify policy violations or
remove inappropriate access privileges
without having to search through
multiple distributed systems you can
also leverage IM IM to ensure that
security measures are in place to meet
Regulatory and auditing
requirements IM IM provides a common
platform for Access and identity
management information you can apply the
same security policies across all the
operating systems and devices used by
the
organization the IM framework can help
you enforce policies related to user
Authentication
Privileges and validation and attend to
the privilege crep
problems IM simplifies sign up and user
management processes for application
owners end users and system
administrators it makes it simple to
provide and manage access and promotes
user
satisfaction IM Services can also lower
operating costs using Federated identity
Services means you no longer need local
identities for external users this makes
application Administration easier cloud
based IM Services can reduce the need to
buy and maintain on premise
infrastructure so importance of a cyber
security certification first and
foremost when I see a certification I
look at it from three different aspects
the first is the training itself which
allows me to gain the knowledge which
allows me to understand the aspects of
security or whatever the certification
is there for the second aspect is the
exam itself how do I need to prepare
myself for the exam and how do I need to
approach the exam how do I need to
ensure that I pass in my first attempt
and the third aspect is the
certification itself which allows me to
be eligible to apply for a particular
job rule so obtaining a cyber security
certification ensures or shows uh to the
organization that you're applying to
that you do have that pre prerequisite
knowledge and you should be shortlisted
for an interview the knowledge that you
have gained during the training will
help you when you attend that interview
and when you attempt to answer the
questions asked to you so these
certifications are designed for a
specific role uh for example a forensic
investigation certificate will teach you
how to investigate a crime scene
forensically a digital crime scene for a
matter of fact a certified ethical
hacking course will teach you about
penetration testing so it is you who's
going to decide which certification you
require and then attempt get certified
on it of course a fresher with a cyber
security certification will have better
employment opportunities because they
can showcase their knowledge with the
certification that they already have
even professionals who want to enhance
their careers can get into managerial or
Advanced uh certifications to improve on
their knowledge and get promoted in
their job profiles so cyber security
cred uh certifications can be classified
in three different aspects the first one
being the foundational level then the
managerial level and the advanced level
uh in the previous video we just had a
small overview here we are going to
discuss about what the certification
covers how the exams are conducted and
uh the price points for each and every
exam so let's start with the
foundational certifications we start off
with with CCNA which is the basic
certification for networking so the CCNA
routing and switching certification
basically it helps you build your
networking career you will join an
organization as a networking engineer
where you can help the organization
establish their routing uh the pathing
of how data packets will travel across
the network this certification covers
all the basic concepts that you require
to understand networking the basic
requirements for this certification are
that the candidate must have a
bachelor's degree but apart from that no
other prerequisites so it's just that
you need a bachelor's degree and then
you can apply uh you can study for this
you can undergo a training and then you
can attempt the exam uh the
certification provider obviously is
Cisco so the knowledge that is limited
to this training and certification is
for Cisco devices only the exam fees for
this certification is approximately
$325 the exam when it is conducted uh it
has around 50 to 60 odd questions which
need to be answered in 90 minutes the
type of questions that you going to get
is multiple choice questions where you
have a question and four answers and you
have to choose the correct answers among
those drag and drop where you have to
click on an object and drag it to its
appropriate Place probably a
architectural diagram and you have to
let's say pick on a router and place it
into a particular uh position if you
place it correctly you answer the answer
the question correctly otherwise it's
wrong and a simulator where you where
there could be a configuration you need
to configure it in a particular Manner
and then check whether the configuration
is correct or not the pass Mark is
around 800 to 850 out of a possible,
marks so each question will have a
different weightage depending on the
depth of the question depending on the
difficult level of the question or the
difficulty level of the question which
uh would then count towards your marks
and if you score 800 to 850 that's when
you clear the exam the job roles as we
have discussed over here would be more
more on the network administrator side
or a network engineer side depending on
the level of experience that you have
the salaries uh that are expected from
this job roles in the US are around
$55,000 to $90,000 annually the next one
is the comcha certification called
Security Plus comare is also a global
certification Authority for uh infosec
courses so this certification teaches
candidates on how to secure applications
networks and devices it focuses on
Hands-On practical skills in the field
of network security I have trained
people on this certification myself so
uh I know this certification is quite
Hands-On it deals with the concepts to
the core it helps you understand the
concepts and then in the Practical
Hands-On demo uh you need to execute the
Practical yourself so that uh you can
gain that knowledge the recommended
level for a candidate to attempt this
training would be at least around 2
years of experience in the it sector in
addition if you have already been
certified for Network plus certification
from comia which is the Baseline
networking certification this is also a
preferred way to go for this
certification as said comcha is the
certificate provider and the exam fees
for this certification is
$339 the exam is quite simple 90
questions in 90 minutes that's 1 minute
per question it sounds like a lot of
time but believe me the questions can be
a little bit confusing can be a little
bit lengthy so you will require all
those 90 minutes to answer those
questions especially when they're tricky
and they're technical in nature the
questions would be multiple choice and
performance-based the pass Mark for this
exam is around 750 points out of a
possible 900 the job profiles for this
kind of a certification is when you want
to apply for a security analyst position
or a security Engineers position where
you're going to analyze some data to
understand and figure out what problems
are ongoing in the organization uh the
average annual salary of this uh person
would be around
$72,000 then comes the c or the
certified ethical hacker training from
EC Council now this is a very well-known
course and also uh EC council is a
global certifying Authority very well
accepted across a lot of countries uh
this is an offensive certification so
here you're basically trying to become a
penetration tester you're taught how to
hack you're taught how to attack a
particular organization from ethical
hacker perspective so the job profiles
that you'll be looking here are of a
pentester where you go into an
organization you test their security
controls or you test their devices find
out flaw flaws within them and then
provide recommendations of how to plug
those flaws or mitigate those flaws and
improve the security of that
organization it is recommended that you
have 2 years of experience at least in
networking or security for these uh to
attempt this kind of trainings and
certifications again a basic
understanding of networking maybe a
little bit of applications operating
systems would be necessary uh before
attempting this certification the
certification provider is EC Council and
the exam fees for this certification is
$500 so the exam here would be 125
questions which needs to be attempted in
4 hours and and you will only get
multiple choice questions in here now
for CH there are two exams one is the
multiple choice questions and the second
is a practical exam where uh you need to
solve some given problems to you in a
IAB scenario and if you are able to
solve them properly you then get
certified for CH practical the cut off
varies from 65 to 85% depending on the
questions that you have answered and the
weightage associated with each and every
question as said the job roles would be
as a penetration tester or security
engineer and your salaries would start
from around $90,000 annually then comes
the CND or the certified Network
Defender also from EC Council now this
is more on the network defense side so
here again the job rules would be where
you uh where there's a network that you
have and you're going to try to secure
the network and the communications that
are going to travel over the network so
you need to be a network administrator
network security engineer or uh in a
similar profile to understand how
networks work and then you're going to
attempt to secure those networks the
certificate Pro provider again is EC
Council and the certification is placed
a little bit below C so it becomes
Network defense then C where you're
going to become a penetration Tester the
exam fees for this certification is
$350 the exam the exam is of 100
questions to be answered in 4 hours
again it's just a multiple choice
questions so you get a question with
four options you answer the correct one
and you move on to the next question the
pass percentage again varies from 60 to
85% depending on the questions on
answered and the weightage of that
question job roles to be applied Network
defense technician CN analyst or a
security analyst from a network
perspective salaries would range from
$65,000 to $75,000 per anom then comes
the forensic investigator course which
is exactly what it is digital forensic
investigator this will help you
understand how computers work where data
is stored and how you can retrieve that
data to investigate a crime that has uh
taken place so the candidate must have
at least 2 years of experience in the
information security sector they need a
good understanding of how networks work
how computers work how operating systems
work how they store data the location
where that data is stored how databases
work how those databases store those
data and so on so forth this
certification is sought after mainly in
the law enforcement areas but there are
a few corporates that offer forensic
investigation as a service especially
when a corporate gets compromised and
they want to uh conduct their own
investigations the certific ification
provider for this is also AC Council and
the exam fees are $500 this is an
advanced level certification so uh
understanding of applications networks
and operating systems is a must before
you attend this the exam is quite
similar 150 questions in 4 hours again
it's just a multiple choice question
exam the cut off again is from 60% to
85% depending on the questions and the
weightage of each and every question job
rules it security specialist network
security pro the job roles foreign
investigators law enforcement agencies
security Specialists homeland security
jobs and your salaries would be around
$88,000 and above all right now let's
talk about the managerial level
certifications Coit stands for control
objectives for information and related
Technologies it's a certification that
will give a candidate an in-depth
knowledge of the framework which kobit
is all about and the framework helps you
manage and govern Enterprise it
environments now this is Advanced
certification so around 8 of manager
experience is suggested before you
attempt the covid 5 certification to
understand all the aspects and to help
you implement the framework properly the
certification certificate provider is
isaka the exam fees are around
$175 now this is a small exam 50
questions but in 40 minutes so you
really have to be on your toes you have
to know the knowledge there's a very
limited time to think and you have to be
fast in your answers the past percentage
is 50% the job roles associated with
this certification would be to uh when
you apply for a information security
manager or as a security consultant or a
cyber security manager and your roles
and responsibilities would be to govern
the uh it space that the organization
owns so all the servers desktops the
network the data flows the databases
everything and how it needs to be
managed and how it needs to be governed
in a secure manner annual salaries would
be around $100,000 plus then the C ISM
also called as sism it stands for
certified information security manager
and as the name suggests it's a security
manager certification it helps the
candidate in understanding the
relationship between business goals and
information security so now you're going
into the space where you're not only
technically nature but you also have to
understand the business needs the goals
of the business and you have to align
the information security of your
infrastructure along with the business
needs and the business goals so it is
your inputs that are going to to go to
the management to see if the
infrastructure is aligned to the
business goals or if the infrastructure
or the business goals need any
fine-tuning around 5 years of work
experience is recommended in the
information security field for
attempting the cism out of the 5 years
the candidate must have a background as
an information security manager for 3
years so you have some experience as a
manager uh you have implemented those
things yourselves which will give you a
better understanding and then you
attempt the certification again
providing by isaka and the exam fees for
isaka members is
$575 for non-members it is
$760 the exam is where you have to
answer 150 questions in 4 hours uh quite
a bit of time but questions are going to
be uh scenario based questions where
they're going to give you a lot of
scenarios you have to think about it and
you have to give the most probable and
the correct answer for that particular
scenario the pass Mark is 450 out of 800
your job profiles would be either a risk
manager or a risk consultant analyzing
the business requirements to the
infrastructure security that uh that you
have and to identify if there any risks
associated with the infrastructure
highlight those risks and then put in
security controls and manage those
controls in a way where security is
mitigated your average salaries would be
around $88,000 and above then the cesa
or the cisa the certified Information
Systems auditor certification it not
only looks into security but it also
looks into auditing and controls uh in
Information Systems this is a highly
reputed certificate and you gain a
better understanding of governance
regulations and auditing your
information landscape again a minimum of
5 years of work work experience in the
field of Information Systems auditing
control or security is necessary now
here the question would be what's the
difference security is where your
technical in nature you have done let's
say a vulnerability assessment or a
penetration test you have implemented
firewalls you have architected security
controls are all about the security
controls that you're going to implement
like firewalls idss ipss data loss
prevention systems uh maybe even uh UTM
and whatnot so experience in
architecting or implementing those
controls in a effective manner
mitigating your security or your your
vulnerabilities that you have identified
in the organization and auditing would
basically mean about looking at
compliance to ensure that everything is
in place you're compliant with let's say
uh ISO 2701 guidelines or the policies
that you have created yourself and
everything is working in order so it's
more of a checklist where you're going
to just check everything is in place and
you're conforming to standards this
certification is also provided by isaka
and the exam fees for isaka members are
$575 whereas non isaka members will have
to pay $760 for the certification 150
questions again in 4 hours multiple
choice questions scenario based so you
have to really understand the real world
scenarios of where what controls and
what audit mechanisms should be in place
PassMark is 450 out of 800 your job
roles would be mainly becoming an
auditor or a senior auditor a director
for information security information
audit manager or a Information
Technology consultant where you provide
Intelligence on how the company should
Implement their infrastructure average
salaries would be 103,000 and above then
comes the crisc also called as crisk uh
certified in risk and information
systems control certification helps the
candidate design and maintain
Information Systems controls for an
organization this is one of the most
sought after certifications as far as
risk management is concerned in Europe
and in us if you have this kind of
certifications you automatically qualify
for a risk manager or a security risk
manager or a information security
consultant kind of role you should have
a minimum of three years of experience
in the field of is control controls that
means information security controls you
should have knowledge about Fireballs
you should know about how to mitigate
risks how to identify risks in the first
place risk analysis risk management and
after which you're going to implement
security controls to mitigate that risk
or bring it to acceptable levels at this
point in time you will also be
responsible to create policies revolving
those risks and how you want to
calculate those risk and treat those
risks in their lifetime certificate
provider again is isaka $575 for isaka
members $760 for non isaka members for
the exam fees a similar question 150
questions to be answered in 4 hours
multiple choice based on performances so
they may give you a scenario where you
have to perform a risk analysis and
provide a report and a solution based on
your findings again the pass Mark is 450
out of 800 the job profiles Associated
as discussed earlier are the it risk
management professionals where they're
going to identify risks treat those
risks calculate analyze maybe do a
business impact analysis to certain how
the organization is going to be affected
and then you will also be looking at
compliances as far as these job roles
are concerned average annual salary
would be 119,000 and above moving on to
advanced level certification now this is
where we come across the cissp or the
cisp certification certified information
system security professional this is the
gold standard of all certifications if
you have this certificate it's you can B
basically be assured of a job in the IT
world now just to qualify you'll have to
have 5 years of experience in the
information uh security field there are
eight domains that are specified by
cissp and you have to prove that you
have knowledge and you have work
experience of around 5 years in at least
two of those domains if you do not have
those kind of experiences you can still
attempt the exam but you become an
associate of ISC Square which means that
you get six years to accomplish the five
years of uh experience requirement for
this certification before taking up the
cisp certification it is suggested that
the candidate clears all the
intermediate level certifications not
all but some of them in fact I've seen
people do the other way around they
qualify for cissp they give the exam
once your cissp the cisa or cesm cisa or
cism exams are way easier to crack but
you need to have that kind of experience
I have seen people with 15 years of
experience and more fail at this
certification in the first attempt the
certificate provided is ISC Square the
exam fees is
$699 like I said this certification is
where most sought after the gold
standard in fact there is hardly any
other certifications after this that you
might want to do the questions now the
exam has changed if it is the English
version that you're giving it's 150
questions to be answered in 3 hours if
it is the non-english exam that you're
attempting then it is 250 questions in 6
hours it's a marathon and if you're
opting for the 6 hour exam you need to
to plan it really well it sounds really
easy but the questions are quite tough
they're scenario based and the answers
are quite confusing as well you would
get multiple choice questions you would
get drag and drop and you might get
simulators as well uh the pass Mark is
700 out of 1,000 but each question has a
different weightage so uh it depends on
which questions are asked of you and
which questions You' have answered
correctly the job rules associated with
this certification would be anything and
everything in information security at
the managerial level and above so
information security manager risk
manager system uh information system
security officer the ceso role the ciso
Chief Information Security Officer any
role that you might think of as a risk
from a risk compliance strategy could be
achievable after this kind of a
certification the average annual salary
is
$118,000 for this certification
technology has become more intertwined
with our daily lives hence it is no
surprise that the need for skilled cyber
Security Professionals is on the rise
cyber security is a lucrative field and
there is a dir of skilled cyber Security
Experts therefore currently a career in
cyber security is something you should
consider if you're looking for an
interesting job role on that note hey
everyone welcome to yet another exciting
video by simply learn which will take
you through the top 10 highest paying
cyber security jobs for 2022 but before
we begin if you're new here and haven't
subscribed already make sure to hit the
Subscribe button and the bell icon for
interesting videos every day so let's
get
started at number 10 we have the job
role of a cyber security
analyst cyber security analysts are
professionals who keep a constant check
on any threat and monitor the company's
Network for potential vulnerabilities
they react swiftly to restore protection
if compromised they identify and correct
flaws uncovered in the company's
applications programs Security Systems
computer networks and more cyber
security anal even recommend ways to
improve the business's overall security
and communicate the specific measures to
be taken they compile ongoing safety
reports document security issues and
measures taken to resolve
them now let's have a look at the salary
of a cyber security
analyst according to glassor a cyber
security analyst in the United States
earns about $880,000 us per anim and in
India you can earn nearly 6 lakh rupees
annually
next on a list we have the job role of a
network engineer a network engineer is a
person who understands the structure and
network Essentials of the entire
organization at a macro level they
design and maintain any network that
supports the company's life cycle and
growth opportunities Network Engineers
take charge of the configuration and
installation of network devices and
services they also collaborate with the
security team and ensure Network
security through the implementation of
tools and procedures in line with them
they monitor Network performance and
ensure reliability and
availability according to glassor a
network engineer in the US earns over
$85,000 per anom and in India the
average salary is 4 lakhs annually
moving on the next job role on our list
is that of an ethical hacker ethical
hackers are Network Security Consultants
who identify and exploit system
vulnerabilities just like how a hacker
would do they are also known as wh hat
hackers they scan the network and
systems for vulnerabilities before a
black hat hacker would ethical hackers
probe and test the network using various
penetration tools and software
additionally they also design new
penetration tools and document the test
results according to pce scale in the US
a certified ethical hacker earns around
$96,000 on an annual average basis
and in India they make around 5 lakh
rupees per anom moving to our next job
role we have malware analyst a malware
analyst analyzes malicious software that
includes BS worms and Trojans to
understand the nature of their threat a
malware analyst has a dual mentality by
being both Forward Thinking and reverse
thinking moving on to the
responsibilities of a malware analyst
firstly they use tools and expert level
knowledge to help decide what kind of
malware they are assembling and if they
have encountered this particular kind of
malware before you will use Dynamic
malware analysis tools to achieve
insight into software attacks secondly
they also uncover hidden indicators of
compromise that should be blocked and
keep an organization software updated to
protect against the latest malware
threats according to glasto in the US a
malware analyst can earn about
$997,000 and the average salary for a
malware analyst is around five lak rupes
in
India up next we have another very
interesting job role that is information
security analyst an information security
analyst is an expert who plans
implements upgrades and scrutinizes
security protocols to safeguard an
organization's computer networks and
information these professionals play a
vital role in the public private and
nonprofit business sectors because they
Shield a company's sensitive and
fundamental
information they use data encryption
firewalls and other relevant security
tools and applications to cover and
protect transfers of secret digital
information information security
analysts perform risk assessments Audits
and tests to ensure the proper
functioning of data processing
activities and security
measures as per glass door the national
average salary of an information
security analyst is around
$99,000 per anim in the state States and
as per indeed.com in India you can earn
nearly 7 lakh rupees per
anom let's have a look at the next
highest paying cyber security jobs that
is cyber security engineer a cyber
security engineer helps to design and
Implement methodologies to secure the
organization's cyber space they also
help in testing and monitoring systems
frequently to make sure that all of the
systems are up to date and work
perfectly to defend the information
they troubleshoot security and network
problems and ensure that the
organization's data and infrastructure
are protected by enabling the
appropriate security controls cyber
security Engineers also conduct tests
and scans to identify any
vulnerabilities in the network and
system talking about the salary in the
United States a cyber security engineer
earns over
$101,000 per anim as per pay scale the
average salary for a c cyber security
engineer in India is nearly 7 lakh
rupees moving on to the next job role we
have senior security consultant a senior
security consultant protects their
client Network through regular
situational
assessments senior Security Consultants
are required to carry out an assessment
of security networks to sport a systems
vulnerabilities strengths and
weaknesses following which they guide
different it teams in strengthening
their security by helping them pick the
right Solutions like new techniques or
tools they also create preventive
measures against future cyber
attacks according to indeed the average
annual salary of a senior security
consultant in the states is around
$104,000 and in India it is nearly 12
lakh
rupees next we have the role of an
application security engineer
application security Engineers work with
as product managers and developers to
plan and Implement security releases in
order to understand any vulnerabilities
Within products they carry out threat
modeling tests Dynamic tests and
Security reviews following this they
optimize a given products efficacy they
ensure that every step of the software
development life cycle follows best
security practices they also help in
testing the application against security
risks before release according to
glassor in the US an application
security engineer earns around
$110,000 on an annual average basis and
in India they make around 9 lakh rupees
perom moving on to our next job role we
have security architect a security
architect researches and plans the
security elements for their firms they
formulate company procedures and user
guides they designed robust security
structures that are capable of
preventing malware
attacks additionally they also approve
the installation of VPN routers and
firewalls according to glassor a
security architect in the US makes a
handsome sum of
$150,000 a year on an average and in
India they make around 20 lakh rupees
perom and finally at number one on our
list we have the role of a chief
information security officer
ciso cisos are senior level officers in
an organization their duty is to ensure
the safety of the information they
develop Implement and maintain
information security and risk management
programs additionally they also interact
with stakeholders and regularly brief
them with information security
concerns according to glasto the average
annual salary of a chief information
security officer in the states is a
whopping
$195,000 and in India it is9 19 lakh
rupees per
anom so those were the top 10 highest
paying cyber security jobs for
2022 now let's have a look at the
companies hiring cyber Security
Professionals here we have deoy net app
KPMG Bosch HP Samsung CGI and GE to name
a few in this series we are going to
discuss about the interview questions
that will be asked to candidates uh in
the cyber secur field we are going to
look at multiple options over here and
we're going to discuss various fields in
which these questions will be asked in
this video we are going to look at 10
different questions on networking then
we'll have 10 more questions on software
and programming another 10 questions on
operating systems and applications 10
questions on cyber attacks and then the
finally 10 questions on cryptography so
we're going to discuss over 50 odd
questions each in these different fields
with which will help you crack your
interviews as far as cyber security is
concerned let's start off with
networking questions let's start off
with question one what is the OSI model
explain the different layers of the OSI
model OSI largely is a theoretical model
uh utilized to understand networking and
how data packets are created and how
they are being processed by a computer
this is normally used by the tcpip the
transmission control protocol over
Internet Protocol software suite
so OSI is known as the open systems
interconnection model it is a reference
model that describes how applications
are going to interact via the computer
network there are seven different layers
that we need to understand they are as
follows so in this diagram there are
these seven different layers we start up
from the bottom first is the physical
layer the data link layer Network layer
transport layer session layer
presentation and application when uh
such a question is asked in an interview
it is not only that we identify these
seven layers explaining what the OSI
model is in the first place we then try
to identify the seven layers and we give
a brief description about each and every
layer if there are any additional
questions they will come after uh this
basic
question so let's start off with the
physical layer this is the lowest layer
of the OSI model now this is where any
and every physicality of your computer
comes into the picture so it could be an
uh network interface card it could be an
RJ45 or a CAT 5 cable anything that
allows data to be transmitted physically
from your machine to another machine
next comes the data link
layer so on the data link layer as far
as networking is concerned we just need
to understand that data packet is
encoded decoded into bits at this layer
this is also the layer that deals with
Mac addressing so the physical address
of every network interface card which is
the MAC address which is utilized to
Route data data package over the network
this is where the MAC address resides on
the data link layer the next layer is
the network layer here datagrams are
transferred from one to another the
function of this layer are routing and
logical addressing the moment we talk
about routing and logical addressing IP
addresses come into the picture IP
version 4 IP version 6 so Network layer
will deal with IP addressing and the
routing of those packets then comes the
transport layer this is the layer
responsible for end to endend connection
that automatically signifies that this
is where TCP and UDP will be working TCP
stands for transmission control protocol
UDP for user datagram protocol TCP is a
connection oriented protocol whereas UDP
is a connection L protocol these two
Protocols are utilized to establish
connectivity between two machines tcps a
more reliable method of connectivity
because there are a lot of packets that
are sent across to verify that the data
has been sent sent data has been
received and so on so forth whereas UDP
is a connection L protocol where data is
just dumped without verifying whether
the receiver actually receives that data
or not so in a nutshell on the transport
layer TCP and UDP make their appearance
and this is where that functionality
lies then comes the session lay this
controls signals between the computer it
establish maintains and terminates
connections between processes so in the
transport layer we talked about TCP and
UDP UDP being a connection less protocol
where data is just transmitted without
verifying whether the receiver received
that data or not where as TCP we studied
is more of a reliable protocol does
there are different packets signals that
will be sent across to verify that data
has been transmitted it has been
received properly and then the next uh
segment of that data is being sent so
those control signals are established
using the session layer so the three-way
handshake of TCP the acknowledgement
packets and uh those kind of packets
will be taken taken care of on the
session layer of the OSI
model then comes the presentation layer
the presentation layer is responsible to
translate data into the application
layer format so the formatting right MIM
or encoding that is being utilized the
utf8 character set that we utilize for
presentation encryption mechanisms all
of these work on the presentation layer
and finally comes the application layer
where the application itself uses a
particular protocol so that the other uh
machine on the receiving end the
application on that machine will be able
to understand what the communication was
about right so in a
nutshell if if I start from up top the
application layer will deal with any of
the data that the application uh is
generating so maybe an user input you're
logging in you're typing the username
password all that data will be
constructed let's say into an HTTP or
https format that's where application
layer comes into the picture then the
formatting of which into
utf8 uh and the encryption of which
would be done at the presentation layer
then the transport layer and the session
layer would kick in to establish a TCP
session do the three-way handshake
establish that connectivity IP
addressing would be done on the network
layer Mac addressing would be done on
the data link layer and when everything
is ready on the physical layer the
packet will be sent out at the receiving
end the packet will be received on the
physical layer and then all these layers
will be reversed and finally at the
application layer the data would be
presented to the application who would
then execute it and showcase it on the
screen of the
recipient so this is the way you want to
explain this question you want to be
very concise precise about what you're
explaining you don't want to go into two
hypothetical scenarios you don't want to
delete Al with the layers you just want
to give the basic functionality want to
demonstrate that you understand what the
OSI layer is how the computer functions
and you want to move on from there if
the interviewer has any further followup
questions they will ask those specific
questions so that's question one moving
on to the question two question two is
Define unicasting multicasting and
broadcasting now this is a question
which can be very lengthy but again most
of your interview questions are designed
that way it's basically to understand
how much conceptually you are aware
about these Technologies so you have to
be very concise don't go uh rattling
about technology too much but in a
concise manner just try to explain what
these things is so when data is being
transmitted over a network it can be
trans transmitted either in one of these
particular manners it can either be a
unicost multicast or a broadcast so what
is
unicost unicost is where when a message
is sent from a single user to a single
receiver so one to one right so uh one
machine talking to another machine and
nobody else so measure pointto Point
Communications one point to another
point if you have to send information to
multiple receivers then you will have to
send it using
multicast right so this is where your
multicast networking comes into the
picture so in our case let's assume it's
a network where there are there's a
Class C Network approximately 255 odd
machines and Within These there are two
machines that want to talk to each other
if they want to talk between each other
it would be a point to-point
communication where they will utilize
unicast where only these two machines
will have visibility of that
conversation and the other machines will
not even realize that this conversation
is taking place if one machine wants to
talk to multiple machines then the
multicast comes into the picture as the
name suggests in this mode of
communication data is sent from one or
more more sources to multiple
destinations multicast uses the internet
group management protocol also known as
the igmp protocol to identify groups so
under this igmp protocol various groups
are created where machines uh are
subscribed to those particular groups
and whenever a message needs to be sent
through those groups it will be
identified by the igmp protocol and then
that particular message will be sent to
those multiple machines that are members
of those particular
groups and then comes the broadcast the
third method is known as the broadcast
as it says it is going to broadcast to
all so this is one to all that is
communication between a single user and
it is going to be sent to all the
machines in that particular Network
right so the three ways unicost is one
to one multicast is one to many and
broadcast is one to all then question
number three
what is DNS DNS stands for domain name
system it is like the internet's phone
book that is responsible for mapping the
domain name into its corresponding IP
address and let me give you an example
over here whenever we go and open up
let's say a browser a Google Chrome
browser we type in ww.google.com
and then we press enter and magically
Google comes in front of us the website
rather now how does the computer know
who Google is because as far as we are
concerned humans understand Google and
words like that computers don't
computers deal with binary zeros and
ones right and as far as Internet is
concerned they will only deal with IP
addresses and Mac addresses so how does
a computer know how to find google.com
and where is it located so the moment we
type in in the browser window in the
address bar google.com and press enter a
DNS query is generated automatically by
the browser where a packet is sent to to
our DNS servers asking what the IP
address is so in short DNS resolves
domain names to their corresponding IP
addresses there is a DNS server which
will have this index a database of all
the domains associated with their IP
addresses if one particular DNS server
does not have that information that
you're looking for it may query on
another DNS server who may have that
particular response so the first thing
is when you type in domain name it gets
resolved with the DNS it identifies the
IP address corresponding to that
particular domain name and thus allows
the computer to route that packet to the
particular server where that domain name
resides so in this scenario if you look
at the screen on the local PC you have
typed in cyers security.com there's a
DNS resolution that a query that goes to
the DNS server what is the IP of cyers
security.com the DNS server looks it up
in its particular uh database Bas if it
has the corresponding IP address it will
then respond back the IP address is
2521 after which the packet is sent off
to cyers security.com moving on to the
question number four what is a
firewall now this is a very good
question and normally a very basic
answer that I've ever heard is that a
firewall is a hardware and a software
firewall but that's the functionality of
a firewall that is what how you can
install a firewall but there are
different types of firewalls and there
is a specific functionality that a
firewall is created for right so
firewall is either a hardware or
software but its responsibility is for
blocking either incoming or outgoing
traffic from the internet to your
computer they secure a network so
essentially the firewall will allow a
connection to happen or disallow a
connection to happen it won't go beyond
that that's the basic functionality of a
firewall okay so based on the
configurations that you have done based
on the rules that you have created on a
firewall it will then based on those
rules identify whether some traffic is
allowed in that Network or some traffic
is to be blocked from entering that
Network so as the screen shows the
firewall rules will analyze whether the
traffic is good if yes it will allow if
the traffic is bad it will block the
traffic and not allow that connection
from happening in the first place now
there are few common types of firewalls
that also need to be included in the
answer to this question and the first
one is a packet filtering firewall these
are the most common types that you will
come across which analyze packets and
lets them pass through only if they
match an established security rule set
now here people do get confused when we
say that we analyze packets people think
that these firewalls will analyze the
contents of that packet which is not
correct when a definition for a packet
filtering firewall says that these
firewalls analyze packets it means that
they are only analyzing the source and
destination IP addresses port numbers
and the protocols that are mentioned in
those packets these firewalls do not
have the capability of De packet
inspection or DPI as it is known if that
capability comes into the picture you're
basically looking at an intrusion
detection system or intrusion prevention
system in today's world called as a
NextGen firewall okay so a packet
filtering firewall essentially will only
analyze data packets for its source and
destination IP addresses port numbers
and the protocol that is being utilized
it will then map that information to the
rules that are there on the firewall and
based on those rules it will either
allow that connection to happen or
disallow that connection from
happening the second type of is a proxy
firewall these firewalls filter Network
traffic at the application Level So when
you say application Level they work at
the layer seven of the OSI model packet
filtering firewalls since we have
mentioned that they work on IP
addressing and port numbers will work on
the network layer of the OSI model also
on the transport layer because they also
look at protocols proxy firewalls will
work at layer 7even which is the uh
application layer of the OSI model and
we'll deal with application Level
protocols such as htdp https FTP SMTP
and so on so
forth and the third one is a stateful
multi-layer app inspection firewall uh
these filter packets at the network
transport and application layers so they
basically do the job of the first and
the second type of
firewalls the packets are compared to
known uh trusted packets but now the
first question is if there is a stateful
multi-layer inspection firewall why do
we have type one and type two firewalls
like packet filtering and pro proxy
firewalls that is because that is how
the firewalls have evolved we started
off with the packet filtering then we
added functionality to it and so on so
forth so if a question comes what is a
firewall you start off with the option
saying it is a hardware or software this
is the responsibility the functionality
of a firewall is to allow good traffic
and disallow bad traffic based on the
rules that have been configured on the
firewall and then you got basically
three types of firewalls packet
filtering proxy and stateful multilayer
and just include a brief description of
each of these firewalls if getting your
learning started is half the battle what
if you could do that for free visit
scaleup by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know more
then moving on to question number five
what is a VPN VPN is also called a
virtual private Network it is a
connection between a VPN server and a
VPN client so it basically creates a
encrypted tunel between the client and
the VPN server which is then utilized to
secure the connections that you're
making with the internet so as you can
see in the diagram the user has a VPN
client installed on the machine the VPN
client then creates an encrypted tunnel
to the VPN server
and through this tunnel encrypted data
is transmitted which can then be
processed by the VPN server uh sent to
the internet information can received
can be received back by the VPN server
the VPN server will encrypt that data
back and send it back to the user so if
there's a man in the- Middle attack that
is happening or a hacker trying to Eaves
drop on the communication mechanism they
will not be able to do so because of the
encrypted tunnel it is very difficult to
decrypt this or hack through this
encrypted tunnel the it is possible but
it is very difficult to achieve that
moving on to question number six what
are the advantages of distributed
processing now before we go into
advantages of distributed processing we
first have to understand what is
distributed processing so it is a term
which describes various computer systems
that use more than one processor to run
an
application here multiple computers
across different locations share the
same processor the advantages of
Distributing processes are as follows
but before we go into the advantages
distributed computing is basically where
multiple machines will pull their
resources together to run a singular
application so an application that has
multiple resources and can scale up and
scale down as and when required the
advantages are that it can be very uh
very useful in data recovery for example
raid where your striping data on various
hard disks it is reliable it is cheaper
lower cost can be ACH achieved and it is
easy to expand because of the
scalability factor that we just talked
about if there is loss of data in one
computer it can then be recovered by
another interconnected computer and one
of the examples would be blockchain in
today's world right what is blockchain
that this data is uh created live and
stored on a connection of computer so if
one of the computers goes offline the
other computers in that network will
still have that data and the the
blockchain will still function without
any issues the second point a glitch in
in one machine does not affect the
processing as there will be multiple
other machines like we discussed in the
blockchain several cost-effective mini
computers are used instead of costly or
Mainframe machine so instead of having a
server bank I can have multiple machines
connect interconnected together and they
can function in that particular
blockchain or for that particular
distributed processing
mechanism depending on the amount of
data processing more computers can be
attached to the network thus you can
increase the number of computers that
can be a part of that blockchain or you
can reduce them as and when necessary
moving on to question number seven what
is
tcpip tcpip or transmission control
protocol over Internet Protocol is a set
of communication protocols that are used
to interconnect networking devices on
the internet this protocol defines how
data should be transmitted over the
Internet by providing endtoend
Communications so essentially if you
want networking to be established on
your machine you will need TCP IP
without TCP IP there will be no work
groups there will be no domains
basically your interconnectivity will go
for a toss tcpip is a software that once
installed on your machine will then
interact with the hardware which is your
network interface cards and then your
switches wires cables and all those
through protocols that have been already
pre-configured in it so within the tcpip
suite of softwares you will have all the
protocols all the functionality of the
OSI layer and each and every protocol
that works on each and every layer will
be predefined and pre-configured to work
in a particular manner the Internet
Protocol is all about routing each
individual packet to make sure it
reaches its destination so with the TCP
you're talking about the protocols that
will allow you to format the data and
generate it so that you can communicate
it over the network the IP will then
deal with the routing of those packets
so that the packet can be routed to the
correct computer and be received by the
recipient so the tcpip model is the
compressed version of The OSI model the
seven layers uh will get converted into
four layers the network access layer
internet layer transport layer and
application layer going on to question 8
what do you mean by ip config and if
config both of these are commands the
first one on a Windows machine the
second one on a Linux machine so ip
config is known as the Internet Protocol
configuration this is a command that is
used on the command line interface of
Microsoft Windows to view all the
adapters and the configuration of each
and every adapters for their Network
interfaces so as you can see on the
right hand side in the command prompt
screen if uh once you type in the IP
config command on the C prompt and press
enter it will give you a list of all the
adapters that are there so you can see
wireless land adapter local area
connection the media is disconnected it
doesn't exist at the bottom you'll see
the Wi-Fi connection wireless landan
adapter and it can give you the IP
version 6 IP address IP version 4
address the subnet mask and the default
gateway so this is the configuration
that allows the the machine to know on
what network it is on what is the
default gateway for communicating to the
internet what is the subnet mask so how
many computers may exist in that
particular Network and what is the IP
address of that specific computer so
that it can communicate across the
network as well if config is the same
thing on a Linux Mac or Unix operating
system so the command will also give you
the list of interfaces and the
configuration of each and every
interface
it is used to configure control the TCP
IP network interface parameters from the
command line interface it allows you to
see the IP address of these network
interfaces so here you can see uh
the wlp1
19s the IP address being 192 168
43215 subnet mask being
255.255.255.0 with the broadcast being
43255 question 9 what is the difference
between a domain and a work group this
can be a very interesting question and
can be a very lengthy question at the
same time a work group is nothing but a
decentralized network where you have
interconnected multiple machines
together and each machine acts in its
own individual capacity thinks of itself
as a server right so a decentralized
network you every user manages the
resources individually on their PC so
local users on their own PCS managing
the network shares what can be shared
from that particular machine what data
should be shared should not be shared to
whom it can be shared with and so on so
forth it is good if you got a small
network uh a few machines altoe uh and
you want them to interact with minimal
management effort right so each computer
each user will decide what they want to
allow other users to see on that
particular Network and all of them would
be connected over a land a local area
network either a wireless or a wired one
so if you look at your home home Wi-Fi
right now that is one of the best
examples of having a work group The
Domain on the other hand is a
centralized Network model so in a
corporate environment whenever you go
there and you got a domain based
username and password which when entered
onto a particular machine gives you
access to the entire network or whatever
applications and whatever resources have
been allocated to you that is where the
domain comes in so it it also uses a
single sign on mechanism for all the
resources that are that are to be made
available to you whereas in a work group
you're a local user only meant for that
particular computer right so coming back
to the domain it is an administrator
who's going to manage the entire domain
and all of the resources connected to
the domain the resources could be
switches routers servers data stores
applications web servers Mail Exchange
servers and so on so forth so all of
these are administered by an
administrator through the domain it is
the most reliable and the optimum
solution for a large Network where where
multiple users are going to interconnect
and share that data amongst each others
right the computer can be connected to
any network that means you can be on the
internet and through the internet using
a VPN you can connect to your corporate
Network authenticate in and get access
to whatever resources you are allowed to
access whereas in a work group you have
to be a part of that Network to access
that particular network if you change
your location you go and connect to
another Wi-Fi you will lose access to
your previous Wi-Fi then the last
question for the networking uh section
what is data encapsulation in networking
data encapsulation refers to the process
of adding headers and trailers to the
data the data link layer binds each
packet into a frame that contains the
hardware address of the source and the
destination computer so in this example
when we talking about data encapsulation
we have talked about how data that has
been created by the application layer
would have a header and a trailer that
will give the various informations of
where that data needs to be sent so the
the hardware address which is the MAC
address comes into the picture and gets
added to the header and the IP addresses
port numbers and all of those things
would then be added to this uh trailers
as well so that the data can be then
routed to the intended recipient of that
particular
communication with this we end the first
10 questions in networking and in this
video we are going to look at software
and programming so we're going to look
at the first 10 questions first question
being how do you keep a computer secure
now this is going to be a very generic
question so you want to put your best
foot forward and you want to identify
the most common methodologies on how you
can keep a computer secure so when we
talk about computers the first thing
that you want to talk about is
authentication mechanisms where you want
multiactor authentication or two-way
authentication to ensure that your
accounts are kept secured now if you
look at using passwords depending on how
passwords are being stored by the
application uh password attacks can be
possible either a Brute Force attack or
a dictionary base attack uh or even
password guessing attacks are possible
to mitigate those kind of attacks you we
need multiactor
authentication to ensure that accounts
are secure now even if we are using
multiactor authentication we also want
to look at secure passwords which means
that the password is complex enough to
withstand most of the common attacks and
a Brute Force attack or a dictionary
attack is just not possible so we want
to randomize our passwords we want to
create a complexity where a password
meets standards such as uh meet has at
least one lowercase one uppercase
character has numerics and special
characters and his randomize is not
based on a dictionary word doesn't
contain usernames email addresses phone
numbers or anything that is personal to
that particular user third keep regular
updates which means that there will be
patches that will be released for the
application for the software that you're
utilizing download the patches install
them on a regular basis to ensure that
you are secured against the most recent
attacks that have been
identified install a good
antivirus could be a Internet Security
Suite which will have an antivirus
intrusion detection system a firewall uh
and will help you protect yourself
against ransomwares
malwares and any script based attacks
also have a specialized firewall on your
system could be a host based firewall or
a network based firewall to ensure that
uh attacks are kept at a minimum and you
have your network definitions in place
to allow or disallow connections from
happening to your devices have anti-
fishing softwares installed as well to
ensure that you are not getting any spam
mails even if you do you're able to
identify that and not fall prey or
victim to those spam males fishing
attacks are generic where they are
directed towards
individuals uh and they pray on the
gullibility of that particular
individual so our Nigerian frauds or the
lotteries that we in on a regular basis
of hundreds of million dollars uh those
messages the emails that we reive they
are all fishing emails where uh they're
basically prone to victimize the user
and then Rob them of money or uh insult
some malware or do some other malicious
activity if you want to enhance
encryption about data that you have
stored on your devices or on your or
that is accessed by your software or
being transmitted by your software use
encryption encrypt your data whether it
is at rest whether it is in motion or
whether it is at use thus reducing data
leakage and data loss uh possibilities
and finally and the foremost secure your
DNS DNS is the domain name server which
is utilized by
computers to resolve domain names to IP
addresses if a DNS poisoning attack is
possible where your DNS settings have
been modified by an attacker and you
redirected to a malicious DNS server
that server is going to redirect you to
another malicious application which may
have a malware or a malicious software
as a payload also you don't want people
to know your DNS servers and the queries
that you're making so you want to use
secure DNS or uh DNS over HT PPS to
encrypt your DNS queries as
well so in a nutshell if you follow
these eight steps your devices your
computers your applications are going to
be as secure as possible the next
question discuss security related
aspects between cc++ and Java now this
is an open-ended question it depends on
which level you're giving an interview
on but you're looking at it from a
fresher perspective or a less experienc
perspective and thus these are some of
the aspects that we want to look at and
the comparisons between cc++ and Java so
the five aspects that we are looking at
are Pointers code translations storage
allocation
inheritance and overall security uh
based on cc++ and Java so when we say
pointers we are looking at how we going
to uh uh we using pointers and uh stacks
and heaps to point to functions and how
we exit those functions and how those
functions are then recalled into the
next function so C supports pointers it
is most secure C++ also supports Point
pointers but it is a little bit less
secure than C Java it is not supported
direct access is given to memory
allocation and thus it is the least
secure as far as pointers are concerned
when we look at code
translations C is able to compile but it
is not secure same with cc++ but in Java
it is an interpreted language and it is
abstracted and secured in storage
allocation in CV use Mal loock and uh
cck memory allocation uh Which is less
secure because it does not have internal
checks on verifying what memory is
allocated and the user input that is
being compiled or that is being input to
that memory right thus this can allow
buffer overflow errors uh to creep in
because of the uh non-verification of
the input data so it is the secure in
cc++ it uses new and delete options and
it's comparatively secure but Java uses
a garbage collector and does is the most
secure as far as storage allocation is
concerned when we talk about
inheritance the most secure is
cc++ C has no inheritance so it's not
secure in C++ it is supported does it is
the most secure whereas in Java there is
multi- inheritance that is not supported
and does is comparatively secure overall
the most secure out of all these based
on these five aspects is
Java the least secure is C and the mid
level is C++ moving on to question 13
what are the different sources of
malware now malware stands for malicious
software right malware is basically a
software that poses as a legitimate
software but has a payload of errosion
virus pyware key logger or some
malicious software that is going to have
a negative impact on security of your
particular device so the question here
is what are the different sources of
malware we want to identify the most
common sources through which malwares
infect end user devices in today's world
and we can start with popup ads so most
of the websites if you're visiting
untrusted sites if you're being
redirected to sites that you don't know
about there'll be a lot of popups coming
your way where it says you're the 1
millionth visitor to this site please
click here to download your gift or it
will say uh congratulations on winning a
particular product for visiting this
page and so on so forth there are some
instances where you can see a banner
which is flashing at you on top of the
page and says that there are eight uh
infections that have been identified on
your computer click here to download an
antivirus to clean the infections so all
of these
popups are there as a social engineering
attack as a fishing attack to to make
gullible people click on those links and
download those malwares now the software
that is posing as a security software
itself can be a malicious software which
is going to install a Trojan or a wirus
or a bot on your machine compromising
the security of that machine the second
is removable media USBS and humans have
a fascination with USBS so if you find a
USB lying around it's a free USB you get
excited about it and you want to take it
home you want to plug it into into a
machine and see what's on the USB worst
case scenario you format it and you got
a free USB to utilize higher the
capacity the better but that is one of
the most easiest way people use malwares
to uh to be deployed on unsuspecting
users if there is a USB lying around why
would why would somebody want to forget
a USB it's most likely planted over
there as a social engineering attack so
that a gullible person is going to pick
it up plug it into their device if the
device is not secured enough it is going
to install the malware right uh then
documents and executable FES this is
where your viruses and uh all those
Creeps in so let's say you're surfing on
the internet you're looking for a
software uh and you find the software on
a particular website you do not verify
the trust worthiness of that site and
you just download and install that
software now that software could be
malware as well thus if you're surfing
on the internet you're downloading files
from different locations you have to
research the website you have to
research the source to ensure that it is
trustworthy and only then are you going
to download and execute those files does
internet downloads as well and when we
say internet downloads it's not just
untrustworthy sites we go to torrent uh
we go to uh dark the dark web or the
Deep Web and we searching for other
softwares especially uh those who are
researching security right we always
want we always on the lookout of new
softwares and we always on those forums
which which may not be so much
trustworthy and we just download those
files and start installing them that is
a very bad scenario right so you have to
be very careful what you're downloading
from the internet your antiviruses your
uh anti- fishing uh mechanisms your
threat intelligence mechanisms uh have
those uh mechanisms installed and you
want to verify where your downloads are
coming from then your network
connections if it is a P2P connection it
is a local area network connection or a
Metropol an area network you have to
verify whom which devices are connected
to your machines and you have to
validate those connections before you
want to trust those devices uh and
before you connect to them if you on a
public Wi-Fi you probably don't want to
connect to a public Wi-Fi in the first
place then comes email
attachments there are so many
attachments that come across in today's
world most of them in a zip format or a
RAR format uh some of them come as
document files where there are macros
hidden within them macros are scripts
that are recognized by Microsoft Office
files right and then finally there are
these malicious advertisements that we
find online right uh Let It Be Facebook
let it be WhatsApp let it be
uh any social media platform that you go
or even your search engines their job is
to display ads their job is not to
verify whether the ad is legit or not it
is for us as consumers to be careful
careful and validate that ad and verify
whether it is a genuine ad or not so
just don't start clicking on uh any of
the ad trusting uh the platform that
you're are on be uh be sure that you are
investigating that ad so these are the
most common sources of malware and the
end
user will always get infected by one of
these mechanisms moving on to question
14 how does email work now this is a
very uh can be a complex question uh but
we have to keep it as simple as possible
and we have to identify that there are
uh two servers where both of them either
using SMTP where which is the simple
message transfer protocol where uh in
this scenario John wants to send an
email thus they've got an email client
installed on their machine which is
connected to the mail Exchange Server
which has a DNS server which Maps the
routing and uh which maps The Exchange
Server and inboxes so when John composes
that message and clicks on send John
should be connected to a Mail Exchange
Server where the email is sent through
that particular person's inbox so John's
inbox will then uh be validated and that
email will then be sent through the DNS
server uh through the internet and will
be received by the recipient mail server
so at this point in time John also
requires the recipient's email address
so in this case this is Jack so Jack
something.com would be uh the email
address so when John is composing uh the
two field will have Jack's email address
the from field will have John's email
address the subject field will have uh
whatever they want to convey as a
message the message body will have the
message itself and then when uh John
clicks on send it will go to their
Exchange Server The Exchange Server will
then validate the Inbox and Iden
identify where that inbox is located for
Jack and then through the internet it
will be sent to the uh to the mail
server of Jack the mail server will then
identify the proper inbox that it that
that email needs to be sent to and it
will store that email in that particular
inbox when Jack opens their computer and
accesses their inbox this email from
John will be already waiting for them
and they can respond to it the same way
John had sent that email if getting your
learning started is half the battle what
if you could do that for free visit
scaleup by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know
more moving on to question 15 what are
the types of threats a company can face
right and this is where your threat
modeling comes into the picture so
you're looking at softwares you're
looking at operating systems and the
company comes and asks you uh what are
the threats that are most likely that a
company will face so on a broader scale
the threats that a company will always
face would be classified as natural
threats man-made threats technical
threats and a supply system threat so a
natural threat would be an act of God
which is outside the control of human
beings could be storms or any natural
occurrences like volcanos uh
thunderstorms flooding earthquakes fire
and so on so forth so anything that is
natural so it depends on the geographic
location that you're in and what kind of
climate that area faces and you need to
identify the immediate threats and
prepare for them so if it is flooding
that you're looking at uh and you want
to look at an office uh uh and the
possibility of the office getting
flooded is real you probably want to uh
take office at a higher
floor so that the threat of flooding is
minimized for fire we always have a fire
drill where we practice our fire
mechanism so that we can evacuate all
humans as soon as possible and then
worry about the technicalities of it
under any circumstances under any
threats humans will always have the
first priority and then everything else
comes in man-made threats are where man
themselves are a problem so strikes
lockouts hackers theft uh War rioting
all of those are man-made threats uh
which we ourselves cannot be in control
of but we need to plan for them and we
need to have uh a business continuity
plan or a disaster recovery plan for any
of these threats that have been
identified then come the technical
threats technical could be software bugs
operating system bugs application bugs
that uh that come with the applications
that we have or a hardware failure where
a server crashes a hard dis crashes
maybe uh the processor stops working the
motherboard stops working Ram gets
corrupted uh any of the technical
aspects stopping uh stop functioning
does creating a break in the business
can come under technical right so uh
anything to do with
computers let's say a server failing or
a patch that is not installed on a
particular software those would come
under technical threats and then the
supply system the supply system are your
environmental threats which dep depend
on your supply chain fa uh failures what
is a supply chain for office to function
there are a lot of of dependencies that
office goes through right there are a
lot of other vendors that suppose that
support and provide critical
infrastructure non-critical
infrastructure for the office to
function for first and foremost
electricity without electricity nothing
is going to be powered on and you're not
going to be able to function so if there
is an electricity service provider and
if there's an electric outage that's
that comes under Supply system so that's
a supply chain failure where the vendor
that provides electricity to to you has
failed in providing that particular
service and now you need a business
continuity or a disaster recovery plan
so you probably have an inverter or you
already have a power generator plant
that is going to generate your own power
and Supply it to your system right there
could be short circuits because of
fluctuation in the electricity uh maybe
the internet service provider fails and
your internet cashes so you have a
backup line for the internet from a
different vendor right and so on so
forth Maybe your Hardware vendors who
are supplying you servers desktops
laptops and whatnot they fail because
they they are facing a strike or they go
bankrupt and suddenly you can no longer
purchase Hardware from your vendor
because they no longer are in business
so that's a supply chain failure so any
of these Systems Failing would also come
under threats so under a broad category
these are the first four threads that
you need to identify and then you can
elaborate by providing more scenarios
based on the experiences that you have
had towards each and every of these
threats so natural threat where you may
have had experience where there would
have been let's say a
flooding or any natural disaster which
caused a problem for the continuity of
your particular business so identify
each and every example for each of these
threats and provide that as an example
in the
interview what is blackbox and white box
testing so when you are testing a
software or you're testing your
infrastructure there are two different
tests that you can conduct the first one
is a black box the second one is a white
box in a blackbox test there is no
knowledge that is shared with the tester
so let's say you're a ethical hacker and
you have been awarded a contract by an
organization to test their current
application that they have developed now
they're not going to give you any
information they're not going to tell
you what the application is they just
probably give you an IP address and a
port number where the application is
hosted and now you have to fire in your
own queries and try to figure out what
the application is try to gather
information see what uh what information
can be gathered in the first place and
based on that you're going to figure out
your way identify vulnerabilities and
see if any of those vulnerabilities can
lead to an security incident so without
any knowledge zero knowledge of the it
infrastructure or the source code that's
a blackbox attack or a blackbox test a
white box test on the other hand is
where full knowledge of the it
infrastructure or the source code is
shared so the ethical hacker has
complete knowledge and based on the
knowledge they are then going to test
out the system to see if there are any
flaws that they can identify right so
why would these two audits be important
because the first one a blackbox audit
emulates the attack of a Outsider a
external hacker sitting outside the
organization trying to figure their way
in whereas a white box attack can
emulate the attack of an Insider so a
disgruntled employee within that
organization misusing using their access
controls or the access rights to make uh
unvalidated profits right so somebody
who's corrupt who has been bribed who
wants to sell out company Secrets based
uh so they're going to try to find out
Vol abilities try to steal data and try
to sell it on the uh gray market right
so a white box would emulate a internal
attack a black box would emulate an
external attack moving on to question 17
what is use case testing now use case
testing is a functional test and it is
also a blackbox test right what is a
functional test it tests the
functionality of a particular software
once it has been
created why is it a blackbox test
because the user doesn't know what the
functionality is they just want to find
out each and every scenario and try to
see what that scenario generates as a
response they are not sure whether that
is the appropriate response that should
be generated or not they're just trying
to find out the response that is going
going to be generated after they fire
off a query so this technique is used by
testers to get the test scenarios to
exercise the whole system from start to
finish so let's say it's a login
mechanism for an application right now a
user at this point in time the tester
since it's a blackbox testing will know
that it is a login mechanism they will
not know the details of what logging
mechanisms are being utilized so they
wouldn't know whether uh input
validation is done they wouldn't know
whether output encoding is done they
wouldn't know how the CGI calls are
being made they will not know how the uh
queries are handled at the server side
and how the database is going to treat
that particular query so they have no
idea whether the SQL injection attacks
are possible and so on so forth so for
them with whatever input they're going
to try to insert for that login
mechanism that's a functional blackbox
test the functionality mean whether the
login mechanism works and based on the
type of inputs that they're going to put
in whether it creates an unwant Ed
output whether they can bypass the
mechanism or they can hack into the
system because of some of the flaws that
were left behind right another example
here is a software made for users to use
for documentation the testers will test
all the cases that the user can do so
can the user view a document can they
add new documents can they edit
documents and can they delete documents
so this
functionality will depend upon the
access controls that have been granted
to a particular user so for this
particular ular user the tester at this
point in time they would not know
whether they are an administrative user
or they are a regular user they'll just
try to do all of these and then write
the responses saying I was able to view
I was able to add I was able to edit and
I was able to delete now the result will
be then sent to a manager the manager
will look at the results and then based
on the actual access controls that were
supposed to be there for this particular
user then we'll try to identify whether
this is an acceptable case or whether
there were any flaws within these case
moving on to question
18 what is static and dynamic testing
now this is again in application testing
static testing is done in an early stage
of development life cycle now software
development life cycles there are
multiple of those what are these life
cycles there are different stages in
which a application is uh
created and provided to the customer so
your first stage would be determining
the scope of the application determining
the hardware requirements for that
application
then creating a flowchart for that
application a functional chart for that
application and then maybe start coding
then an architect comes in test the code
verifies the code then the testing phase
comes in then the security testing phase
comes in and then the user acceptance
testing comes in but in every stage at
the very earliest of All Stage a static
test will always be started to see
whatever code has been developed
whatever uh scope has been developed
whether that scope is going to be
correct cor or not this will include
walkthroughs and code review what is a
walkth through a walkth through is going
through documents that have been
generated and trying to find faults in
the documented Journey that has been
that has been created so far so let's
say somebody has created a workflow or a
flowchart for a program how the
functions are going to be called and how
they're going to be executed so a walk
through would be where uh all these
responsible people will walk through
that particular flowchart and find out
any flaws within that and then Rectify
them if there is any code that has
already been written this code will be
reviewed manually and any flaws within
that code would then be identified
static testing will always be 100%
accurate in a very short amount of time
because it is immediate uh you have
created it and then the expert is going
to test it to see whether everything is
fine or not right it is all about
prevention mechanism so since you're
doing it at the exemption itself if you
find any flaw it gets immediately
repaired so this is about preventing
vulnerabilities from creeping into that
application at a later point in time
whereas Dynamic on the other side is
done at the end of the development life
cycle so you have generated the
application everything is ready now you
want to do Dynamic testing includes
functional and non-functional testing
functional testing is where the
application itself is being tested the
functions to see that all the parameters
that are given to the application are
functioning properly non-functional
testing would be where security
parameters uh administrative parameters
all of them are being verified right
this is where your test case scenarios
come in and uh you're going to test each
and every scenario by generating inputs
and analyzing the output that the
application is going to give you Dynamic
testing is all about cure so here you're
going to identify vulnerabilities report
them to the management and the
management is then going to figure out a
way of patching those vulnerabilities so
that they can be mitigated moving on to
the next question what are the test
levels in software testing so as far as
software testing is concerned there are
four test levels module testing
integration testing system testing and
the final one is acceptance testing so
in the testing phase of your development
life cycle the first thing is a module
test you're going to check your routines
your sub routines your subprograms
procedures that have been written in a
program so all your functions all your
uh mechanisms for that application are
going to be tested when you go into
integration testing the software have
been integrated with multiple softwares
there may be different API calls coming
in maybe a third party software on which
you're uh depending upon to supply for
information so all of these integration
of various softwares various apis are
tested to ensure that they're
functioning properly and there are no
flaws errors or mistakes left behind in
the integration of all of these
softwares then the system testing is
where the entire system so including the
hardware including the software right
right it starts from the installation so
now the software is complete we know
which Hardware we are going to support
for it we start by installing the
software and see whe the installation is
going to be completed properly if there
are any errors in the installation
process
itself then once it is installed the
performance of that particular
application the uh write speeds the read
speeds on the hard disk uh the
transaction speeds that the application
is capable of the network dependencies
that the application may have all all of
those would come under system testing
and then the acceptance testing which is
basically a quality assurance exercise
that the application meets the client's
requirements so the client in the first
stage would have given the scope of what
needs to be achieved in the acceptance
testing you're verifying that that scope
has been met and the client requirements
have been met and you can assure the
client about the functionality and the
performance of that particular
application coming to the last question
in this uh software programs what are
the valuable steps to resolve issues
while testing so in the previous
scenarios where we have started testing
now if you find out a when you execute a
particular use case and then you find
out a flaw what would be the steps that
you would utilize to address those
particular flaws in those tests the
first step will always be record then
you're going to report it and then
you're going to introduce a Control
process for it so when you say record
you're going to create logs and you're
going to try to resolve all the problems
that have happened now when you say
resolve you're not going to recorde the
application but you're going to test the
system again and again to ensure that
whatever is being recorded is
accurate and all the logs all the error
mechanisms all the dumps all of those
that have been generated due to this
particular log of due to this particular
error are being captured so that they
can be reported to the higher level
managers so the next step is once you
have once you have accumulated all these
logs and Records you're going to report
them to the higher level managers who
are then going to investigate it and go
back to the developers trying to figure
out the best way to mitigate those
particular flaws so the report writing
needs also also needs to be accurate uh
it needs to be to the point uh it needs
to detail what the problem was it will
document all the steps that there were
that you took all the inputs that you
put in and it will also record all the
errors and it will also record all the
mechanisms that were utilized and the uh
errors that were generated and that
report will be given to the higher level
managers who can then forward it to the
developers who based on those reports
can start their troubleshooting and then
the control mechanism comes in you're
going to uh Define the issue management
process so this process needs to work in
a particular manner where you're doing a
test you're recording whatever is
happening you're creating a report out
of it you're sending it to the
management the management will then take
those reports study them take it to the
developers the developers will test
based on their criterias they might
interact with the testers at that point
in time to identify particular flaws and
then they might want to recorde that
application or develop a patch which
once installed will mitigate that
particular flaw and then it can come
back to the testing phase again where
you can repeat those tests and validate
that the flaw is no longer existent
so these are the three steps that would
be uh utilized for testing
purposes and that brings us to the first
10 questions on the software platform in
the next video we'll be looking at
operating systems and applications the
first question is on virtual memory what
exactly is virtual memory for a computer
we have two types of memory we first is
the primary memory which is your random
access memory which is also known as a
volatile memory and the secondary memory
is your hard disk where you're taking
data is stored permanently but for a
computer when it has let's say a 4GB
memory or a ram as in this scenario on
your screen it is going to replicate
that and is going to create another 4GB
of virtual memory on the hard disk and
it is going to use it in tandem along
with the
ram so if the ram is insufficient the
processor is going to utilize the 4GB of
the virtual memory that is created on
the hard disk and it is going to swap
data from the ram to the hard disk
this can also be known as a page file or
a swap file the next question is what
are different scheduling algorithms now
the context for this question is you're
talking about a Prof a processor and
you're talking about how processes are
going to be fed to the processor and how
the processor is going to treat these
processes so the first is first come
first serve so the process which
requests the CPU first gets the CPU
allocation first now whenever there are
processes that are being run by
different applications they make
requests for some CPU time now in first
come first serve the first service or
the first process that is going to
request some processing time will get
that much allocated to them they will
run through the process first and then
the next and the next and so on so
forth the second one is the shortest job
first this is the process where the
shortest execution time for that process
is calculated and that process is
selected first for the
CPU then there is priority scheduling
the schedulers selects the tasks to work
as per priority so there would be some
tasks that are marked with high priority
some would be normal and some would be
low So based on this high normal or low
priority uh all the processes will be
classified high priority will be Dent
with uh first then the normal and then
the least
priority the fourth option is multiple
level cues where processes are assigned
to a queue based on the specific
property like process priority the size
of memory Etc so it will be classified
based on the attributes given to that
particular process and uh multiple cues
will be created and then based on the
attributes the processes will be uh
processed by the
CPU then shortest remaining time the
process will be allocated to the task
Which is closest to its completion so
you look at it this way the process that
will take the least time to complete its
processing would be chosen
first and then the round robin method
where each process comes in turn gets an
equal share of time so if there are 10
processes each process will be allocated
a certain amount of time after which the
next process will be processed and so on
so forth and it will continue in a round
robin fashion till all the processes get
executed so in short six different
scheduling algorithms depending on how
you uh how the operating system deals
with
it the next question is what are the
steps involved in hacking a server or a
network so this is more of ethical
hacking question you're looking at
devices and for uh and the interviewer
asks you uh what kind of steps are
involved what are the activities that
you would do in hacking a server or a
network now there are no specific steps
that you would Define because every hack
is going to be unique but it has a hack
can be classified in five different
steps which are quite generic right so
the first step will always always be the
recognizance step also known as
information gathering phase also known
as footprinting or fingerprinting uh
depending on what exactly you're doing
but in this phase the attacker gathers
all the evidence all the information
that is possible about the targets that
they want to attack so here you're
trying to get to know the victim so you
can launch specific attacks towards them
you want to identify what operating
system they're utilizing what IP
addresses Mac addresses the versions of
the operating systems and applications
the patch levels find out
vulnerabilities find out whatever
information is possible find out the
information about the uh person who's
using those computers so you can launch
social engineering attacks and so on so
forth so the first step is all about
gathering enough information based on
which you can launch further attacks
once you have that information comes the
second phase which is known as the
scanning phase this is more of a
technical phase so you have in the first
step you have got your IP addresses
domain names maybe even Network maps and
you have identified which devices are
available now in the scanning phase
you're going to identify live
devices and then you're going to scan
them for open ports processes protocols
Services you're going to identify
vulnerabilities you're going to
enumerate them to identify more
information from them thus at this point
in time you will have identified a
certain set of vulnerabilities or a
certain set of security Loop holes that
you can
misuse once you have identified
those you're going to the next step
which is the gaining access St in this
you're actually going to execute your
attacks based on the V abilities that
you have found and you're either going
to gain access to that particular system
by installing aosion or destroy the
system by installing a virus or install
a spyware or a key logger whatever you
wanted to achieve so in the gaining
access phase you would have based on the
knowledge that you have gained in the
first and the second phase you're going
to launch your attacks and you're going
to try to gain access to that particular
device then the next step is where
you're going to maintain that access now
that you have hacked into that device it
is not necessary that you will always be
able to get access to that device uh
suppose you have cracked the password of
that particular user and the user
changes that password after a few days
your attack is worthless so what you're
going to do here is you're going to
maintain your access so this is where it
is assumed that you want repeated access
to that device and thus you're going to
install a key logger or a Trojan or some
mechanism which will still allow you to
get access to that device without the
knowledge or the authorization of that
particular user and finally the last
step is where you're going to cover Your
Tracks so whatever activity that you
have done so far will have created logs
and will have created information based
on which the victim will come to know
that they have been compromised and may
be able to trace that activity back to
you so to prevent the user or the victim
from realizing that they have been
hacked and to prevent them to discover
who has hacked them you want to cover
your tracks by deleting logs and any
references that point to that particular
activity you're going to hide the files
that you have created so you have
installed a droan or a key logger these
will create files and directories you're
going to hide them so that they are not
discovered you're going to hide
processes that have been created you
going to try to hide all the activity
that you have done so that to conceal
the actual attack and preventing the
user from realizing that they have been
compromised so these are the five steps
that will be involved in hacking a
server Network application or any
Computing device you'll come across the
next question refers to what are the
various sniffing tools now this is a
network based attack where you're trying
to capture data package that that are
being transmitted over the network and
then you're going to add analyze them to
see if you can capture any sensitive
information like usernames passwords
Bank details or anything of that sort
now these tools would also depend on
which operating system you're utilizing
for example MSN sniffer would work on
Microsoft uh operating systems eer cab
would be based on Linux and so on so
forth so on the screen you'll see six
different sniffing tools that work on
different operating systems wire shark
is uh something that is common both on
Windows and line
uh it is used to analyze Network in
details it is the defao tool that you
will come across in most of your ethical
hacking trainings in most of your
organizations when they want to do uh
data
captures now data capturing or packet
capturing is not only done by hackers to
gather more information but is also a
known troubleshooting technique used by
administrators and network
administrators to analyze any issues
that may be going on in the network
right so the first tool you see on the
screen is wi shark like we stated is
available for Windows Linux as well then
there is TCP dump which uh again has the
same capability of wi shockk but is a
command line version whereas wi shockk
also has a GUI a graphical user
interface TCP dump is available on Linux
MSN sniffer it's a very old tool uh when
we had MSN Messengers uh MSN Messenger
is no longer there but my Microsoft does
or did have a Microsoft message analyzer
Tool uh which they have stopped
development since 2015 uh but that's
another tool that is specific for
Microsoft operating systems from
Microsoft that can be installed to
gather more information then you got eer
cap which is a tool to launch man inth
the middle attacks data capturing and is
is essentially a Linux command line
based tool then D sniff is another
password and network capturing tool
which can help you capture data packets
prominently a Linux uh tool same with
eer this is a graphical tool which will
allow you to uh capture data data
traffics and map protocols and identify
which IP addresses have been
communicating with what essentially all
of the tools have similar functionality
except that uh some have additional
functionality like launching man in the
middle attacks or uh capturing or having
specific filters that will help you
identify and troubleshoot subet network
issues that you may be facing moving on
to the next question what is an
operating system now this is a very
difficult question to answer because uh
we normally when we want to answer this
question we start off with the
functionality of an operating system
right uh we try to describe what Windows
does or what Linux does or what Mac OS
does and then we trying to figure out
what an operating system is in the first
place but an operating system
essentially as the slide says is a
software program that provides a
platform for computer Hardware to
communicate and operate with the
computer software so it is basically an
enabler for human interaction with the
hardware that you have if you take the
operating system out of the question
it's just some Hardware which cannot
interact with you but essentially when
you have operating system like Microsoft
Windows or Linux or Mac you're ENT
essentially installing an instruction
set on that particular device which will
allow you to
interact and manipulate the hardware to
do whatever you want that Hardware to do
right essentially uh when we talk about
uh drivers for your various devices like
a driver for your Lan card or for your
sound card or for your graphics card
which allows you to tweak these cards uh
for functionality right it allows us
input and output
functions uh for example the basic
example you open up Microsoft Office
Products like Microsoft world or Excel
and you get a GUI on the screen uh which
you can interact with you got a keyboard
and you type on that keyboard and the
computer knows what you're typing and
reflects those actions on the screen by
showcasing it on that particular uh
Excel file or a word file so how does
the computer know what to do or what
you're exactly intending to do at this
point in time it is all the operating
system that is providing you all these
Services analyzing what your inputs are
and then based uh on the programming it
is going to execute that and show it to
you on the screen right some of the most
common commonly used operating system
are Microsoft Windows you have them in
desktop as well as server variants Unix
Linux again Linux has desktop and uh
servers You Got U 2 in Linux red hat and
so on so forth and then you got Mac OS
uh for uh Apple related components the
next question what is the difference
between micro kernel and macro kernel
now the first thing we need to know is
what is a kernel kernel
is
the heart of the operating system that
allows that input and output to happen
it allows those drivers to be set up so
that the hardware can interact with the
software and we can then instruct the uh
software and the hardware both to
function in a particular manner so there
are two types of kernels micro kernels
and a macro kernel micro kernel is
something that we normally use micro
kernels are for uh operating systems
that use processes directly handled by
the processor the micr kernel is very
small in size uh micr kernel is large
because it basically is the entire image
of the operating system the execution
for a micr kernel is slow the micr
kernel is going to be faster because it
is more evolved there's a lot of
programming involved extendability
micro kernels are easy to extend micro
macr kernels are hard to extend as far
as security is concern if a macroc
kernel crashes it takes everything down
with it the entire operating system is
going to crash but in case of a micr
kernel it is only that particular
process that is going to get affected
micr kernel there is a lot of coding
involved micr kernel less coding is
involved examples of micr kernels would
be Symbian OSS most popularly used on
Yer your phones noas if you remember
those uh QX and so on so forth micr
kernels your Linux or BSD operating
systems essentially use macro kernels
next question what are the different
types of operating systems so as you can
see on on the screen five types of
operating systems batched OS distributed
operating systems time sharing
multi-program and real time what are
batched operating systems the computer
operator places the jobs coming from
input devices into batches so consider
this not from a desktop perspective but
from a server perspective where these
devices are used by organizations to
compute and to crunch some processes
that is going to make some business
sense out of it so when there are
multiple processes coming in multiple
jobs that are going to be scheduled a
batched OS is going to place these jobs
in batches and they're going to Crunch
those based on the uh inputs that have
been given by these operators
distributed OSS where there are multiple
computers which are interconnected and
are communicating through networks so in
a corporate environment you don't use
one single computer to do everything you
got a Data Center and the data center
will have a cluster of servers where
they're going to share some resources to
Crunch one particular task right so
that's where your distributed OS come
into the picture then you have time
sharing OSS where you're renting some
time so time sharing oss minimizes the
response time example in today's world
Cloud right uh you go onto the cloud you
have a virtual service over there uh you
schedule something you schedule a job
over there it is uh it is executed and
for that time being that operating
system Services your particular requ
request and provides you that particular
job any application that you see online
that is executed for example Facebook uh
from a consumer's perspective uh could
be a time shared
experience then multiprogrammed OS the
operating system uses CPU scheduling to
separate jobs so you're scheduling the
CPU to complete certain jobs in this
particular Manner and in realtime OS the
operating system gives Max maimum time
to critical operations so it identifies
uh the priority of these operations it
knows the high priority items the medium
low priority items and based on that it
is going to execute these critical
operations and get the job done moving
on to the next question what is the
difference between logical address space
and physical address space now when
you're looking at address spaces this is
where applications come into the picture
and when you execute an application it
is going to create a particular address
in the m
where it is going to create a buffer to
store its own information so that it can
be provided to the processor processed
and then can be returned back to the
application as an output right so as far
as definitions are concerned a logical
address is generated during running of
an application or a program a physical
address is a physical address or a
physical location on the memory module
itself right visibility you can view a
logical address because it is programmed
into a computer so if I'm looking at uh
C C++ and I'm using maloc or memory
allocation uh that's where the logical
address is going to be created where a
buffer is going to be created for that
program and whatever the user input is
going to be it's going to be stored in
that buffer but whereas physical address
is concerned this logical address will
be created on a physical store uh or a
physical memory module which will have
its own addressing mechanism thus you
you can can see the memory module but
you cannot see the specific address on
that particular memory module but as far
as a uh a logical address is concerned
while you're programming or you're
debugging the application it will show
you the logical address that has been
created the start point and the end
point of The Logical address that has
been created for that particular program
it it can be shown in a debugging
environment right address space logical
and physical address is physical like
this case it's the memory mode mod
itself you can access only the physical
address on that particular memory
because logical addresses can be viewed
but you cannot access them physically uh
generation uh The Logical addresses are
generated by the CPU uh during the
processing time whereas physical
addresses are generated or computed by
the memory management unit or the mmu
that you have on your
computers and as far as logical
addresses they will always they are
variable whereas the physical address is
always going to be constant looking at
the next question question what is the
difference between logical address space
and physical address space so moving on
from the previous question to this The
Logical address is a address created by
the CPU for the processes that need to
be addressed and that need be stored as
a buffer in the uh physical memory
whereas the physical memory itself is
going to be a address that is going to
be there on the physical part of that
memory which is uh which is going to be
assigned to it by the mmu then the next
question discusses uh shells so what
shells are used in Linux now what is a
shell shell is the command line
interface that we utilize on a Linux
machine so the terminal window as we
call it is a shell and there are
different variations of a shell based on
what lineu operating systems you're
using the desktop operating systems that
you use uh or the server operating
systems in real in today's world that
you're going to use normally will'll
always have a bash shell which is the
first shell that you see on the screen
known as a b own again shell it is a
default for Linux distribution so as far
as end consumers regular consumers are
concerned it is always going to be a
bash shell a bone shell that you're
going to utilize for scripting and to
execute regular commands but when it
comes to high level programming or it
comes to specialization tasks then you
got the rest of these uh shells that you
can utilize for example the ksh known as
a con shell is used for high level
programming which supports associ is and
buil-in operations the CSH or the C
shell uh has different functionality
like spelling Collections and job
controls the zsh or the Z shell provides
unique features like file generation
startup files and fish friendly
interactive shell which provides
features like Auto suggestions and
configuration so all of these have
different functionalities depending on
what uh usage that you have for that
particular shell the most common shell
like I stated is the bash shell that
you'll always come across in your
desktop Linux operating systems then
looking at the next question what are
the process States in Linux now what is
a process process is basically a service
that is running for a particular
application for that application to
function right uh this process is going
to direct user input to the processor
process it get that output back to the
application execute it and then show it
onto the graphical user interface for
the user so in Linux there are five
states for a process first is the ready
phase now in ready in this state the
process is created and it is ready to
run so it is waiting uh it is waiting
for input it's ready uh the application
is executed the running is when the
process is being executed itself blocked
or wait is when user input is being
looked upon so it's waiting for user
input so that it can do the processing
completed or terminated it has completed
its execution or was terminated by the
operating system for some reason or the
other so this is where things have uh
the processing has been completed and
then last state state is zombie where
the process is terminated but the
process table still holds the
information or maybe it is waiting for
the kill request before it gets
terminated so these are the five states
for a Linux process to be in and that
brings us to the 10 questions in the
operating system and application space
in the next video we'll be looking at 10
more questions on cyber attacks
interview questions based on cyber
attacks let's start off with the first
one the first question is what is SQL
injection SQL stands for structured
query language which is a language that
is used by most of your databases or
your relational databases uh the the
variations of your database would be
MySQL Microsoft SQL Oracle
SQL you'll have IBM databases all of
these databases you utilize the
structured query languages to interact
with the applications now all of these
databases have their own syntax so
you'll have to study most of these
databases based on which applications
and which databases you want to provide
security for but as the name suggests
SQL injection avability or a structured
query language injection vulnerability
is where a user can maliciously inject a
SQL input or a SQL statement in a query
and send it to the database and evoke a
response response out of it so this
varability is not specifically to the
database it uh the vulnerability lies
more in the application and the coding
of that application so when the
application receives a query which it
needs to be forwarded to the SQL uh
database we need to configure at the
application Level of what queries are
allowed and what queries are not allowed
so there are different various aspects
of how to manage a SQL injection
varability but the Bas basic flaw lies
in the application where uh invalidated
input is accepted and sent forward to
the database where the database might
confuse it into an executable statement
and thus create a response that was not
warranted there are various types of SQL
injections as shown on the screen inband
SQL injection where you can look at an
error based or a union based injection a
blind SQL injection where it is either
Boolean based or a Time based attack
back and then an outof bound SQL
injection essentially you're looking at
databases and you're looking at
application security where you want to
encourage secure coding practices so in
unvalidated input is
mitigated then the next question is what
is spoofing now in spoofing you're
basically assuming the identity of
another person so here the attacker
pretends to be some other person or an
organization and sends you an email that
appears to be a legitimate email it
looks on most genuine it has been
constructed to replicate what a genuine
email would have been and it is very
difficult to spot a fake one there are
different ways to identify whether an
email is genuine or not but that's for a
different video moving on to the next
question what is a distributed denial of
service attack or a Dos attack now
generally a denial of service attack is
an attack where legitimate users are
prevented access to the resources that
they legitimately can access right so
for example if it is a bandid based
attack the attacker consumes the
bandwidth of the network in such a way
that there is no more bandwidth left for
legitimate users to access the network
now a single device may not be able to
generate that much amount of uh traffic
to consume the bandwidth of a youth
server thus the attacker will construct
a botnet and through that botnet they
will launch a distributed denal of
service attack to the Target victim
right so a botnet uh there are two terms
that we want to look at over here the
first term is a bot and the second one
being the botn net itself bot is a
software that once installed on a
victim's machine allows the hacker to uh
send remote commands to that machine
that will make it do generate some
activity once we have enough machines uh
on which s Bots have been implemented
the collection of these machines would
be known as a botn net so an attacker
would then instruct this entire botnet
to start generating data traffic to be T
to be sent to the targeted Network or to
the targeted server which will then bog
down the server thus crashing it and
preventing users from accessing that
particular resource the next question is
how to avoid ARP poisoning or ARP now
first let's understand what ARP is ARP
stands for address resolution protocol
which is a protocol used by computers to
communicate over the network once your
computer boots up it starts a discovery
process of identifying its neighbors so
if I'm in a particular subnet my machine
will proactively send out ARP request
and address resolution protocol to find
out which other machines are within the
same network and which are live once it
sends out a query a live machine will
respond to that query along
with its Mac
address this information is then stored
in what is known as a ARP table or an
ARP table on the machine's cache so
whenever my machine now wants to send
out a packet to this particular machine
it will go to the ARP table it will
identify the IP address and the
associated Mac address it will print
that onto the data packet as a
destination uh IP and destination Mac
and send that packet across to the
switch the switch will then identify the
MAC address and send the packet to the
relevant machine that is connected to
that particular switch now to confuse
the switch into sending it to a
different machine R poisoning attack is
created this attack is generally
launched to create a man in the- Middle
attack now to prevent this AR poisoning
from happening in the first place there
are three different aspects that we can
utilize first we can use packet
filtering
which will fil filter out and block
packets that have the same Source
address data so you have identified some
malicious IP addresses and you want to
block out some IP addresses so you're
using a packet filter firewall where you
have instructed the firewall to filter
out certain
packets originating from particular
range of IP addresses this firewall and
this technique will then block those
kind of packets coming in second keeping
away from trust relationships
organizations will develop protocols
that do not depend on trust
relationships and thus you want to keep
this protocol away from that once you
have created a trust
relationship uh these machines should
not be sending out ARP requests to other
machines in the first place since uh the
trust relation has been has been defined
and these machines know whom to
communicate with such kind of protocols
should then be disabled or you can use
an ARP spoofing software so there are
some there are softwares out there that
will look for ARP spoofing and prevent
that from happening in the first place
so if somebody has sent out a spoofed
ARP packet that packet will be picked up
by this software and it will be
mitigated of network visualizers like
glass wire antiviruses like soof force
uh they have inbuilt capabilities of
identifying uh op spoofing attacks and
mitigate them in the first place in the
next question we going to discuss what
is
ransomware now ransomware is a type of
malware that blocks w itims to access
personal files and demands Ransom to
regain access there are three categories
before we go into the categories let's
just revisit what ransomware is let's
start with the word malware malware is a
malicious software that poses as a
legitimate software but has a payload
that will have a security impact on your
machine so in this instance uh viruses
Trojans all of these can be classified
under malz so can Ransom w a troan is a
software that will will give you a backd
door access to a to a particular device
a virus will do some destructive
activity on that device a ransomware
will basically encrypt the data of that
particular user from on that particular
machine thus rendering that that data
inaccessible to the users themselves and
in turn we'll demand a ransom to provide
access to that particular data so the
three types of ransomwares the first one
is scareware which uses social social
engineering to cause anxiety or the
perception of a threat to manipulate
users into buying unwanted software so
this prays on the gullibility of humans
where you can see a popup appearing on
your screen which can scare you into
believing that you may have been
attacked or there is a virus on your
machine and then instructs you to
download a particular software to
mitigate that particular virus now the
malware will be in this software that
you will be downloading and then a
ransomware will be installed and your
data will be encrypted screen lockers uh
where locking users computers by
preventing them from logging in and
displaying an official looking message
you will see a screen saver once you
boot up which prevents you from
accessing the login page so it will not
allow you to log into to your own
machine but it will give you a warning
that your data has been encrypted and
you need to connect to a particular
email address and send bit send Bitcoins
over there uh to get a decryption key to
access your own data and then then
encrypting ransomware displays a message
demanding payment in return for the
private asymmetric key which is needed
to decrypt the symmetric keys for
encrypted file so once your files have
been encrypted you might just have a
blank screen in front of you where
you'll receive a warning message uh
where it instructs you to pay up a
ransom in Bitcoins or in some
cryptocurrency to some particular
digital ewallet which is not traceable
and once you make that payment they will
send you the decryption key and then you
can access your data
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit scaleup by simply learn click
on the link in the description to know
more then talking about the next
question what is the difference between
an active and a passive Cyber attack now
when we talk about cyber attacks Cyber
attack is a activity that is caused by a
malicious user who wants to try to get
access or do some security incidents on
the victim's devices so there are two
ways that can happen it's either in an
active manner or a passive manner in an
active manner the Intruder attempts to
disrupt a Network's normaly modifies
data and tries to alter the systems
resources so this is more active where
the attacker will proactively uh try to
destroy the network so that
Communications fail or they might try to
modify the data where using a ransom
where they can encrypted or they might
delete that data using a virus or steal
that data using a Trojan or they might
even alter the data so that it is no
longer trustworthy whereas in a passive
attack the Intruder intercepts data
traveling through a network here the
Intruder EES drop but does not modify
the message so they're just listening in
they're just observing what is going on
they're not manipulating the data
they're not stealing anything it's just
that they are monitoring the activity
that's going on then the next question
what is a social engineering attack now
social engineering attack is a
people-based attack the victim here is
the h by itself the viability also lies
in the human it may be executed through
a computer but end of the day the gabil
is of the human so it is the art of
manipulating people so that they end up
giving up confidential information now
we always reading the papers where
somebody got manipulated their passwords
got hacked and somebody's life savings
got wiped out right because they shared
the OTP with someone or they shared a
the password with someone now creating a
scenario where these people will will
fall pre to this attack and share this
kind of personal information to unknown
people that is where the social
engineering attack comes in creating
that scenario which will ensure that
these people give out this confidential
information now there are three
categories in this attack one the first
one is a fishing attack second is a
spear fishing attack and a third is a
veiling attack now fishing attack is
basically a generic attack it is
targeted To The World At Large whoever
Falls pre to that attack will be a
victim whereas a spear fishing attack is
a targeted attack towards a specific
individual or a group of individuals or
towards an organization so there is a
lot more research that goes into spear
fishing where you analyze the victim you
try to figure out what the
vulnerabilities are and you tailor make
or you customize the attack to that
particular vulnerability once you have
that attack you launch it against those
people those people will then fall prey
to this attack and a veiling attack is
where you're
attacking uh top level Executives so the
C Level Executives of an organization
politicians movie stars wealthy and
powerful people uh so any of these
people when they're attacked it will be
known as a veiling attack next question
what is man in the- Middle attack now
this is something that we had touched
base when we talked about ARP where the
ARP poisoning attack needs to be
executed to leverage a man in the middle
attack now in the man in the middle
attack the attacker attacking computer
takes the IP address of the client
unaware of this the server continues to
communicate with the attacker now if you
remember in a previous question we have
also talked about spoofing so in this
scenario uh attacker has spoofed their
IP address to replicate themselves as a
genuine client and now with that
spoofing in mind they might either
through a r poisoning attack or just
because of the spoofed IP address
become a man in the middle that means
that they are now e dropping on the
conversation between the actual client
and the server by posing themselves as a
server in this scenario the attacker is
now a go between between the client and
the server and can e drop and can copy
the data if they want they can modify
the data as well so as as you can see on
the screen the attacker becomes man in
the middle which means that they are now
EES dropping on the conversation that is
happening between the client and the
server the next question who are
blackhead hackers and white hat hackers
the main thing is the differentiation
between a blackhead hacker and a white
head hacker now a blackhead hackers are
skilled individuals who illegally hack
into a system the motive behind such an
attack is mostly for monetary gain these
individuals are known also known as
security crackers now if you look at
your criminal hackers those who have
malicious intent those who do hacking
for the intent of personal gain or for
the a matter of disruption the main
thing that blackhead hackers lack is
authorization they are not authorized to
do the activity that they are about to
do and they're going to get unauthorized
access to devices or to data which is
going to cause losses to the
organization involved whereas on the
other side a whad hacker are are also
known as ethical hackers these are the
individuals who discover vulnerabilities
in a computer
network and they help the oran
organizations mitigate these
vulnerabilities they help the
organizations defend themselves from
blackhead hackers so the main difference
between these two types of hackers a
black hat and a white hat is the intent
and the authorization so black hat
hackers will have malicious intent they
will try to personally gain from that
attack from by finding out V abilities
they also will not have authorization to
conduct whatever activity they are doing
whereas on the other side whad hackers
will be hired by organizations they will
be provide authorization for certain
activity that the white hacker can do to
find out those vulnerabilities once
those vulnerabilities have been find out
found out by the whad hacker they will
report it to the management and guide
them in implementing security controls
to mitigate those vulnerabilities the
main difference between a black hat and
a white hat is the authorization and the
intent the next question what are honey
pots now honey Poots are a very
interesting device that can be
introduced in a network
uh these basically are decoy servers
that are implemented in a network to
attract the attention of a attacker it
is there to lure an attacker uh into uh
attacking that particular device thus
creating a security blanket blanket for
the rest of the devices so if an
attacker has been able to bypass a
firewall and is now trying to scan a
particular Network when they Scan they
will come across various devices that
are there in the network they will will
then proceed to do a avilability scan on
these devices the honey part at that
point in time will provide as an prove
as an attraction to these attackers
because it will demonstrate some
vulnerabilities to the hacker which will
divert their attention so these
vulnerabilities are simulated on these
devices these actually do not exist but
the moment the attacker then starts
interacting with the Honeypot the honey
poot will identify that as a malicious
traffic and will warm the warn the
administrator about a possible attack
that is going on the administrator will
then investigate through the honey pod
of what activity is going on and then
reconfigure the security controls to
block the attacker or mitigate the
attack itself right so it is more of a
decoy server uh that will showcase or
simulate some vulnerabilities to an
attacker thus to lure them and Safeguard
the rest of the network these are the 10
questions for cyber security in the next
video we'll be talking about
cryptography the first question Define
cryptography encryption and decryption
now
cryptography is used by Security
Professionals to scramble data into
non-readable format uh which is used in
securing that
information so it involves converting
data from a readable format into a non-
readable format and then reversing it
back to readable format again for
example the word computer is now
scrambled into looking like a unreadable
format now if you look at this word that
it has been scrambled led into it would
be very difficult for a human to figure
out what the actual word was now in this
scenario we have taken an algorithm
where we have made a shift of the
alphabet where we have added two
alphabets the current one so C + 2
becomes e o + 2 becomes q m + 2 becomes
o so we have done a shift of two and
thus the key over here for this
algorithm is the alphabet plus two so
any person who figures that out will be
able to unscramble this and convert this
back into readable text the fact of
scrambling a readable text Data into
something that is unreadable by using a
particular key is What cryptography is
all about now as we discussed the
decryption again is uh replacing the
alphabet and taking it further back by
two characters so e minus 2 becomes C Q
- 2 becomes o o - 2 becomes M and so on
so forth so anybody who knows this key
uh the shift
key anybody will able to decrypt this
particular character so this depends on
the user if I want to utilize alphabet +
5 then the spacing the shifting of that
character will be the fifth character
from that particular character and so on
so
forth the next question what is the
difference between Cipher text and clear
text Cipher text refers to the text
which is encrypted and totally
undesirable the message received after
decryption is known as clear text this
text is comprehensible so the word
computer is clear text that means that
it has not been treated to any
cryptographic measures it is what it is
intended to be however if the moment we
encrypt it that means we scramble it
into unreadable text by using any of the
algorithms that we'll be looking at that
text is known as a cipher text
and without the key this becomes
unreadable the clear text as discussed
is the plain word that we have utilized
we are using the English language in
this instance so the plain word computer
is the clear text once we add the
encryption layer to it uh we get the
cipher text to
it moving on to the next question what
is a block Cipher this refers to the
method of encrypting the plane message
block by block the plane message is
broken down into to fix size blocks and
then encrypt it now a block Cipher is
normally used for data that is stored so
a data that is stored on a hard disk and
we want to encrypt that data that is
known as block encryption or a block
Cipher so a block Cipher is an algorithm
that will allow you to encrypt data that
is stored onto a hard disk so in this
example we've got uh plain text which is
64 bits in size and we have added a
layer of encryption to it so plain text
plus the key that we have studied in the
previous questions and then The
Scrambled data out of it which is
unreadable and thus encrypted then the
next question what is public key
infrastructure now the public key
infrastructure is a set of policies
which secures the communication between
a server and a client it uses two
cryptographic keys public and private so
the infrastructure itself is a set of
policies people procedures and
techniques which are standardized in
nature and are globally accepted which
allow us to use digital certificates to
encrypt data and decrypt the data uh at
the other end we use a symmetric
encryption over here which means that we
are used two keys one is a public key to
encrypt and the private key to
decrypt the other part of encryption is
a symmetric encryption where the same
key is used to encrypt and the same key
is used to
decrypt now in a public key
infrastructure uh like I said we have
standardized that so in in the
standardizing part of it these are the
various players that have been defined
in the public key infrastructure the
first is the user or the sender in the
scenario the one who requires this
digital signature to digitally sign a
particular transaction or a
communication a registration Authority
with whom they're going to register for
that particular key the certification
Authority who issues that key the
verification Authority who validates the
uh key itself and the recipient who is
going to be the other party of that
particular transaction so how is this
utilized a sender or the user who
requires this digital signature will
request or apply for a digital signature
with the registration Authority the
registration Authority would validate
the genuinity of the user so they might
do some uh identity verification or uh
proof of residence or something like
that once they've identified the person
and they have validated the information
they will then send the request to the
certification Authority stating that the
sender has been validated and we can and
the certification Authority can issue
the digital certificate to the
particular
user they will send the public key to
the sender which will be utilized by the
sender for a further transactions so
when the sender is going to sign some
data and uh wants to send it across to
the recipient they will use the public
key to sign it and send it across the
recipient will then validate with the
very verification authority to see if
the data the sign data is correct or not
now while the certification Authority
sends the public key to the sender the
certification Authority updates the
private key with the verification
Authority so whatever is signed by the
uh sender uh received by the recipient
and they want to validate it they will
send it back to the verification
Authority the verification Authority
will validate using the private key once
the private key is validated it will
then send the okay signal back to the
recipient does allowing the validation
of that particular
transaction if the signature is tampered
with or is not uh the verification
Authority is not able to validate the
signature it will then send a denial
message back to the recipient and the
transaction will not go through so the
pki enables trusted digital identities
for people so the pki grants secure
access to digital resources based on the
infrastructure that has been created and
the core of the pki is a certification
Authority which ensures that the
trustworthiness of the Digital Data is
ensured so going back to the previous
slide these are the key players that
have been standardized in the public key
infrastructure the certification
Authority is the authority that issues
the digital certificates the validation
Authority is the one who validates that
uh digital certificate moving on what is
RSA RSA is one of the first public key
crypto systems that is used for secure
data transmission it stands for revest
Shamir and Adelman now these are the
three people who have created this
algorithm Ron reest ADI Shamir and
Leonard Edelman who are the inventors of
this technique it is a asymmetric
cryptography algorithm which works on
both public and private Keys hence the
encryption key is public and the
decryption key is kept private now as we
have discussed earlier symmetric and
asymmetric cryptography symmetric
cryptography is where the same key is
used to encrypt and decrypt whereas
asymmetic cryptography is where there
are two keys to encrypt and decrypt the
algorithm what are the few alternatives
to RSA now RSA is an algorithm that is
used for encryption there are a lot of
other algorithms that can be utilized uh
to alter or to scramble data depending
on your requirements so in the previous
question we have studied and we have
talked about what RSA is it stands for R
Shamir and adma the three creators of
that particular algorithm but there are
a lot of alternatives to this algorithm
depending on how secure you want that
data to be and some of them are listed
here on your screen Duo security OCTA
Google Authenticator and last pass last
pass is a password
manager so is Doo security Google
authentica is something that we all
utilize it is an application that we can
download and store on our mobile devices
and we can set that up to authenticate
ourselves with certain portals so it
issues uh unique ID to us which once
utilized will allow us access to those
particular portals OCTA is an identity
manager where you have you have created
different digital identities and you
have assigned them certain permissions
and based on your authentication
mechanisms OCTA will allow or disallow
access to those different applications
or different portals as you have
configured it so all four are
authorization authentication mechanisms
which can be used as alternatives to RSA
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit scaleup by simply learn click
on the link in the description to know
more next question what are the prime
objectives of modern cryptography and
this is a very important question
because we've we've so far looked at
what cryptography is and what public
infrastructure is but what is the
achievement out of it why are we
utilizing it and what do we want to uh
gain out of it so the main and the prime
object objectives of modern cryptography
are uh as follows mentioned on your
screen the first one is
confidentiality the second one is
non-repudiation third one is
authenticity and the fourth one is
integrity now if I go back to the first
one confidentiality uh that is where I
want to uh keep data confidential that
means it will only be visible to the
authorized users right so here I have
created a list of people who have deemed
as authorized users and I've created a
digital identity to them and have given
access controls to those people now that
is how confidentiality is ensured so uh
when we want to keep data confidential
we create a list of users who we are
going to allow access to certain
resources and we are going to Define
what access controls are to be utilized
what access are allowed whether they got
an administrative access or user level
access and only those authorized users
are going to be uh able to access this
resources that is how we maintain in
confidentiality the next one is non-
reputation non- reputation is the
prevention of denial of having being a
part of that particular transaction so
in the publicy infrastructure that we
discussed where a digital signature was
utilized to sign a particular
transaction and then sent to the
recipient the sender would not be able
to deny of having gen originated that
transaction because it was using their
digital certificate thus non- reputation
comes with the picture uh one more
example that we can have here is uh on
our mobile phones when we use SMS short
messaging service and we send a message
to uh to another person the person when
they receive a message the number is
validated by the service operator and
thus the sender cannot uh deny having
sent that message the sender at the same
time can have a delivery report sent to
them uh from that the message was
delivered to the inbox of the recipient
and thus if the recipient Den having
received that message that delivery
report becomes proof of having that
message being delivered to their inbox
thus both the parties cannot deny of
have a of being a part of that
particular
transaction then comes the part of
authenticity now in confidentiality we
have created a digital identity assigned
it to a particular person and we have
given them digital signatures where they
cannot deny having being a part of that
transaction but authentic is the part
where they try to prove that they are
who they claim to be so if I'm claiming
a digital identity I have to prove that
I am that person who I'm Who I'm trying
to claim to be and an example to that is
when we go to our gmail.com websites it
first asks us what is our username our
username is normally our email address
which identifies the account that we are
trying to access right so this account
is confidential because it is only
authorized for a particular person and
and once they identify themselves by
identifying the email address that's
when the authentication part comes into
the picture where it asks for the
password now it has never ever happened
that we just go on to the gmail.com type
in a password and then it figures out
which account we are talking about so
the first step is always the
confidentiality part where we identify
which account we are talking about and
then we try to authenticate as the owner
of that particular account by providing
the appropriate password to that account
if both of these match only then do we
get access to that account and we are
able to make uh whatever transactions we
want to make now when we are making
those transactions non reputation comes
into the place where all our activities
also being logged so we have identified
our account we have authenticated
ourselves by providing the password so
the proof is there that it is us who are
trying to access it and then whatever
activity we do send an email receive an
email delete something attach something
all of those activities are logged and
stored as proof of what actions have
been done so tomorrow if we deny having
sent that email gmail can still prove to
us through those logs that the that that
activity was done by
us and the fourth part is in Integrity
which ensures that the data received and
sent and the re uh sent by the sender
and received by the recipient has not
been modified while in uh motion so the
Integrity part is the trustworthiness of
that data that that data has not been
modified by any hacker or any other uh
entity and is still trustworthy so these
are the four Prime objectives of modern
cryptography once I have scramble that
data
using my public uh signature it is only
my private signature that is going to
decrypt it right uh using these
mechanisms I will be able to achieve all
these four aspects of cryptography and
security next question what is safer now
safer stands for secure and fast
encryption routin team which is also a
block Cipher as we have discussed pre
previously block Cipher is a cipher that
is used to encrypt data that is stored
so it has a 64-bit block size and bite
oriented algorithm uh safer encryption
and decryption procedures are highly
secure this technology is widely used in
applications like digital payment card
so when you're using your a digital
payment gateway to make transactions so
you have you have gone onto an online
portal you want to purchase a particular
item and then it takes you to another
payment Gateway where you have to fill
in your credit card information
sensitive information like your uh
expiry dates CVV information and then
the OTP or the password that you have
created for your particular account now
all of these need to be secured or
highly secured based on PCI DSS which is
the payment card industry data security
standard so these standards ensure that
certain Protocols are utilized to attain
that level of security safer is one of
those block ciphers that is used under
the digital payment Gateway
infrastructure next question how does
the public infrastructure public key
infrastructure work now we have already
discussed this in the previous diagrams
uh we have identified the key players
the certification Authority the
registration Authority the end user who
requires the digital certificate the
validation Authority who's going to
validate it and then the recipient the
end user with whom the transaction is
going to be
uh conducted so the first point here is
uh the request for the digital
certificate is sent to the registration
Authority they validate it and then they
okay to the certification Authority who
then process the request and the digital
certificate is issued to the person who
has requested it so when the person
wants to conduct that transaction they
use that uh digital certificate to sign
that transaction with the end user the
end user validates that with the
validation Authority and once validated
the transaction goes through and now the
last question what is the Bluefish
algorithm it is a 64-bit symmetric
encryption algorithm so this is an
algorithm that uses the same key to
encrypt and the same key to decrypt the
same secret Keys used to encrypt and
decrypt the messages here the operations
are based on exclusive ORS and additions
to on 32bit Words the key has a maximum
length of 448 bits now this is a little
bit technical uh you might not want to
go this technical in an uh in an
interview question you just need to
identify what the algorithm is used for
so whether it is a symmetric algorithm
which means it uses the same key or a a
symmetric algorithm where it uses a
public key to encrypt and a p private
key to decrypt uh thus the Blowfish
algorithm is just one more algorithm uh
which uses symmetric encryption to
encrypt and decrypt data algorithms that
we have seen RSA and the others that we
have discussed as far as the interview
questions are concerned what we need to
remember is uh which algorithms are
symmetric which algorithms are symmetric
what do symmetric algorithms do and what
do unsymmetric asymmetric algorithms do
and we also look at block ciphers and
stream ciphers block ciphers are
utilized to encrypt data that is stored
stationary data data at rest and stream
ciphers are utilized for data in motion
while they're being streamed so SSL and
TLS is another algorithm that comes into
the picture when we looking at streaming
data so here we wrap up cyber security
course for beginners if you have any
questions add it in the comment section
and our experts will be happy to help
stay tuned with simply learn for latest
updates in cyber security thanks for
watching staying ahead in your career
requires continuous learning and
upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in Cutting Edge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here